[Music]
[Applause]
round four of the 2016 US chess
championships it was a huge round with a
much anticipated Marquee matchup as US
champion Hikaru Nakamura was gunning for
the win against his main rival Fabiano
Carana but his opening Choice backfired
as Fabby played a fantastic game to take
over soulle first place in the
tournament on the Ladi side teenager
Jennifer Yu played the role of spoiler
as she defeated Co leer Carissa Yip to
NAB her first win seven time Champion
Arena Crush showed why she's the odds on
favorite to dominate the event once
again when she rolled over teenager AATA
kkev to move into a tie for the lead
it's the day before the rest day and the
players will be giving it their all
round five starts right
[Music]
now
welcome everybody to the fifth round of
the US championship and US Women's
Championship we see some of the players
just getting ready for their fifth round
round game it's going to be an important
one it is the round before the rest day
and it's usually a bloody one here at
the US championship in the US
Championship everybody's talking about
Fabiano corana three and a half out of
four a fantastic performance but let's
not forget that he's being chased by two
very strong players with three out of
four and in the women's section we have
an incredibly close tournament fantastic
ground there Anna satony will be playing
against tyena crush a classical match up
in this tournament and T abrahamian will
be playing against Katan andova two of
the favorites of this event fantastic
games here before the rest day and for
analysis of that we'll go to the panel
with Jen Yas and
Maurice thank
you yes good to be here with you
Jennifer yes it's wonderful in our fifth
round now tomorrow we have a rest day so
will it be combative lullabi round or
party time round uh combative all the
way yes the players know that they get a
rest tomorrow so they often give their
all let's take a look at the standings
in the usj championship as Alejandro
alluded to we do have a clear leader
Fabiano caroan he's got three and a half
and he is showing some marvelous chest
here at the US Championship so far half
a point behind we've got Ray Robson and
Wesley cell Sam chanin also doing quite
well Nakamura unfortunately for the
dynamic player with so many fans only on
an even score but you know he's ready to
string some wings together will he start
today while it goes to show the
competitive nature of the event and how
strong his opposition is that the
defending Champion only has a 50% score
after four that's right meanwhile in the
Women's Championship whove got three
players Ty for first so a very tight
battle there Maji pidi and K abrahami
and along with Irina crush the defending
Champion the seven time Champion all TI
for first Anna zatonski and chrisa Yip
just half a point behind but we' got
some herings today that are going to be
really exciting a lot of drama in these
pairings starting with the championship
we've had a very dramatic battle between
Wesley so and veru niobian you guys
remember what happened last year if you
don't we're going to refresh your memory
throughout the broadcast exactly and
hikaro Nakamura looking for his comeback
against Sam Shanklin he's going to have
to really turn on and play a great game
shabala fortime US champion going up
against the debut ton and leader of our
tournament ooh that's going to be a
great game he promised the shav off
smash meanwhile in the Women's
Championship it might be listed last
year but it is not least we've got Arena
Crashers Anna zatonski an epic battle
that we always look forward to in the
Women's Championship that truly is the
Marquee uh game at the tournament I'm
looking forward to a great game in that
uh on that board that's right so lots of
excitement today but Maurice what do you
expect what are we going to see today
well if it's anything like the first
four rounds this round should be
spectacular we've seen Fighting Chess up
and down play upsets everything that you
want out of a tournament and today we
expect even more first of all this big
matchup on the on the open side you see
Alexander shabalov shaba we call him he
loves to attack a king and he plays
every game for the win he's going to
have his hands full against Fabiano
Carana fabulous Fabby who's playing just
absolutely beautiful chess right now
looking to All rights Like A Champion
we'll see whether or not he'll be able
to stop the shabas storm in this game
and on the ladies side well this is
absolutely a centilating matchup since
2006 these ladies have been responsible
for the last 10 championships between
them it's just these ladies Arena crush
a seven time champ and a zatonski a four
time champ this should just be a great
game as Arena has a slim half a point
lead Anna knows she's got to Nick Arena
because if the championship train goes
Arena Crush usually runs over everybody
on her tracks we'll see how this round
five goes an exciting round to come as
the players come into the Hall game
about to start in a few minutes thank
you Maurice and then in that Anna versus
um uh Arena match you know that they've
played 15 times in different time
controls in the US championship that's
got to be some kind of a record of a
competition between two players what's
our format for the tournament I think
you know the answer to that we got an 11
game round robin and both Fields um
almost $300,000 in prize money and
playoffs if there are any ties so don't
worry no silly math tie breaks in around
Robin where everybody plays everybody we
will see blood spilled but today it's
going to be a real thrill
to see who might set themselves apart in
the Women's Championship and who might
start to uh nip it Fabiano's heels in
the championship yes well again that
that field in the Women's Championship
is so tight and that tatev uh game is
going to be crucial and don't forget uh
naagi undefeated she just keeps chew
chewing right along and she could get
into the mix with the wind as well so
that that is a really tough uh one to
call I understand we're going to be
taking a poll uh during the show uh from
our audience as to who they think is
going to be the Champions that's right
you can vote on who you think is going
to win the Women's Championship and
who's going to win the championship um
tweet us your guess that the St chess
club and Classic Center St Louis there
actually is a poll so go on to the uh
CCS CSL page now remember if you just
pick the favorite then you might win but
it doesn't mean as much right kind of
like if you play an NCAA pool and you
just pick the favorite
Kentucky and you know yeah that's too
easy right that's too easy and here
we've got a gotsky playing against
Jeffrey Jang Jeffrey Jang so far
undefeated will he um continue his
impressive play here at the championship
wow I I really love that photo of um ho
youan right in the background there
that's right I mean just a such a
wonderful player and you know speaking
of strong female players who are also
successful in mixed Fields um Maggie
Fang just won the US junior high school
championship first woman ever to do it
wow pretty impressive big shout out to
her congratulations Maggie and here we
got Carissa Yip who has also broken all
sorts of Records even the record for the
youngest expert in America the youngest
expert she became an expert at 9 years
old oo
wow I didn't know that they were keeping
track of that record yeah they do keep
youth versus youth in this one though
isn't it yeah well um Agata 16 and uh
Carissa Yip 12 we see them laughing
giggling before the games get
started tomorrow actually we have a
special event that all the women are
participating in where they're going to
be playing bug house and bullet and all
sorts of yes Blitz they're actually
going to be playing Blitz with an allh
chess set so that's like Ona set well
they're not actually going to be playing
Blitz with that one cuz of course that's
an art chest set so right thr those
patties as you like to say might be a
little bit painful for Yoko but um they
are going to be playing an all-white set
so it's kind of in between um blindfold
and real chess in a way cuz of course
you still have the pieces but they're
all the same color might it might throw
you off to see the pieces and blindfold
you can keep it separated in your mind
oh I don't know I think it would be
easier to play with an allwhite chess
set than to play blindfold what do you
think I'm not sure might might might be
more disturbing but we'll find out yeah
I guess we will and we we'll find out
when the fers and there they are getting
bigs um and we've got Maurice with his
thoughts on as we getting in the very
first moves of this opening games you
know what fascinates me about this round
as I look at all the matchups on the big
board is that there are no boards
absolutely no boards in either section
where you see a likely draw or someone
who's think thinking I just want to draw
today it looks like everyone who's
playing is looking for something you
looking there going to be a sharp game
no matter what the match up between
Wesley so and varujan akobian that one
was contentious last year as Wesley lost
a forfeited because of no taking you
look at Onish truk versus akat Shandra
he wants to defeat the youngster does
Onish chuk absolutely expect a sharp
game jeffre Jong against gsky that game
got knows he's got to come back he's
going to have to beat the youngster if
he's going to come back back in the
competition of course shabala versus
Carana we know shaba goes for the win in
every position and Fabiano will be
looking for a fight Ray Robson against
Lenderman another big time matchup
that's going to be sharp probably Ray
Ray is going to get in some time
pressure at some point and Naru Nakamura
against Sam Shanklin to round out the
open side you know hikaro wants to win
today he lost yesterday he's looking for
the win no matter what same thing on the
ladies side when you look at it you see
Arena Crush versus zatonski Zoni knows
if she doesn't make a move now Arena
could just keep going and going and
going Nazi pidi big Edge rating wise
there Alyssa mikina over Gort Alyssa
with the white pieces will play for the
win Sabina voer again the youngster
playing against her as is won that's
going to be another matchup Carissa Yip
AATA KV they're too young to think about
draws let's get some points and finally
karita mova against tatev Abraham Yan
tatev did get nicked for a half a point
earlier in the tournament when she was
completely winning and Katarina has lost
a game and then drawn a game that she
was winning so she's feeling like I've
got to get back in this tournament so
I'm looking at 12 games with 12 likely
attempts anyway at decisive results so
we should see that be uh be a great game
we have some special guests guests in
the in attendance kids coming from
Ferguson uh taking a look at the games
it's always wonderful when we have kids
coming in to watch and that that young
young man you see right there I for I
don't know his name but he was stroking
his chin right yeah we zoom in he's a
third grade champ of his school and when
I asked them if they thought they could
beat me you should have seen how many
hands went up no no respect no respect
somebody's a fan of tatev Abraham on in
that photo um rocking the purple hair
just like
Tates there we go I mean that can't be a
coincidence right that is remarkable for
sure I just wanted to say too what I
found interesting at the when when we
had our opening shots of the players I
hadn't realized it that Jeffrey really
one of the young is he the youngest oh
or he is the youngest no uh yeah Jeffrey
is the youngest I try right uh playing
against one of the oldest players in the
tournament the oldest the oldest oh no
no no sorry shabalov is the oldest right
uh five time uh US champion uh godsky
has essayed the very rarely seen um
alakin defense uh in that game so
very uh KY decision by G because I'm
pretty sure that the alakin defense was
not in jeffy's preparation for this
particular game coming into the match of
course it's in his General preparation
though yes in the general preparation
only though all right shall we go to our
top board our leader uh Fabiana caruana
uh up against Alexander ball off hey
shabalov promised us a shabalov smash I
thought that was going to be E4 F4 can
he plays G3 and B G2 that sounds like a
virgin
terer not like a not a tropical drink
that I was
expecting true a little bit uh um well
off the beaten path here for shabby if
shabby is going to throw down the
gauntlet uh he's doing it in a very tame
way at the start Don't Call Him shabby
it's shaba shabby doesn't sound right I
always like shabby because I always I
like term that um V Victor spil often
cited not too shabby ah so that's well
then you have to say not too shabby
shaba not too shabby shaba okay so uh
both sides Fe and shadowed in that game
uh nothing too surprising as we take our
Look Around the Horn we have the
Rubenstein French defense played by
verian no Scandinavian today for VAR as
he essays his favorite French defense
and trades in the center and very
well-known uh position
Theory um and in the game of Ray Robson
versus Alexander Lenderman we're seeing
a lot of Knight f3s in kingside fien
chettos for white I told you it could be
the Le bu round and I'm just kidding
yeah the even even if somebody plays 903
it doesn't mean that they're uh content
with a draw just a different type of
struggle yes and often times so
transpositional that that can come right
back into a queen Pawn yeah exactly I
mean that's what the confusing thing I
think that that trips a lot of players
up when they phone and plays Knight F3
or C4 they have trouble making sure that
they don't get tricked into playing an
opening that they wouldn't normally play
exactly exactly they do it for
transpositional move orders aaroon in
the uh game between hikaro Nakamura and
Sam Shanklin so this is the two knights
two knights variation Bishop G4 H3 quick
captures E6 G3 I always thought that
that wasn't the right move order for
white G3 I think after Knight
F6 uh it's a very easy equality now for
black after Knight F6 the the key point
is that this ending pardon me after
Bishop G2 captures captures captures
captures Queen D5
and I just consider this ending after a
trade of Queens to be completely
balanced and even you know would be
really epic if Wesley so now went into
the confessional booth and said Focus
concentrate and you're referring to of
course their last year's matchup where
basically uh Wesley was forfeited very
early in the game as he had written on
his scorese sheet those words that you
just mentioned Focus concentrate um
after warnings after warnings that he
was not allowed to take notes on his
score sheets but he didn't understand
the warnings of course because he had
used a separate piece of paper not his
scet to take his notes he just uh but
it's it wasn't allowed and here we have
a from last year's uh us
Championship a real pivotal moment huge
Arbiter Tony Rich stopped the clogs
um asked Wesley about a score sheet and
the players eventually adjourned to the
boardroom where discussion ensued and
very very very reluctantly Tony Rich The
Arbiter uh felt compelled to
Forfeit Wesley so so no love loss
between these two not best buds as they
play their first matchup since that game
took place but of course they did shake
hands
today not enemies but I think there's
still a little extra history and you
know desire to win on both players
thoughts today of course of course no
you have a very strong desire they're
well they're Gladiators they're
competitors um I just referring back to
a moment of our game uh between hikara
Nakamura and Sam Shanklin we already
spoke at the opening of the show how
crucial this point is going to be for
hikaru's campaign um and I mentioned
the move Bishop G2 if you go back and
you you play the move D2 D3 to avoid
that end game I just uh
expressed spoke about then you have this
move Bishop B4 and after Bishop
D2
D4 get there Knight D2 you have moves
like Queen B6 but if you just go for the
straight forward stuff takes takes C5 I
think that this is or even E5 for me I
think E5 is more precise I beg your
pardon I think that this is just fine
position for black so I don't think in
the opening hikaro is going to get any
advantage if Sam plays the move Knight
F6 who are currently at this position
and I'm expecting Knight
F6 shall we go to the ladies matchup
yeah let's check out Arena vers Anna
how's that opening shaping up absolutely
well again just mentioned earlier they
have played 50
times in US championships featuring
different formats because they had that
huge
Armageddon uh which was a cause of a lot
of dissension between between these two
fine uh ladies and let's throw back to
that moment go back to when their big
Armageddon showdown from the 2008 US
Championship Oklahoma
Oklahoma the players are very short on
time
no increments no
increments we
have very rapid move and this shows the
benefit of being black when you're
playing a blitz
Dam you might get the black pieces but
the comes closer to you I
mean come on it's closer to your
dominant hand we see her knocking the
piece away there I think they're still
trying to find that uh King by the way
that that went off the oh that'll be
worth a lot of money yeah be the king
yes but here you see them in a far more
cool calm collected set setting where uh
they're very carefully considering each
and every move well that would never
happen again because even in her playoff
um and Anna has made like some I think
it was yeah against Irena she didn't she
she did make a huge blender in a playoff
ones that I think cost her um her fifth
title um she did you remember that she
like hung a rook in some situation yes
yes I had to console her after the game
from the blue I mean just like
completely crazy and I think if she
hadn't have done that she probably would
have won that Championship exactly so
but that being said we are using
increments even in the um armagedon
games really we we always use incr 53
and well the way it works it's like that
right that bidd yes exactly cuz cuz you
just don't want somebody to I mean it's
fun in a way great for for spectators
but it's going to be great for
spectators even with an increment in
fact some people argue that Blitz with
an increment is more exciting because
that two second increment can elongate
the struggle so they're just basically
playing Blitz for like they are playing
Blitz for like 10 minutes rather than
like it being kind of slower and then
like only the last couple minutes and
somebody loses on time in a way it's
actually kind of
anticlimactic well not that that not
that one not that one but you know what
I'm saying like sometimes the increment
can actually make things more exciting
Different Strokes for different folks
you're you're a delay guy or a sudden
death guy yeah I'm sudden death you're a
sudden death guy yeah for sure no no no
if I Maurice is a sudden death guy too
um we're going to go to
Maurice I'm definitely a sudden death
guy that increment stuff is for the
birds you see watch the point the
seconds going up and up and up and up
and up and the fans can't appreciate
that well I guess the chess fans the
diard chess fans do but not the average
fans at any rate that's a that's a
debate we'll have it seems for quite
some time but I'd like to show you guys
this position just backing up to this
moment in the game between Karissa Yip
and Agata bosev and this to me is the
opening of the round so far this is a
kind of opening we'd love to see in all
the boards just like thematic let's just
play this one all the time because right
now the move G4 appeared on the board a
sicilian as we've seen a bishop G5
naidorf Sicilian main line line and
they're in it right now and in this
position the typical move is B7 to B5
striking on the queen side preparing to
bring the bishop to the B7 square
instead this move Rook B8 now B5 has
been played over 3,000 times in the
database Rook B8 about 78 times so a
minuscule number of moves and yet
Karissa played Bishop to H4 Bishop F6
this position uh has been seen a few
times but Bishop F6 is the most popular
move so you can get G5 and she decided
to keep her Bishop with the bishop to H4
that prompted the move G6 and G5 she
surged ahead Knight to H5 and now F5
definitely steaming forward with her
attack Knight to E5 Queen to
F2 played in the game and this position
has only been seen once before and
they're both just throwing down moves
the move B5 still following a game where
black Steam red white and it looks as
though Kissa is in the position now it's
her turn to move after this move B5 if I
remember correctly yes the game ran A3
B4 takes takes Bishop H3 and after C and
after
castles castles takes on E6 takes on E6
Bishop takes check takes Knight takes
forking these two pieces black commonly
play Queen A5 and after Knight takes
Rook black ignored everything and played
Knight to C4 and suddenly the threats of
the position were just dominant for
black this Knight is irrelevant it's all
about Ma on this side this check
followed by taking was just too
overwhelming an idea white played the
move Queen D4 and after Knight to F4
making sure this Knight cannot move
because of this KN Fork suddenly white
was completely busted and on the next
move Knight takes B2 happened but this
is all over now but the crying because
of just This ferocious attack as Queen
both all these pieces are ganging up on
the king so at the moment we have this
position here on the board and I don't
know what her preparation is Karissa but
she is in that position that was played
once before and agate in the meantime
has blitzed out her moves so she only
she's only used well you know it's funny
one she's at 129 and 13 seconds normally
we would say she's only us 47 seconds
but since she's getting a 30 second
increment on every single move she's
clearly used more time than that maybe
recalling her preparation now that last
move I talked about Bishop H3 that was
played in the game need not be played
and it's a good thing that Carissa is
pausing right now to check out all the
counterplay the engines are giving the
unusual but typical idea Bishop to E2
unusual only because it ignores this
threat of B4 with the maneuver Knight to
B1 as being better for white so Kissa is
going to have to estimate this position
because most most of us playing Sicilian
would not want to put our Knight on B1
we'd like to put it maybe to D5
sometimes to E2 and even sometimes to A4
although he doesn't look good in this
position so a strange position for her
to work out uh Karissa will she might if
I'm if I'm thinking like a human she
might think about a move like Knight to
E2 I don't know if this is any good at
all uh the engine saying yeah actually
not a bad move I'll uh Rush myself off
of
that well done mace well done well
done well I I find it interesting that
these two very young inexperienced
players are willing to go down the
sharpest lines of theory instead of
playing you know safe solid moves that
sort of like they really want to play
tactical uh moves uh forcing tactical
moves where their
preparation perhaps is an
ascendency interesting game wow all
right I just uh again I'll bring us back
to the Fabi Alexander shabala Fabiana
Carana game for a moment because it has
been exceptionally tame um we now see
now we see a double fee in CED by white
and after this move C takes D5
anticipating C takes D5 by no means
Force but then it has all of those
Contours of an exchange slav which has a
notorious VAR uh reputation in top chess
for being a draw because there's no
imbalances in the positions uh both both
sides just play good moves and you just
trade a lot of pieces and the draws
often times the result this shav smash I
don't know may maybe woke up on the
wrong side of the bed today and just
decided to play a very solid game with
white maybe of course he of course ja
can go both ways in that way I just I
just thought uh the he was the one who
promised the shavala Smasher do we make
that up either way I think we did a
prompting okay gotcha yeah very good so
um not not a drink that's going to get
into my repertoire I don't think right
so what do we have here this is a game
of Jennifer G3 Sicilian a g well it's a
dragon uh well it was a nidorf attempt
to be a narf that's soon transposed into
that happens a lot when they play G3
against a nid if you see people playing
uh this move G6 the thing is normally we
can't play A6 and G6 because it's so
slow right right but when our opponent
plays one of the less sharp variations
like for instance with a bishop B2 or a
G3 sometimes we have that chance to
being K our Bishop anyway right and I
always felt that castle and kingside was
a little soft for Dragon players they're
not uh they're not being placed under a
fearsome attack right off the bat
exactly and Maurice speaking of fearsome
attacks right off the bat take a look at
this position yes I know you like the
French was one in your repertoire you
going to have to comment on this kind of
French after Wesley so play this with
the white pieces Bishop D3 castles Queen
C2 threatening to take on F6 and then
take on H7 and so H6 was played but this
move certainly suggests to White the
idea of G4 and G5 opening up this side
you've got two steaming Bishops just
look at that those that Bishops on that
diagonal they're piercing Down The Long
diagonals and white could consider
castling in this position of course
giving black some counterplay Rook to D1
is also possible for some reason I do
get attracted to this move castles right
now realizing that I can put my king on
B1 at any moment and with the plan of G4
G5 y you've got to tell me because as an
attacking player wanting an open game I
really like white but I know you have
defended this kind of French position
before what's your estimation of Wesley
so's chances excellent actually I I may
have defended it but I didn't like it I
didn't like it one bit let me tell you
something and those two Bishops on D4
and D3 are so menacing uh eyeballing
Black's King uh basically I see Wesley
is getting a free shot at var's King he
hasn't sacrificed a darn thing and he's
just got a great uh buildup for cating
attack I agree very very strongly
Castle's long move your king to B1 and
just toss out the patties with Rook G1
and G4 G5 looks like Wesley is going to
have a real
um charge in that game mean I will wish
be wishing that he could play the move
H6 to H7 at some point right to take it
back so having said all of that my
understanding is that the move Bishop E3
again this is old thing is that you
don't trade and just encourage white to
post his Bishop on this fantastic Square
on D4 you're supposed to again old think
play the move Knight D5 maybe it just
tactically doesn't work as a bishop B5
check in
95 um sorry uh he may have uh felt that
this
variation uh would be good for white I'm
again I'm not too certain about that
because Knight takes E3 and it's it's a
wild uh Affair but
just out that that Queen A4 check might
become menacing yeah but this looks this
looks really warm really not fun not fun
one at all I mean it's very clear that
White's just posting his pieces for a
king site attack and after castles it
just looks like this idea of Rook to G1
or just G4 straight away perhaps trying
to sacrifice in some lines it's like
it's not going to be it's not going to
be a fun Pond to take with or without uh
capturing this Pond this this
is wow I mean this is huge advantage in
my estimation for white and again he
hasn't even sacrificed upon or or
anything no counterplay that I'm uh that
I can see uh Maurice maybe the engines
can save it well the engines are too
happy either about this position but I'm
looking at the database to see how white
does in this line and this is just
pulling up chess base to see how white
does and I'm counting white winning of
the 15 games that we're seeing here as
the database uh is showing all these
moves of the 15 games I see one two
three four draws four draws one win for
black 10 wins for white 10 wins for
white why would VAR walk into this line
against Wesley so when the odds are that
he's just going to get blasted off the
board it's incredible that he chose this
particular line he maybe he has
something in mind but I can tell you
Wesley is sitting there licking his
chops seeing that King just looks so
delicious G4 G5 coming almost inexorably
like how are you going to stop this what
looks like a straight attack and we saw
how Wesley handled his attack against
gakamsky when there was even less
looking like an advantage in that
position when he sacked a piece you can
count on this young man who's the number
10 player on the planet to find some
kind of way to head straight towards
that King no question about it uh
everybody likes uh such attacking
positions and especially as they put uh
they haven't made any sacrifices to get
uh these very nice Bishops and um that
H7 H6 it's an anchor that is just
begging for uh G4 G5 yeah exactly and
sign me up for this opening I used to
not like playing the French if I could
get this position feels like I'm playing
as a Sian exactly where I have a couple
ad
mov indeed and uh this is like just uh
developing a nose for the attack um you
know for those uh viewers watching and
by the way we would like to encourage
you to give us calls we've uh really
enjoyed those uh those calls that we've
been receiving so far as in the show
this uh attack of G4 G5 um is it's it's
it's simply too
promising but will he execute it
correctly and get his full Revenge we
will find out meanwhile Maurice with an
update from the Women's Championship
just quickly remember that position we
showed where Bishop H3 happened in the
old game and led to a devastating
victory for black and we wondered
whether or not Bishop E2 challenging the
Knight very positional concept here to
play for Bishop E2 instead and and
deviating looked like a better move well
guess what the youngest player in the
competition Karissa Yip decided to play
Bishop to E2 willingly allowing the idea
of B4 where her Knight will be best
placed back on B1 and will come back
into the game on the D2 square at some
point but just very uh deep positional
chess having a feel for the position is
Carissa I'm very impressed by this move
guys Bishop to E2 allowing this play and
deviating from the main move it looks as
though she's either been doing her
preparation or she just has a really
fine sense of how to handle this type of
position and she has forced AATA now who
has been blitzing out her moves to give
pause on this New Concept amazing you
know we've criticized karissa's
positional understanding in some
previous games but the thing you have to
remember about a 12-year-old playing in
a twoe championship they act it's scary
but they actually get better during the
tournament yes I mean that's a
terrifying thing cuz she's never played
a tournament like this her positional
chess is actually going to be different
at the end than the beginning right I
remember playing my first US junior
Championship in Memphis Tennessee and I
felt that going into the event I was YZ
1.0 coming out of the event I had just
changed my understanding of Chess so
incredibly much when you're playing
against good level comp competitors
opposition you're
your experience your confidence your
knowledge your understanding just seems
to Blossom and at age 12 that's just
that's absurd that's ridiculous 12 years
old wow I mean it's a function of two
things of your brain being so spongy at
that age and also just it being your
first experience so you other players
have done it before so maybe their
talent has been actualized whereas you
have all this Talent you haven't had the
opportunity yet and then when you have
it you just you just uh shoot up so we
do have a phone call thank you um let us
know uh who you are and where you're
calling
from how's it going my name is Tyler
from New York can you guys hear me yes
yes hi Tyler cool so first I'd love to
say I love your guys' program and
Maurice needs to tell us where he's
getting these foods from there
amaz I'm not the only one who talks
about
fashion my question is I took a lesson
in the St CH from Ben fold this summer
and he said that for an under 2,000
player the best way
to improve is to eliminate mistakes um
and that is more important than finding
good moves at this level for the US
Championship how many games are won
because someone makes a good move rather
than makes a mistake um thanks for
taking my question I'll let you guys get
back to the uh to the broadcast
interesting question Tyler asks what's
more pertinent uh great moves or good
moves that win games or bad moves that
loses games I'm sorry to say I think
it's still mistakes rule if you can cut
out those mistakes and just play a lot
of normal good moves but I think
mistakes are more costly than great
attacks I totally agree and that's a
painful thing about um that blunders
it's it's so much about not it would be
like if you're if walking was about not
falling on your face that's a bit like
CH okay falling on your face I've got a
lot to look forward to don't I there I'm
making chest sound so appealing but the
thing is of course that that experience
makes you stronger and that's why it's
so good for children like knowing that
it's really so much about life is
avoiding those massive screw-ups you
know like you don't want to get into a
car accident no you know obviously it's
great to be a perfect driver but it's
much more important to never never drive
when you're drunk or tired or texting
and just make a massive error that will
ruin your life I think not to get too
dark I think not to get too dark but
chess is kind of like yeah if you if you
just never blunder that's why computers
were were good even before they were
good right even before they really had
any kind of positional understanding and
even when they had the Horizon effect
they would never actually hang a rock
yes that is true yeah as they started
getting good their their errors were
like you say the positional kind they
weren't the material loss you know just
horrifyingly hanging upon which
unfortunately even the uh Elite Grand
Masters do uh make those horrifying
mistakes now a little twist on that um
philosophical if you could um program
yourself so that you you would never
blunder anything over a bishop how many
rating points do you think that would be
worth anything over a bishop anything
over a knight anything over a knight I
mean I could never blunder not so much
because I bullet you'd be like the best
bullet play oh well by far it just like
huge it would make you a superhuman
bullet play basically absolutely no
blunders of that nature in Blitz or
bullet I was thinking more in the
classical chest in the classical way
like but for somebody who's like 15 or
1,600 that would probably add a several
hundred rating BLS at least and I think
that's what Ben was referring to at
least I mean certainly when I was an
expert I was still blundering pieces no
question about it especially in time
pressure and we do have another
caller
hello hey welcome to the show let us
know your name and where calling
from hello hey welcome to the
show hey this is Jason from New Orleans
hey we can hear you Jason let us know uh
what you want to talk
about my question regarded that um
moment between Anna and Arena and I was
wondering if there would be any traction
in us or World Chess switch to allowing
players to use computers for Armageddon
or Blitz tie
BRS what what I couldn't quite
understand it something about
computers you said something about I was
wondering if there was any traction in
US CH to allow players to do Blitz and
up again tie breaks on the computer as
opposed to the board to avoid
circumstances like happen between Arena
and few years back great question you
know I I play a lot of Poker and one of
the things I playing online the question
is using a computer to play the tiebreak
kind of like Battleship style call the
chess equip
the yes we in in poker we call this we
call this Battleship so like Irene and
Anna would still be there but they would
actually be playing on computers right
and the idea is that you can actually
make the move physically much more
quickly on the computer screen than you
can on the board in pieces so it's kind
of like a five minute game becomes like
a seven-minute game if you will and a
one minute game becomes a two-minute
game and to do this to avoid pieces
being thrown or not on the squares and
yeah and to make sure that the dgt board
picks up everything sometimes if the
player like if there's some kind of
crazy like Rook move that spills off the
board and the TD has to come in and
correct it it's it's hard for us to
follow sometimes occasionally so yeah I
actually think it's a really good idea I
mean it I know but there's something
very personable about seeing two people
play Blitz and tactile about seeing them
play head-to-head but I do agree from a
practical point of view it's not a bad
idea interesting but um yeah it's good
to think outside of the box so I really
like the question um yeah keep them
coming at our # usess ch
and also you can call in the
oldfashioned way in the oldfashioned way
okay just uh doing a quick look uh we do
have
that uh exchange slav type of position
on our for first board between uh
shabalov and uh Karana nothing happening
here guys um just uh basically a very
standard position where I'm expecting a
move such as Knight E4 O pardon me it's
black to move is it yes oh sorry Knight
C3 was uh White's last move so you just
play Rook to C8 you bring your Rook to
the open SE file and there's a usually
once again sad to say these these
positions are so dry it's very hard for
either player to upset the imbalance
without getting the worst position so
this game is very tame um moving on to
our next board again this is the we did
see cast
by by Castle's long pardon by by Wesley
so I mean a clear IND indication that
he's looking for the attacks that we've
been mentioning Queen A5 King B1 so
veran is going to try to get a little
counterplay of of his own I mean I see
two ways that he might try to do this
maybe wrenching open the uh B file with
B5 and B4 okay but do you think that's
going to be it's all it's all a matter
of time um if he tries to go for this
type of line is it going to be too slow
one thing thing I notic is that B5
actually weakens a C6 Square so we could
actually play um Knight E5 not only
promoting our move G4 but also it's the
direct threat of Knight C6 so you would
be compelled to take a time out and play
Bishop to
B7 right and this is uh essentially
heading right down that Primrose path
where uh wh's attack frankly is coming
uh like a ton of bricks much fter much
much much faster than blacks we have
time to play but let's let's let's just
play a few more moves I'll play Bishop
D5 with a little threat okay and then
you'll I'm I'm assuming I'm just going
to probably play B3 guard or uh block
the diagonal with a move B2 B3
and well I'm just saying it's a
defensive task for VAR you think I'm
just too slow here like if I play if I
play like Rook a C8 or something I just
want to yeah yeah just want to see you
Checkmate me let's try all right Rook a
C8 G4 way we go now I'm thinking I might
actually play Bishop B4 here because um
I I think B4 you can just play C4 right
oh you have Pawn takes B4
sorry I think that's Pawn takes B4 I got
a a Tempo against your queen yeah and
that's just k um so I can't I can't play
Bishop B4 which is kind of annoying
because it looks like B4 just you just
play C4 right yes and that's just the
end of my party right the problem like
right I'll shut you down and it's still
very hard for you for black to stop uh
G5 but up to this moment I can imagine
it going this direction I'm telling you
again I I defended these positions I
wasn't happy about them I can imagine a
move like Rook to uh f8 to d8 to begin
you know exit stage uh left type of
thing you know just get to get on my
running shoes in a moment here uh to get
out of what I am anticipating a big big
bad pwn storm but yes in that just that
position you just showed yeah there's uh
there looks like some nasties on F7 oh
definitely it looks like in fact you're
just going to kill me right away yeah
just
RI and is already shaking his head point
out this line yeah is why this is so
powerful because well again we we we've
spoken about how these Bishops got
posted up eyeballing Black's King uh
almost from the get-go and after King
takes well it's a very straightforward
mate 2 check and it's kind of sweet that
the Bishops that were sitting on D4 and
D3 deliver a very handsome uh
checkmating pattern on H7 and G7 I'm
stunned that he went for this position
and VAR must not be happy we saw him
shaking his head there and just now that
one looks painful just it really does uh
something really interesting happening
in another game that's
similar that that's just bizarre if you
take a look at this situation let's just
go back to what was a an very well-known
opening line in the NSO Indian with
Queen C2 then B6 a move here and two
popular moves A3 and E4 when I looked in
the databases uh with in the database
they were the exact number of moves even
though they've been played hundreds of
times they've been played the exact
number of times E4 very aggressive C E5
one move here and now
D5 getting some space obviously trying
to get a bind Queen E7 an unusual move I
remember seeing this move I wrote a book
on the millionaire chess open number one
and this move was featured in a game
Real brilliancy where the Knight E2
happened Queen E7 seems like just odd
move to me Bishop E2 but it was Knight
E2 that was played in that other game
this line has not been seen but once uh
this position I should say and the move
Queen to E4 check out that move a queen
E4 offering a queen trade showing that
you have this nice pin on the diagonal
looking to trade and attacking the pawn
on G2 now of course after a trade night
takes Black's just hunkidori and happy
in that position so white decided to
sack the G pawn and play Queen to D2 I
mean these pinning issues are incredible
he's he couldn't take before so he
unpins himself but he's also sort of
pinned because the bishop could also go
through to the queen even night takes
Queen is not really that threatened here
because night takes will happen and
you're still pinned on the Square so
it's not a real threat that is that
devastating but the question is would
you nibble on this Pawn on G2 and that
is what Young aak Shandra is going into
the tank thinking about we've seen him
spend an hour on the Move yes this is
not one he should spend an hour on at
all it's time to back that Queen out of
there but he's once he said a he seems
like he wants to say B and he's going to
estimate is is this move worth it Bishop
to F3 Queen back to G6 very natural and
now Knight G2 and we just talked about
the Wesley so game with a rook on the G
file this Rook will go to the G file as
well and I'm sorry no thank you for this
kind of Pawn no way in the world a
threat your knight can't get out very
easily it's going to be slow roll trying
to get into the game and Whit pieces are
going to get in very quickly the Queen's
going to move The Bishop's going to move
he's going to Castle and he's going to
have the exact same attack do you
remember that game with Anna zatonski
against Katarina mova we asked Katarina
after the game why she took so long what
variation was she looking at and she was
looking at exactly this kind of
variation a queen landing on G5 in her
game followed by taste on G2 and then
she realized what am I doing I'm running
after pawns on G2 I should have just
ignored that line and saved my time well
AKA Chandra now finding himself with the
same dilemma does he take on
G2 after the move Queen to D2 or does he
just back his Queen up and get out of
there of course there's another line
where he could take this Knight as well
not to be recommended and then take on
G2 engine saying you don't want to do
that after you back up in this position
we're very happy to play now against the
two Bishops with the two Bishops and The
Rook coming to the file and you're going
to get smashed so maybe he's just
stunned by this Pawn sacrifice but look
at him sitting so lonely in the corner
that's terrible they sent them into the
corner of the room well of course
somebody has to sit over there but man
this move Queen D2 is on the board and
there goes onru thinking I dare you I
dare you to take my Pawn absolutely um I
think that uh unfortunately for our us
Junior Champion he's had some very bad
experiences thus far in the first half
of the tournament with his clock uh poor
time management and it looks like he got
caught unawares with this move Queen D2
we have a caller yes we do welcome to
the show let us know your name and where
you're calling from hello
hello uh little little noisy in the
background there hopefully you can hear
me yes I can uh it's no it's noisy on
your end but uh my question is I wanted
to piggy back on that gentleman when we
mentioned the computer for armag game
who would you think we'll say the world
open or even millionaire chop not
everybody can afford to travel that far
this year it's going to be in Atlantic
City for millionaire chess they found a
way to do it through computers and being
monitored very much like the colleges do
or Webster they play online they have
somebody that way I don't even have to
go physically that would make some of
these big tournaments even bigger more
prize money more sponsors and not and on
and on it also would increase the USF
membership
dramatically well thank you for your uh
question caller let's turn it over to
organizer the millionaire open chest tan
himself Maurice Ashley well it's a great
idea we would love to do it um my friend
very good friend Jones Murphy in New
York is experimenting with tournaments
that you can play at a distance where
you go to a center where there's a
tournament director a number of players
much like your brother Greg shahadi uh
Jen doing similar things you play on a
computer with an Arbiter sitting over
the players at the tables and makeing at
the at the computer terminals excuse me
and making sure that no one is cheating
Etc the problem of course is security
and confidence so if you start talking
about something like the millionaire
chess open and this year it's going to
be a reduced price fund at $510,000 but
still a lot of money first place in the
open section is 50 Grand and in the
lower sections is 20
grand if someone at a distance started
winning a game started stringing
together a number of games it's very
difficult to convince the public that
some kind of Nefarious activity is
absolutely not going on and to solve
that problem will be the issue for
players who want to do exactly that
because I think it's it's brilliant if I
can go to my home City not go at a
distance and just sit and play in front
of computer terminal and assure everyone
that I'm on the up and up it would be
perfect it would be the absolute best
solution for chess actually overall we
could play tournaments all over the
world in different time zones all that
could be done but until you can convince
people and actually we took a poll about
it online and it came back almost
unanimously people were saying
absolutely not I will not believe that
you could solve the cheating factor and
you know we just shrug our shoulders we
get it it's the case at least for now
until the until that is resolved that
one big issue there's no way people will
play Big Money tournaments put their
money in with the with the confidence
that there's no kind of cheating going
on elsewhere thank you Maurice if I can
get in a common on that first of all
thank you for the caller question I
think it would be very brilliant and I
think it would be great for chess clubs
so for example let's say you had the
millionaire millionaire uh chess open in
New Jersey and I'm from San Francisco I
would go to the mechanics chess club
where I'd be in a controlled environment
right with maybe 10 other people and I'd
play at a distance and you know under
cameras surveillance and under Arbiters
at the chess clubs at itself so maybe
somebody at the Franklin Mercantile in
Philadelphia at the um in New York City
the Marshall chess club these very
famous clubs they would get a lot more
attendance in and of the club as people
played in a sense Visa satellite uh
around the United States I think clubs
would Embrace that and I understand
wholeheartedly the uh you know
confidence of no cheating but again
if you had the cameras the webcams at
the clubs I don't see how anybody could
object and especially if entry fees
raise the pricee funds it's a win-win
win for everybody yeah and we are having
experiments with that of course us chess
league and um the uh us Chess Federation
also has um rated competitions now
online both on chess.com and ICC but
great question um and Maurice has an
update from one of our games yes
absolutely fantastic questions and we
hope to resolve that issue in the next
few years big occurrence in this game
the youngster ashria eson unfortunately
has fallen for a tactical blow uh she's
playing against Saina fer and they're
playing an isolated Pawn position
isolated Queen pawn queen G4 signaling a
potential attack on this side and F5 a
controversial move but often seen in
this kind of position playing the move
F5 even though you're weakening the E6
point you accept it in the position
because you figure you can stop White's
demonstrations and sooner or later
challenge this Knight on E5 Bishop to F6
so far so good Bishop to C4 now that the
bishop is no good on this diagonal why
not put it on a new one and there were a
number of moves here Rook E8 for example
was one move Knight C7 is given by the
engine not a move I like Rook E8 looks
logical but she decided to develop with
the move Knight to D7 and this one
unfortunately is not a good move because
it was met by this discovery Knight to
C6 and that one is a nasty shot hitting
the E6 Pawn hitting the queen and ashria
now staring at the board after only 14
moves realizing that this Knight if it's
captured will simply just be met by
check and then you just take the bishop
and it's a free Pawn this Knight is
under heavy pressure you can't do pretty
much anything if you trade nice just to
try to get at this Pawn then of course
Pawn takes reinforces this guy so unless
there's some bizarre tactic that even
the computer is not seeing if we go back
tonight to C6 the other point is if you
move the queen to the guard this Pawn on
this Square then suddenly Knight takes
on D5 and of course if you take back
then Bishop takes with check thanks for
the pawn everybody's happy for white and
if you capture this Knight then the move
Knight to C7 appears
and things are really bad here so KN to
C6 a complete oversight on the part of
the youngster and it looks as though Sao
foer looking very intent though
everybody knows these youngsters have
been coming back in this tournaments and
sa is making sure that there are no
tricks associated with this move but it
looks as though she will win a pawn and
being in the driver seat in this game
and we do have another phone call so uh
let's take that a beautiful move by
Sabina fer you know she was
underestimating her her chances I think
sometimes people do that at a
Superstition very good now she's fing M
like 196 so we do have a call uh let us
know who you are and where you're
calling from and what you want to chat
about hello
hello yes this is Steve from Dallas hi
Steve hi uh first off congratulations to
all you guys yes San and Jennifer
shahadi and then congratulations to
Marie sasy getting inducted into the
Chess Hall of Fame
yesterday uh my question is sort of a
two-parter what is the relationship in
y'all's Collective op of
practice uh that is game playing games
of Chess versus lots of study and sort
of dry you know study the books read the
watch the
DVDs thank you for your question Steve
so the caller asks how do you divide
your time between study and practice
great question I think it depends on
person to person it differs a little bit
some people enjoy playing a little bit
more some people enjoy studying but but
one thing's for sure you got to do both
and probably close I think something
close to 50/50 but if you're going to
sacrifice one probably sacrifice the
study because if you're not playing you
don't really have study material exactly
so maybe 6040 in favor of playing 50/50
has always been a good rule of thumb for
me as
well great question great question I'm
looking at the game between Jeffrey uh
and Gata uh it's it's early in the um
opening
of of the alakin very risky opening at
this high level and Jeffrey played a
move I'm not really completely satisfied
with Rook C1 in this particular
structure I've always been of the
opinion that it's important to get in
this freeing break C4 C5 very quickly
and I think that uh if White's going to
get an edge he should do it right away
and strike so to speak while the iron is
hot the idea is that any trades
involving also by the way the trade of
the Queens is usually well countered by
this move Knight
D5 and if you play Knight A6 I'm I'll
just simply grab that Knight and I got a
fork on C7 which wins the game so
against the move C5 essentially the only
move is to back up with the Knight right
you back up with the Knight you give
your opponent two choices one one choice
that he can handle is simply to take
take Bishop C4 and I consider the
superior development is leading to edge
for white the other thing is just to
leave this Pawn on C5 for a
moment uh don't make that trade and
simply play the move Bishop C4 after for
example a move like castles Knight F3
and I like this queen side majority I
think that White's play on the queen
side even though black has a central
majority it's harder for black to use
his e epon as some kind of a battering
ram than it is for white I always
thought that this was an easy line for
white Jeffrey played the move Rook C1
instead castles B3 already a second
indication that he's not completely
comfortable Bishop F5 that's a little
bit of a surprise move for me um huh
Bishop F5 D5 E5
takes so yeah that move Bishop F5 was a
surprise as you can see it looks like
black lost a Tempo moving as Bishop
first to F5 and then back to E6 but
nonetheless I think that that the
position is now closer to even than it
is uh to an advantage for white so uh
Jeffrey playing
solid uh close to the vest uh chess but
uh maybe letting a little opportunity
slip here uh early in round
five we we've got some uh questions
coming into our hashtag at us chess
Champs stepen Oracle asks playing off a
previous question that we had do
Grandmasters play Stronger chess with a
physical board in pieces or with a
computer display pieces in BO or is
there simply no
difference in my case I feel I play much
better with the pieces in front of me I
I mean that my early training that's
that's the only thing I did there wasn't
computers
uh today's Millennials I think they're
raised with an electronic screen in
front of their eyes whether it be a
smartphone or computer or tablet and I
think they're more comfortable actually
with a 2d whereas I like the pieces
interesting yeah I mean definitely
they're at least as good with the
two-dimensional I mean with the with the
two-dimensional but are they actually
better that that's kind of an
interesting question it would be an
interesting stud they're just simply
used to seeing and if you've ever
watched Hikaru Hikaru I once watched him
playing a Blitz game Blitz Games on the
IC where he wasn't making moves he was
typing them in he was typing in his
moves while having a conversation and
just briefly glancing at the screen it
was phenomenal and by the way it was a
one minute game wow and there was shot
of him and wishing that he was playing
on a computer Eric Rosen asks will uh
Karina mova Castle King side or queen
side just don't take 20 minutes to
decide well he tweeted that 4 minutes
ago and let's see if she has made a
decision that's a game between right I
just kind of go surveying the women's
boards for a second uh well and she had
she has decided um she she so he was
referring to the position before castles
after Queen to D7 so we got to this
position a very tame way by the way in
my view of meeting the French defense uh
uh Kate's choice and here it sure does
look like she was setting herself up to
castling long I guess she thought the
better of it and castled short and boy
the position looks really really dry to
me uh no Advantage whatsoever for the
first player in this key matchup and we
have a phone call please uh let us know
who you are and where you're calling
from hello hi hello hello can you hear
me yes oh uh my name is Angel Collins
and I'm calling from Madison
Wisconsin hello can you hear me yes you
can oh okay I'm Angel Collins from
Madison Wisconsin welcome Angel
congratulations to all of you great
great
cast uh my question is um in the
Stonewall P
formation and the Stonewall P formation
if you can use them for both sides and
black and and white now and the second
question that I have I'm sorry I have
few questions and the second question
is I've been using the king Indians
attack and they guide me all the way to
two some rating but then I couldn't pass
more so then I start using the stone
wall and now I'm reaching like 2100 my
question is
after 2100 what will be the best
um um opening to continue reaching
higher and my final question is why to
retire
onet well thank you for your questions
let me uh take a shot out of it
certainly the Dutch Stonewall is a uh P
formation that you can use both for the
white side as well as the black side no
questions about that second one was like
uh he started to change his opening his
opening repertoire because he found that
you was kind of flatlining flatlining or
had reached a little bit of a ceiling
and I think that's very important in
chess that um you make switches you
switch opening switch defenses when you
feeling that you've plateaued it's very
important in chess as in life to
challenge yourself if your game is too
easy or comfortable it's not it's
because you're not giving yourself
enough challenges so definitely mixing
it up when you feel that you've hit a
plateau is very important and the third
question I missed uh that didn't come
over so uh easily for me do you recall
what he said well no but angel can
always call back all right well thank
you for your question and I'm going to
turn it over to
Maurice yeah so there have been a
development on this board and you know
it's interesting as the position gets
deeper and deeper and deeper even when
you're better even when you're winning
you still have to find accurate moves
and you still have to calculate deeply
you can't just sit back and say I played
the move and now it's done and as s on
is showing that right now that even
though she might have missed this move
Knight C6 she played the move Queen to
E8 a really interesting move in the
position Knight takes D5 e takes D5
Bishop takes D5 check King to h8 now
normally you would say wait a minute I
just want a pawn therefore I should
trade queens and get into a winning end
game I'm up a pawn after all not so fast
sometimes when you're ahead you have to
maintain the Queens anyway because in
this position after takes Rook takes on
E8 and suddenly white is confronted with
an issue of this pin along this line yes
you have the pawn but your piece is
pinned this way and this Pawn on D4
needs to be protected and that's an
issue right now for white also so if if
this Pawn drops for sure the position
stabilizes quickly so white has to get
some kind of edge here and the engines
are not giving much for white in this
position except something like Bishop to
F3 if you played something like Bishop
to E3 saying well where are the threats
in the position this wouldn't be bad for
you except you'd have to consider the
move Knight to B8 and here comes that
pin that we were talking about being
used along this
diagonal suddenly Knight takes on B8
Bishop takes on D5 your knight can
certainly get back out and trade itself
off for this piece you're up a pawn but
it's not exactly the pawn you want
because this bishop is a very healthy
blockader and it'll be difficult some
kind of work certainly good for white as
white thinks about getting to the E5
Square for example with her own Bishop
but still this one is going to be
difficult to eject so there's going to
be some work ahead in a line like that
she'll have to be looking very closely
at this line so back to this position
with King h8 the engines give as best
Queen F3 maintaining the strong diagonal
push down this
line still there are some tactics here
worth considering uh in this position
for example the engine gives Bishop
takes D4 certainly not the kind of move
a human plays instantly Knight takes and
suddenly the move Knight to E5 and the
queen is having trouble eyeballing this
bishop defending it very easily you
might wonder well why don't I just play
this move a lot to calculate again takes
takes and now the move Rook to d8
attacking the queen and telling the
queen where do you go you cannot look at
the geometrics of this move you can't
defend your knight on D4 best is
actually to sacrifice the queen and go
down this line looking for Advantage but
not much of an edge here so you see the
calculations and the complications after
you've already put your hand in a cookie
jar stolen the cookie ready to eat it
and then all of a sudden the sirens go
off and it's like work again and Sabina
is feeling feeling that right now as
she's starting to think about the
position very carefully realizing that
it's not that easy to keep this Pawn
that's right it's like you you you went
for a chocolate chip cookie and it turns
out that it's just like with
raisins wanted it wasn't completely what
you wanted I'm going to turn our
attention before we go on break to the
game between Arena and Anna our Marquee
matchup in the women's championships uh
they have played a very well-known
variation of the queen Gambit declined
that was played in the 1960s uh by tan
petosan amongst others as well as in the
1990s uh in the matches between Gary
Kasparov and anat karpov after the move
Bishop F5 the highly desirable idea of
developing the light squar Bishop the
slight drawback is after Queen F3 they
do go into this ending where these
double pawns do represent a
weakness although they control a number
of key squar
all of these moves are very well known
and top level chess uh Knight B6 and
we're up to date in a very theoretical
position I believe it was actually Gary
Kasparov who won as black in this
particular ending against Anatoly carp
off in their match games but well-known
ending nothing too special uh to say at
the moment because again it's all
Theory all right well um we do have a a
special feature for for you as we go to
Break um one of the players is going to
tell us their most embarrassing chess
moment is this a confessional or a
pre-tape kind of little
interview it's it's pre let's see but uh
yeah who was it and what did they do
it'd be so hard to narrow it down to one
but let's find out and we'll be right
back with more from the championship in
US Women's here in round six five
sorry
[Music]
about 10 years ago I played in a
tournament and um somehow my opponent uh
as he was playing pushed his a pawn to
A3 and you know as a chess player you
should know where all the pieces are
right I calculated all this line
probably about five six moves and ended
up playing a line that would bring me
the win because at the end I'll play
Rook B3 and just win some material I
play Rook B3 and he captures with the
pawn in B3 and I started saying are you
serious what are doing the pawn was in
A3 you cannot capture my rook and um he
was like no I never played that pawn and
I was looking on the on the score
and I realized that yes indeed he never
did that but everybody saw it that it
was an A3 so he ended up offering me a
draw and I said no I don't want to draw
I'm winning what what do you mean and uh
then I realized that actually I was lost
so I took the draw but that was really
embarrassing for not remembering where
he spone was
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
I'm Mike maeni manager of the Cardinals
and chess fanatic many people don't know
that St Louis has a chess history as
rich as its baseball at the
world-renowned chess club and Scholastic
Center of St Louis across from the World
Chess Hall of Fame our goal is to teach
play and promote the sport come to the
Central West End and experience all that
chess has to
[Music]
offer
e
[Music]
for
e
[Music]
for
and we are back at the 2016 US
championships and US Women's
Championship here in round five where we
are discussing our most embarrassing
moments that's never fun no to think
about like all bad things that have ever
happened of course just does put you
into a tough spot where you know there's
so much pressure
and you know you just have to have these
memories where you hung your queen or
you lost on time and you try to shut
them out right it's tough it's tough
because those are the harsh the hardest
losses uh you played a good game your
opponent played better you can live with
it but when you did something really
egregiously embarrassing you know oh
that's that's harsh yeah when you want
to kind of like sink into the floor
right under the table and disappear you
bet well the action is heating up
Jennifer I tell you I'm looking at the
game of nji pitti as she is playing uh
against Jennifer uh woo and uh I like
White's position here it I've always
liked these kinds of uh structures where
on the queen side and most especially I
my Queens side majority pardon me I
wanted to say but most importantly I get
the square I get to use the square D4
it's like that pawn on
D5 really gains a lot of space it
reaches into Black's position and behind
the pawn on D5 I get to either put a
knight on D4 or a bishop on D4 in
certain cases and eyeballing the C6
Square this is not a fun position for
black I don't see uh good ways for black
uh to create uh counter uh pressure
chances not that the position is bad I
just think of it is a little bit too
passive for my taste uh on the on the um
black side of the board I agree at least
we have like some small Cheapo alert if
uh Na were to play Bishop D4 we could
maybe um snack on the H3
Pawn uh sorry uh instead of the move B3
yeah or at some point at some point
let's say Bishop D4 you mean I know
there's there's all those great tricks
if you play a bad move like Queen D2
Queen D2 yeah Bishop takes H3 kind in
the air you know because then you've
always got these Knight F3 um uh Forks
but against the immediate Bishop D4 does
I was checking to see if it works after
Bishop H3 you have the in between move
um Bishop takes E5 so so what am I
missing if I just take oh I I I've got
the bishop defended hav I that's true
yeah a couple of times yeah it's not
ready yet not quite there yet because I
do have it I know what you mean that
Bishop on G7 nicely is in Ambush spoken
like a real Grom well I do play the
dragon but one thing is usually these
positions are a little bit more pleasant
for black and I I think one of the
reasons that Bishop on D2 makes a lot
more sense with the pawn on D5 a lot of
times when I get a position like this
where the white is on D5 White's Bishop
is like on E2 or something which is a
lot less effective because
you don't really have these ideas of
planting a night on C6 or they're much
harder to execute exactly exactly night
Knight and we were seeing it yesterday I
think it was in karissa's game where she
could have gone for Knight C3 is black
and you try to go for Knight C6 as white
in these positions looks very good for
white so so but we do have our our phone
call so tell us where you're calling
from and your
name
hello
caller hello let us know uh what your
what your name is where you're calling
from and what you'd like to talk
about my my name is Patrick and I'm from
New Jersey and Jennifer I could hardly
hear you but I'm gonna see if I can get
this through anyway I just wanted to
mention that uh um you both you and
Maurice were talking about the women in
chess and uh I had the opportunity to
meet this three-year-old child girl who
is actually
um in my opinion is going to be one of
the greatest grest players if she
continues uh usually three-year-olds are
playing with pieces as if as if they
were figurines of
sorts um but uh this little girl knew
how to play knew how to piece she set up
the board F that and I did and uh the
only question she had I was trying to
teach kids at my local chess club and
the only question she had was about the
uh the way the night moves and I showed
that to her
again wow wow that's fantastic I mean
it's wonderful to see three-year-old uh
already embracing chess what's her name
come on you we got to keep an eye out
for her yeah I got to tell you I can
hardly hear you but I think you said
that's wonderful um yeah and morce was
talking about the diversity and and more
women in chess there's not that as many
you both you and Maurice were mentioned
there's not as many women in chess and U
what I'm seeing in the local chess club
is that there are more women and what
I'm seeing here on the computer screen
here I'm seeing these kids that this
this 12-year-old girl and they they're
you know from the schools in New York
and stuff like that um I see that you're
doing a great job in in promoting this
game thank you thank you caller for the
question threeyear old my gosh although
I do love the story about the poar
sisters about how um lozo taught Susan
and Sophia who are the older sisters
Sophia is the middle Susan's the oldest
and um actually decided learning from
their experiences that he had taught
them a little bit too early um maybe
three or four and waited till Judi was 5
to teach her like I I'm not sure what
exact it would be really interesting
question to ask llo or or Susan at some
point I'm not sure exactly what the
rationale is but that somehow it was
diminishing returns to to start before
the age of five interesting that was
actually a conscious decision and of
course he was very into
pedagogy interesting and of course
Judith went on to outpace her sisters uh
in the world of Chez I mean I doubt it's
related to that but you never I mean it
is it is kind of interesting because a
lot of times people do ask me what age
they should start and I think the answer
is when they like it and that might be
around five or six for a lot of kids
interesting uh Maurice I do agree with
that and the research does bear that out
that it's much easier to start at a
later age because the abstract Concepts
that they're able to digest they do so
quickly at five or six as compared to
three but if a three-year-old is picking
up all the pieces right away and saying
God got it which is rare for sure then
why argue she's obviously a Mozart in
the making so I don't see anything wrong
with that speaking of some young mozarts
in the making Carissa Yip is playing
this Wild game against aat kvv and this
position is insane look at the pawn
storm she allowed the move B4 in this
position dropped her Knight back to B1
so this night is temporarily out of the
game and after long thought I got to
decide is you didn't want to see F6 up
here on the board too easily without
contending with this formation and
decided to play the move H6 now this is
one of the engine's top moves although
the engine seemed like they settled on
the Move A5 as the best one and in this
position she played Rook to G1 now she
could have taken on H6 as well but this
move says I'm going to maintain the
tension no trades let's see if you can
figure out what to do here well takes
was played takes takes and Rook takes so
we have this position on the board and
as you look at this you really feel like
white has broken through already
whatever white was trying to do white
has achieved E6 is under pressure G6
could potentially become Under Pressure
certainly H5 with a rook on G5 is
absolutely Under Pressure where is this
King going to live it's not clear at all
it looks as though Carissa has found her
way to Advantage in this particular
position absolutely you've got to like
white in this game going to another game
I found fascinating a moment happened
here that was really interesting in the
game with gakamsky
and and young Jeffrey Jang this move D5
this whole setup yes has is a very
contentious one if white chooses to do
so the move E5 was played on the board
and this is where Jeffrey made a mistake
the move has been seen before and I my
opinion it's a mistake because dakes E6
was played I don't think you want to
trade off this Pawn at all it's the
wrong thing to do in this moment there's
different ways to play this position one
is is to be super aggressive with H4
another is to challenge Black's entire
setup with the move G4 and after the
bishop drops back to then continue with
H4 sharp as ever position if you go into
it you need to prepare it he decided did
Jeffrey to take on pant this is the most
popular move but to my eyes after Bishop
takes E6 this is exactly what black
wants when playing an alakin defense you
get your Pawn formation then I break it
down so far there's only one Pawn left
this const right here well this
relationship Pawn to pawn if I get in D5
you got zero and check out what happened
the next couple of moves Knight G to E2
D5 on the board and now C5 looking like
a move that will compete against the D5
move when a break happens you try to
bypass there three different ways you
leave it alone you capture or you bypass
he bypassed here thinking all was well
and good until got to drop the move
Knight to C6 on the board complete
completely ignoring this move now
prepared to play the move d4 himself if
you take his Knight he's going to win
back a piece after D4 with lots of play
instead after Knight to C6 Jeffrey
played the move Knight to D4 and that
move is not considered good at all and
look at this crowd around this board a
rich position to be sure got now played
a beautiful move the kind of move we
really love to see
he captured on D4 with the bishop as
recommended by the engines a paradoxical
exchange giving away your dark Square
Bishop for the Knight but after Bishop
takes the engines are screaming the move
which has not been played as yet Queen
to H4 and suddenly Black's position has
exploded dynamically a dream of an
alakin position this bishop can't just
move back because suddenly D4 appears on
the board meantime the bishop is under
attack from this queen what do you do
with it any move to defend it like
Knight B5 really looks tepid at best
moves like Rook to E8 or possible A6
challenging the Knight also possible
this is dynamic for black you got to
love that move he played Bishop takes D4
I think these two moves he has shows the
level of a goak kamsky knight to C6
ignoring the attack on the Knight and
then after Knight D4 Bishop takes
D4 exceptional moves are what really
separate the best players or the great
players
from the good players and I think that
that last move was exceptional although
he did not play Queen H4 surprisingly he
played the move Rook to E8 instead not
as big as Queen H4 gakamsky misses the
most point in continuation should have
play Queen H4 Rook E8 the injuries are
giving as equal giving young Jeffrey a
chance to get back in the game fantastic
uh one of the great lines from Victor
kchoi uh was that uh I I made some
absurd suggestion and he says to me Yas
sir before you break the rules you
should first know
them and uh clearly uh some rules being
broken by gamsky but he knows when to
break them that move uh I really like
Knight C6 and Bishop D4 you know um not
being prejudiced and giving up your very
powerful Bishop on G7 for what looks
like a poor night but the Dynamics favor
we we uh we have been conducting a poll
asking you our viewers who you think are
most likely to help uh to win the
Championships pardon me and to help you
along we have the road ahead as we show
what our top three players in the
championship section face uh over the
rest of the tournament let's have a look
at the
graphic well Fabiano Carana has yet to
play onuk Shong Robson Lenderman csky
and Shandra meanwhile Robson still has
to play against kamsky kaana and
Nakamura as well as so and changlin so
Robson does have a brutal um lineup
ahead but he's been playing well Wesley
so Nakamura shaav onos shuk Jang Robson
and Lenderman so to me looking at this
it's pretty clear Robson has the
toughest Road um and then next after
that uh
F right faty uh has a much easier Hood
compared to Ray Ray's going to be
playing all the favorites of seems uh
going forwards and even so I think has a
harder road than Fabby so that's one of
the reasons why people are so impressed
with poob so far of course he has got a
lot of tough players left to face but
also if you look at the colors he was
he's white against onos he's white
against Robson he's really got the white
pieces against a lot of the stronger
players in the tournament but actually
is that better or worse like if you have
to choose do you prefer to get white
against the highest rated player so that
you're less likely to get bludgeon or do
you want white against the lower rated
players so that you could try to score
some full points more easily uh My
Philosophy when playing in the US
championships was I always prefer to
have white against my nearest Rivals
because I was hoping to beat them and
push them further down on the cross
table give me white come on Jennifer so
like Bobby did against um against
Nakamura yesterday absolutely absolutely
no question and we've got another phone
call let us know who you are and where
you're call
from hello let us know who you're who
you are where you're calling from and
what you'd like to chat
about I don't I don't think they realize
we're on the line so uh we'll probably
go back to that later uh but let's uh
take I'll pick up with the game between
Sam Shanklin and um hikaro Nakamura very
early in the tourn very early in this
opening I was really uh pumping for this
move Knight F6 Bishop G2 it castles
again this uh to my eyes at least is a
very well-known equalizing uh sequence
of moves for black where you can force
um pieces off the board as well as the
Queens I agree white has the two Bishops
I'm not a big believer that this is a
very
uh strong or an advantage that is is
good enough uh to give a a clear Edge
for
white I don't think I think this is a
historic moment I've never I've never
seen you be so dismissive of the two
visions yeah yeah well in this caracon
structure they're just really good uh
pawns that's right you play The Carol KH
so right that wasn't uh at all what Sam
had in mind however what he had in mind
was to play a French defense which is
kind of the structure we have minus his
light Square Bishop he seemed to be very
happy uh hikaro on the other hand
equally happy pardon me this Pawn on E5
very very nicely uh controls in the
center of the board he wants to support
the pawn very self-evidently with the
move F2 F4 by first getting his Queen
out of the way C5 breaking down White
Center all very standard moves by both
players this this Knight on A6 is
clearly off sides right I mean it needs
to get back into the game and with the
KN move Knight B4 uh Sam is looking to
bring his Knight back to C6 and uh snap
that Bishop on D4 Knight all of these
moves look very very natural to me and
yet at the end of the
day this position that we have on the
board I still favor white despite the
fact that black has succeeded in trading
off his uh poor light squared Bishop I
like this space and
Maurice well you like the space in that
position yes I like the dynamism in
Black's position in the gakamsky game
absolutely fascinating position take a
look again at this moment your knight is
under attack you think it's a good idea
to move it actually the engine start
that was a good idea move the Knight
that's not a bad move but Knight C6
definitely a good move as well
sacrificing a knight for the D4 threat
Knight D4 shutting that down preparing
to make trades and still the tempo on
the Knight on B6 and now this move
Bishop takes D4 giving up the dark
squared Bishop around your king allowing
Bishop takes and the move Queen H4 was
definitely the most direct and stronger
than the move played but take a look at
this move Rook to E8 eyeballing the king
a discovery of some kind and the engines
say boldly that the best move is
unquestionably take the Knight on B6
allow the discovery and now for black
Bishop G4 is a mistake Bishop to E2 no
problem you've got zip
no worries at all for white in fact
White's much better here there's no
tactics working if you take whatever
happens the knight's covering he's
castling on the next move no big deal
what should you do after C takes B6 then
I was like you just gave away a full
night what are you doing well the best
move
paradoxically I'll just take my Pawn
back thank you very much give it to me
keep what do you mean like what do you
mean what is happening here turns out
that now if you play Bishop to E2 the
most natural move th thow down to please
peace black has the tempo Queen to H4
attacking the bishop daring it to move
Bishop E3 we've seen runs into the move
d4 so now what well you could take this
Pawn on B6 But Here Comes the D Pawn
down the board and he's going to get
back something here because this Knight
is hanging on the Square it's high time
to Castle don't try to stay in the
middle of the board with a move like
this one because suddenly Bishop to G4
show shows up you don't have F3 this is
hanging you start playing moves like
Rook to C2 trying to defend and here
comes D3 oops and now you're just toast
after Knight to B4 fork and queen and
Rook Bishop still hanging it's over so
after the move C3 let's go back to D4
excuse me right here best get the heck
out of there allow this capture to
happen but now A2 is hanging black after
all the pyrot Technics is just fine is
it's actually just a Vision better
according to the engines probably both
sides will be happy to shake hands right
now and say let's just take the draw
because that was ridiculous but wow talk
about crazy tactical ideas and Jeffrey J
has to navigate all of them in this
position fortunately for him he'll be
okay as white if he plays the Right
Moves he's looking deeply but man yes to
calculate all that that was a wild
variation Maurice and if you could just
go through it again for a second cuz
there was a moment there that I didn't
understand myself okay it was Bishop
takes D4 Bishop Rook E8 inaccurate it
seems take the
Knight then you went Queen
H4 no you took on pardon me you took on
B is the best Queen Bishop E2 now you
went Queen H4 correct and now I was
thinking to to protect the bishop with
Knight
B5 but what do you do about Bishop G4 I
was going to go
G3 oh Rook C2 now sorry Rook to C2 and I
wasn't I didn't see the the correct move
according to the enges is continue to
trade right then trade again ah an A2 is
hanging and F2 is hanging got it the
open file suddenly emerges beautiful if
you move it take with the queen of
course the D4 pieces hanging right
beautiful line insane insane beautiful
variation must be be calculated deeply
of course that's what we have engines
for is they help us to navigate those
variations if we had to look at that you
and I as in just say with by ourselves
casually it would take us some time to
work out every variation we wouldn't
even believe some of the variations for
white we'd say or for black actually
we'd say really does he really have the
compensation yet and it might take us a
solid 15 20 minutes to go yeah he's okay
he's got the compensation but these
engines Split Second 5 Seconds 10
seconds 15 seconds got it all worked out
no problem Magnus Carlson was asked
would he ever play an engine again his
answer was nope no thanks they're better
than us why would I play in such a match
it's completely ridiculous concept one
mistake by me it's all over and they're
not making any obvious mistakes so that
battle is done uh was done for quite
some time now but we still use them in
order to analyze our games to test our
variations and of course for commentary
so we can elucidate the finer points of
the game
intelligently we hope to the viewers A7
takes B6 that move was wild amazing and
the capture has occurred by the way the
capture has occurred on B6 and Jeffrey
is testing him in the main line wow so
this game definitely a a brutal tactical
battle and we'll have to see uh what
csky sees today I absolutely I remember
uh we did a um a junior Camp here in St
Louis um we had a summer camp for kids
and uh Jeffrey was in the camp and this
is already 3 four years ago and I recall
um doing a lecture with a very tactical
position and jeffy's calculation skills
were extraordinary even at that very
young age so he's a great tactician he
can calculate I wanted to turn you know
one of the first people to notice a
great talent of Jeffrey jeang who's that
Joy Bray the man manager here at the St
Louis chess club she fell in love with
him that's
different no she knows that was he is so
cute she just wanted to adopt them I
know she told me but it's true that even
if you're not a strong chest player you
can sometimes note by a kid's
disposition um my brother wrote an
article about having so much experience
at us chess schools and the best
indicator that one of the kids was just
going to soar and it was a lot to do
with their approach to chess how much
they studied how serious they were about
their study routine in their game and of
course uh Greg also noted that uh Jang
was up there with the uh the Sean and uh
Leon a Wander of course absolutely for
me it was always I could just spot a kid
um at the board their
concentration was extraordinary kids
that you know were really really focused
in on the matches uh looking at their
pieces and um in instead of looking
around and you know wanting to say hello
to everybody they were very focused on
their game and I thought that was really
the mark of a champion if you look at
Carissa right now right here she's where
her are her eyes peeled directly at the
board they're not looking at kibitzers
or Spectators that may be walking by
she's focused she's in the zone that's
right you got to be in the zone that's
that's what it's all about that if you
want to get 200 points stronger than
your actual understanding of Chess you
got to be really good at getting him
and that's why some people who um don't
understand as much don't even see as
much they might be better than you if
they're able to reach that state of
massive concentration during the game
tomorrow is a free day but we do have a
couple of very exciting events coming up
at the World Chess Hall of Fame and the
first one's actually one that I'm
hosting we have a popup a chess
demonstration tomorrow and that's going
to be really fun because it's going to
be in conjunction with the shows ladies
night and her turn two exhibits at the
hall of fame that focus on women's
achievements in chz and also women's
perspective on the art of jazz I
actually have a piece in that show as
well and the event is going to be the
ladies from this Championship playing in
the most degenerate forms of jazz so
we've got Bug House we've got one minute
chess you don't like Blitz Blitz on an
all-white chess set blindfold as well
Anna Zony um the um most wellknown in
the Women's Championship for her
blindfold exhibition she can play many
players at once can I play as one of the
players in the blindfold exhibition
against Anna I think I got a chance I
thought for sure you were going to say
you weren't wanted to play in The Bug
House oh well that too of first did you
remember who the best Bug House players
were we just like went down the the um
we didn't go down the rating list we
went on the the birth year list the
younger the better at Bug House in
inverse correlation to age and Bug house
cuz they just the kids just love playing
Bug House get a skirt if you want to
play Ser go buy a skirt no no no no guys
are welcome come on now guys are welcome
what makes a great Bug House player in
your estimation Jennifer um practice and
tactics the Tactical eye that that's
great right and being a good team player
that's very important being aware of
what's going on you're so much better at
bug I'm actually really bad at bug house
like I I don't play much and when I when
I play they they draw they draw much
lower to players draw straws to you has
to play with me really yeah I'm not very
good
game I I I did get a couple tips from
kazm gam Ali who's a very strong Bug
House player but I I I need I need some
tips from y yaser so what makes a good
bug house buyer the tactics and the team
uh being aware talking to your a partner
uh can I trade Knights instead of just
trading Knights oh don't hold off for a
second you know and that that that
awareness I wanted to turn our attention
to a game that uh Maurice had pointed
out earlier it was that that game
between Alexander
Onish and AA Shandra uh they had reached
this position in the opening and axat
had very proudly played the move Queen
E4 anticipating that after a trade of
queens that he was going to get to the
superior ending he was shocked by
Alexander's move Queen D2 challenge
challenging black to capture the pawn on
G2 and after much deliberation he backed
off with Queen E7 and as a result of
those lost Tempi has now reached a very
poor position as Alexander Onish shook
with this move Knight H4 a very nice
move I really like this move very much
uh telegraphing his intention of playing
H3 G F4 and G4 trapping this bishop if
the bishop were to make a mistake and
try to step back to the G6 where in
addition this queen is now nicely ready
to come to F4 uh posting up attacking
this Pawn on D6 and unfortunately for
our us Junior Champion he's feeling the
heat right now and there's also some
dreams of getting a night on F5 one day
and we saw how devastating that was
early in the tournament I'm I'm
envisioning something like you get a
queen to G5 and a bishop to F5 and you
might be compelled the trade and then
once we get a night on F5 it's all over
checkmating patterns uh just erupt and
meanwhile Maurice has an update on a
game from the Women's Championship we
haven't really looked at yet yes this
game is interesting because black has
sacrificed upon or lost upon if you are
not a fan of this position Alysa Melina
against the young Akita gor who was only
13 years old and Alyssa played C4 in
this position with a threat and it
looked as though she was looking at
queenside expansion but a said okay I
will shut that one down only to see this
exchange occur on the board Bishop takes
Knight the most important Exchange in
all of Chess in my opinion takes and now
Queen takes on D5 Free Pawn just like we
saw Sabina grab a pawn in her game
against another youngster ashon now a
free Pawn again the Elder of the two
players saying I got a pawn except hold
on a second you might have a pawn but
you give up your light squared Bishop
for that pawn so AA play this move
Knight to E7 sacrificing yet another
Pawn go ahead take my pawns please if
you take this one Bishop to C6 and just
inspect the gorgeousness of those
Bishops raking the position instead she
played against Knight E7 Queen back to
D2 now Knight to F5 posting the Knight
on a fantastic Square in the position
anticipating the move Knight to C3 and
even here the engines are saying after
Bishop to C6 look at those Bishops this
bishop is awful this Knight might be
protecting this Pawn forever even in the
end game these Bishops look fantastic so
AIT gorti playing very enterprising
chess in this game and she looks like
she's solid you got a pawn but I got
some
pieces thank you Maurice and I'm just
looking at our U Board number one where
our tournament leader uh Fabiana caruana
has imbalanced the position and things
are suddenly getting very intriguing as
to what's going on in this game there's
going to be I think uh quite a tactical
slugfest in store and I'm not sure how
it's going to turn out uh Black's last
move was the move Queen A5 which looks
very good uh developing the Rooks are
finally now connected black catches up
to White in terms of connecting his
Rooks the queen on
A5 kind of menaces this Pawn on A2 as
well as keeping an eyeball over the
Knight on B5 but check this move out you
go F2 F3 now if you n naively move your
knight to this Square Knight C5 I I
spotted this tactic B3 B4 suddenly
forking Queen and Knight you've got to
take uh my Pawn I've got Bishop A3 and
guess what I'm skewering a knight there
are ideas of Bishop D3 where black is uh
might be able to turn the tables but
these are these tactics are something to
very much keep in mind and if I can
force the Knight the other way Knight G5
I was wondering if I can't somehow trap
these pieces these pieces look uh a
little bit out of sorts but this move H7
H5 was important that was why um Fabby
played it earlier in the game because at
this moment the bishop is not trapped
after the move uh G4 this takes and the
bishop can simply go to the square E4 so
things are beginning to heat up
I thought you were to talk about the
marit of night H and I was like yeah you
don't lose a piece but no no no I I
can't do that to at night and uh put the
Knight on E6 and Marie uh getting
interesting here in round five Super
interesting and another game that has
just lit up now is the game between
Karissa Yip and Agata by kosev check
this out Karissa has definitely broken
through she has everything a player
would want with the white pieces except
the presence of this night in the game
but pieces are still not developed the
castled king well what castled king
never going to happen and there's
pressure the breath five break is
through it looks like she has everything
she wants so Agata decided to fix her
Knight and bring it back to F6 a
dangerous Square to be sure because of a
possible Discovery but she is hitting
the he the E Pawn on e4 the engines like
to move Knight to D2 there was a problem
child that night bring it back into the
game but Karissa decided forget that
forget the pawn on e4 I'm going to break
through with takes on G6 avoiding the
ignoring the threat of the Pawn on e4
and now AATA is in deep thought over can
she take this to try to win material
well the response would be flicked in
another move ignoring a threat G7
hitting the Rook the Queen's under
attack yes but your Rook is dropping so
Rook to G8 would be forced and now the
move Queen to H4 and if you grab the
exchange now Queen h8
and The Rook will come back in her
pocket so that's the line she's analyzed
it's still not as good after Rook takes
h8 because you're up a rook after all as
the other line it's still not as good
knight D2 was a better move in this
position to be sure she should have just
calmly waited excuse me instead of
Knight instead of takes on F6 she should
have just calmly waited she had all the
trumps there was no need to risk
anything at all here just played Knight
D2 and play the position out but the
rambunctiousness of Youth couldn't she
could couldn't resist it and she took on
G6 now waiting for her opponent to come
up with a move in fact Agata has no
choice here Agata must take on e4 the
Knight is simply hanging G7 threats if
you just you can't take the knight's
hanging on F6 there's no choice so
whatever she's looking at she best she
just has to go in she's in the fire now
she must take on e4 meantime Carissa
looks like she's weaving something
playing with you know when Judith pogar
was 12 years old she came to New York
City to play in the New York open and
she had and There She Goes 94 was the
only move she had a pet lion I say pet
lion it was a little small miniature
lion that she would bring to the table
and the lion is going the way we
expected with G7 now and Rook G8 is the
only move to be followed by Queen
H4 uh she would have this Ling and
you're like who is this little girl she
got the little lion next to her she's
playing chess but she he played some
lionist moves boy you were just they
were dropping tactics all day long those
poar sisters but especially Judith
here's Karissa walk walking right into a
super sharp line having played like we
said maybe not the most accurate move
but now she's accurate moves but now
she's continuing in the main line Queen
H4 is to be expected right here but
Agata is going Toe to Toe in this
position and there's that move Queen H
for all the computer moves being found
by this young Phenom that's right she
played that with a little twisted of the
piece right confidence here confident
move well I can't blame her for I I
agree the Knight D2 was the more patient
quiet way of playing the position but
let's face it when you're 12 and you're
excited and you can see a line like
Queen H4 to h8 you can't control
yourself you got to go for it that will
only come with experience uh to look for
a better move but um I I'm just uh I'm
just so impressed by uh the young ladies
uh in this event they play really really
enterprising chess it's great remember
what Chris said yesterday about how she
felt like she had to beat all the
Juniors now to be fair she is higher
rated than uh I think all makes it for
maybe Jennifer you but you know higher
rated is in like 50 points or expected
score might be you know plus one or
somewhere between even and plus one
she's like I had to go 40 against them
exactly that's the kind of ambition that
uh really does create a champion what no
question and uh I think of myself as a
very provocative player but what vuan
aobi and today is doing against
weso is really un even more provocative
than the word provocative itself he's
just absolutely Stone Co challenging
Wesley so to come and get him um we left
it provocative the provocative I don't
know what the word is but it's it's
extreme let's put it that way and uh
Wesley uh sa very natural move 95 of
course we we we've been uh trumpeting uh
the attack based on G4 but Knight E5
certainly supports G4 we struggled to
find counterplay for black with the move
B5 because that would also weaken our C6
Square so instead of our trying to play
Bishop D7 hoping that white would give
up that Knight
now this was a bit of a surprise for me
this move Queen E2 arguably uh What uh
Wesley didn't want to see was the move
Bishop A4 which would have provoked B3
potentially weakening his Queen side a
bit or if you play Rook C8 first I would
actually come with a concrete threat
because after Bishop A4 B3 we would have
the move Rook takes D4 embarrassing the
queen on C2 so let's just continue A
variation so we can show our viewers
what we meant if White you know were to
go Whole Hog on the king side so to
speak with the moves G4 and H4 you're
mentioning that after Bishop A4 B3
thanks to the fact that this Rook is on
the C file we do have this uh
opportunity to play Rook takes D4
exactly and finally we find a position
where we like black yay took us a while
for our fans Queen E2 was played Bishop
C6 uh ignoring the pawn on G2 Rook G1
Bishop D5 uh what I think you were
trying to Checkmate me in just a very
similar way uh Jennifer well this this
comes with a little bit more bite
because at least he's trying to also
loosen up the uh the bishop on D4 which
is precisely what happen C3 C4 Bish we
can't play Bishop takes C4 because after
Bishop takes C4 um that does protect the
um Bishop on D4 and then the queen E2 um
holds the Knight on E5 so you have no
little tricky here okay C4 Bishop takes
G2 Bishop C3 and now I believe it's VAR
to play and he's basically opened up the
G file against his own King there are
all kinds of tactics in the position
including but not limited to Knight
takes F7 and queen takes E6 so VAR has
basically really issued an extraordinary
challenge uh one I would not have uh
mauce maybe the CH engines don't see
checkmate
the injes don't see Checkmate because
they're figuring it's time to trade off
some pieces with Bishop to B4 in that
position I'll come back to that in just
one quick second because I have another
position that is bananas this one
between kamsky and Jeffrey Jong Jeffrey
Jong has not lost a game yet out of four
in this competition signaling that yes I
might be the youngest yes I'm only 15
but you guys know I have arrived give me
a couple of years and I'm going to be
super dangerous but today he has to face
off against gakamsky who's looking to
make some kind of move in the
championship given his tournament
situation now we had pointed out that
the best move according to the injures
was to take on B6 Queen H4 was slightly
inferior it turns out only slightly
inferior but look at the reasons why
after this move Queen to H4 attacking
this bishop daring it to move we've
already seen the possibilities of being
able to chase this Knight away Jeffrey
anticipated and played KN back he is now
cleanly up a piece he's ahead by a full
piece in this position what does to do
he just simply takes on B6 now opening
the foul for his Rook A2 is hanging in
some positions and he's ready and
basically he says to Jeffrey what are
you going to move I hear you you're up a
piece but this piece is not working this
Rook is not working my late friend
Ronald Simpson used to say if your
pieces are not in the game they don't
count pick them up and throw them away
so bishop and Rook right now they don't
count if they get in the game we get you
but we're going to keep making moves
unless you prove to us that they're
working and look at this next move Queen
to D2 that's not one of those moves
trying to prove that this piece is
working or this piece is working and the
engines are saying black has full
compensation here white is up a piece
temporarily for one Pawn but with a move
like Bishop to G4 for example man you
got to feel the heat if you're Jeffrey
your king is stuck in the middle of the
board pieces are hovering everywhere
tactics all around now that game you had
mentioned this one here after Bishop
takes G2 he has the engines are trying
to sack exchanges as fast as possible in
this position first of all let's trade
off this dark squared Bishop it's a
dynamic piece and now when you play a
rook over to G1 you're like lining up
it's a attack the king and after Queen
to E3 then just saying you know what
kill this guy Now quickly get rid of
some pieces and bring the queen back if
necessary but the G the game is very
sharp even in this position Knight takes
Queen takes Queen Queen takes on H6 and
now the defensive Knight back to E8 and
black is saying I'm going to try to hold
on for dear life he has an he has a
bishop and a pawn for the exchange
engines like white here I think Wesley
would be very comfortable taking the
white pieces here and that he'd be able
to take care of business so it may not
be mate in the end but the technique of
Wesley so looks like it will win out
thank you Maurice and uh before I let
you go I just want to refer back
refer back to that God of csei game cuz
that's absolutely wild I thought the
move Bishop G4 was natural and automatic
Bishop F5 instead saying I'm a piece
down I don't mind being pieced down and
I'm still left scratching my head was
that a good uh Choice by gakamsky does
he have sufficient compensation for
examp he played the move I didn't
realize he actually played the move yeah
he's played the move Bishop F5 for
example after Rook
D1 is the
compensation enough there was a line
there's a line here let's go back Queen
D2 Bishop G4 I remember a line Rook D1
the engines no this move is not possible
because you can take on D4 now and
you're all the way through after Rook
takes A2 Rook to D2 and now in this
position take on E2 and the more you
take well now you're just losing your
uh because if you take you're going to
get hammered so well we should point
that variation out that here takes over
and it's going to be ugly there mate
threats you're ripping off all the pawns
you're up a whole bunch of Pawns so
there was some line I did not see I did
not see it appear in the analysis here
in this position to play Bishop E3 but
D4 was coming I'm surprised he didn't
play Bishop to G4 he opted instead for
this very solid move but Rook to D1
according to the engines you don't have
any move basically you're not getting
out of this bind wow it's just a bind
why can't we play Bishop C2 here so
Bishop C Bishop C2 I think you could
just take this piece take and then move
the queen again after this take which is
I mean the lines are getting crazy Rook
takes us Queen takes but now you move
the queen here and the best move being
given by the engine is Knight C6 or
Knight back to F5 completely crazy
position Bishop F5 is fine though
according to the engines Rook
D1 uh Rook
D1 uh did we get Bishop F5 on the board
Rook D1 here are the engine saying you
can play Rook to C8 preparing to get the
Rook into the C fou it even gives moves
like B5 let's just save our Pawn for now
wow I like this move it's interesting
Rook C8 is the move it's giving as best
uh the analysis but I really like this
move it's it says I'm taking my Pawn
it's not because it's I don't care about
the pawn itself I just like the fact
that he just made a move and said okay
your turn how do you un tangle this mess
that is created right here just how
exactly do you do it you're not going to
do it through G3 for example because
Queen E4 will come and it's even worse
what's going on to you right now you're
just weaking squares and this Knight
will show up this Rook will show up this
is just a big and if you play this move
this bishop will show up here and it's
just there's nothing to do there's just
nothing to do so what got has done he's
created a state essentially of just
domination your pieces have no moves you
have to sit there essentially and it's
up to Black to crank up the pressure
because white is completely undeveloped
on the king's side such a beautiful
conception not forcing the play letting
him stew in his own confusion and look
at Jeffrey he's like how do I get out of
this and there is no way to get out of
it according to the engines no easy
moves to figure out how to get the king
out of the middle of the board an
amazing bind a beautiful conceptual PE
sack in the REM reminiscent of tall you
would not expect this of gakamsky but
he's showing it right now that he's
making a bid to try to get back in this
us Championship wow this is probably one
of the most amazing cases of paralysis
for a player who head who is ahead a
full piece that I've ever seen it's
really an extraordinary conception and
just the fact that you could play a move
like B5 when you're whole piece down
which doesn't have any single threat to
it amazing it just says to White your
turn what are you going to do uh it
impresses
you blows me backwards W if he wins this
game and we have that game alongside
Fabiano carolan's win where he paralyzed
his opponent in round one mhm I think we
can put them side to side and maybe
rival
nimic go away go away I mean no those
two games like together as a pair though
just astonishing examples of zwang in
the middle game of course zwang usually
doesn't have happened in the middle game
there's been a big turnaround in the
cursa Yip game in which she did not
actually play the move Queen AJ that we
were expecting and since she simply took
on G5 so um we we'll look at that in
just a second but perhaps a slip for y
meanwhile we have a caller on the line
let us know your name and where you're
calling from hi hi my name is my name is
Alberto and I am a life coach
psychologist from New York City um what
an honor thank you for taking my call uh
Jen I just want to say first of all yes
sir Maurice for awesome job that you're
doing in promoting chess and you are so
personable it's it's your advice is
really Priceless and my question is uh
on the psychology of Chess and
specifically in terms of addiction
versus learning I remember reading uh
about the Soviet School of Chess and how
they would teach opening Theory and then
they would instruct their students to
play out the variations in five minute
Blitz Games so there was always an
objective so I was wondering what are
you throw at in terms of teaching
children's uh of evaluating when you are
just crossing the line uh on and what
are you thoughts on chess uh playing
Blitz game versus chess
addiction that's a great question well
shoot go for it Jennifer what are uh
what do you think well I think that
addiction it's it's a fine line because
sure people might get addicted to one or
three minute games but perhaps that uh
kind of propels their passion to chess
like a lot of times we Define an an
addiction whether it interferes with the
rest of your life and your other chess
studies so if you have time a negative
way as well yeah so if you have time to
play all those one minute games remember
Grandmaster Yuri Schulman a big promoter
of Chess in Chicago who used to come
second in these tournament how far
they've come that he's not even in the
event anymore he said hey you can play
as many one minute games as you want as
long as you look at the openings
afterwards I think you actually been
Blitz Games as long as you time to
actually look at those Blitz Games and
see did I screw up on move five in this
opening right interesting I was always
raised on I was raised on Blitz full
stop and end of story so uh nothing for
me to really comment other than the fact
that I enjoyed it a lot and uh actually
my parents and I uh made a compact with
one another CH they they treated chess
As a treat so only if I got good grades
in school and did my homework work and
did Shores around the house in a
gentlemanly fashion well then I got to
go and go and play in a tournament and
so for me uh it was never really an
obsession certainly not but definitely
definitely a passion very nice and if
you're going to be addicted to something
uh just not as harmful as other
addictions in fact not the worst
addiction not a bad idea if you're
trying to like quit smoking or something
to take up an interest in bullet chass I
think I somebody on chess.com wrote an
article about that but it's actually
kind of interesting because you know
that desire like that desire to smoke
doing something like where it's
completely harmless but it also kind of
activates your your serotonin as well
all right Checkmate Checkmate Checkmate
Maurice yeah I think the Call's question
is really intriguing actually before I
just get to this analysis because you do
see some players ruin their lives
playing chess all the time you do see
players get addicted to it I've seen
players in New York on the in the park
scene uh that's all they do and they
they don't work uh they they ignore
their regular lives I've actually seen
that happen and I think that it's an
important thing to do to make a
distinction between the time amount of
time you're going to spend playing chess
and the amount of time you're going to
spend working in your actual life and I
think that all of us have been blessed
enough to make the transition and the
combination of casual chess and serious
chess because we were really all about
becoming great players as much as we
could but there are some players who
just do do it exclusively so I think
that the question is as you said yes you
you had a great guide and a parent that
said look if you do all the right things
you're going to be rewarded by being
able to play as much chest as you like
but if you don't it's not going to
happen not everybody has that blessing
and so sometimes you have to really be
careful I think Blitz chest is wonderful
wonderful to development as long as you
use it as a training tool that to be
sure now that said this position is not
good for Karissa she decided to take the
knight in this position after Knight G5
we showed the analysis where she needs
to play Queen to h8 that was by far the
best move I'm really surprised because
she actually wins this Rook there's
nothing to do about this Rook coming off
the board so I'm shocked that she took
on G5 right now when Queen h8 was such a
very direct alternative Queen G5 is
greedy green Queen G5 is like I'm going
to I'm going to get the Rook later I'm
going to somehow figure that out but
that's not so easy to do in fact the
move F6 would have immediately gotten
rid of all these threats in the position
even though it looks dangerous to
confront this move with Bishop Czech and
this is probably why the move was
ignored King to E7 I think that this is
why she said look I'm not interested in
this position it's too unclear so why
play for it but the engines like white
here sorry like black in this position
so Queen takes G5 instead the move Queen
to E7 was played and this gives white a
little bit more of a chance because
Queen H6 is a move here and I think
that's this move this move actually the
F6 move answered by Bishop H5 check this
is probably why Karissa thought let's go
down this line because she doesn't get
rid of my G Pawn so easily after this
check so this let's give her that credit
that was her thinking because you're not
going to see Queen G7 happen anytime
soon so she probably thought let me go
for unclear play here and let's just say
black better solve the problems quickly
because there's also another Little Pony
looking to come to pasture all the way
down the board at H Pawn could be really
fast so she played Queen to E7 now the
best move Queen H6 was found is on the
board and that Queen E7 move not as
great as it could have been the next
move Bishop to B7 is possible the
engines giving moves like Knight to D2
and saying that black is doing equal
only in this position after a move like
Rook to G1 if you play F6 or even the
move Knight to sorry after F6 the move
Knight to
C4 eyeballing this Pawn on D6 not making
it easy to capture here if you take on
C4 now Bishop takes C4 now the E6 pawns
under threat so a very sharp position
has emerged here because of the slip by
Karissa but then the counter slip by her
opponent Agata but guess what this is
just sharp stuff it's easy to make small
errors in a position like this one no
question about it thank you Maurice and
uh boy I know we're due for a break and
we've got puzzles for you but take a
quick Gander at the game between hararo
Nakamura and Sam shankland this is Big
Time chess F4 F5 by Hikaru Nakamura
going after Sam's King at the cost of
the E5 Pawn he's got definitely evil
intentions of
checkmates uh opening up the file and
let me just get an update on the board
we have few moves so B takes C3 was
interpolated and then um f takes E6 by
Naka so after the move F4 F5 B take B4
takes C3 B takes C3 yeah that's right
that's right Knight takes E5 takes and
we're about to see and now we're up to
date after F takes E6 exactly wow okay
so uh the big question is do we spank
down 96 at once or the idea of course is
that you can't it may appear that this
Pawn on E6 is protecting protected no
way don't even think about capturing
that because Bishop takes D5 will cost
you your queen and this position is
getting wild looks pretty awful for
black though yes Maurice what's going on
yeah that one looks bad for black and
take a look at another game we've been
following where wild developments have
occurred as well in the game between
Jeffrey Jang and gakamsky Jeffrey
decided you know what I've got to get my
king out of there now I need to move and
unpin myself
and got to continued in the style of
tall and he played Rook takes on E2 a
nice sacrifice highly recommended by the
engines and after Bishop takes E2 now
Knight takes on D4 and he's down in
exchange he's gotten back at least in
exchange has got a kamsky but he has a
pawn for it and he's got a king sitting
on D1 and asking Jeffrey how you planing
to get your king out of the middle I've
got play I got all guns blazing the
engines are saying that black is the one
who's slightly better here the F2 Pawn
is hanging also their Maneuvers in this
position although F3 is the recommended
move this is going to be tricky to play
for both sides I think this look at this
move by the engine Bishop D7 as the
number one move completely ridiculous
kind of move in this position uh the
point I'm not even sure what the point
is yes you help me out here what is the
point behind such a crazy move I was
thinking you're going to move your night
here and go here what's the point of
that I don't know let's go back to this
and see if we can find a human
continuation here that's natural the
enges are saying moves like H5 Queen F6
it's not clear how white attacks how
black attacks white in this position so
that might be the only thing about this
position that's strange is it's not
obvious how you make the next few moves
you know we had a discussion at dinner
last night and I was seated next to
Lawrence Trent and next to him was
Fabiano Carana and Lauren said one of
the hardest things that he's had to
learn and he's seen it happen in his
games time and time again is the Art of
Doing
Nothing the point being that sometimes
you have a good position but there's no
straightforward way to go like you just
not going to win the game you need to
get more weaknesses from your opponent
maybe what you need to do is play a
waiting move for example here A Move
Like H5 might be possible uh dropping
back and just repositioning not with any
concrete threats
very hard to figure out what to do when
there's not really anything forcing to
do and your opponent just simply has a
position that has some coordination
issues which if they make some strange
moves they'll make the mistake it's hard
to be patient in those kind of position
and just simply improve your position
this is where God is going to face in
this exact position as F3 has actually
been played on the board by Jeffrey and
he's saying I don't see what you're
going to do and got may not have much to
do right now except say I have a good
position all dressed up not necessarily
with anywhere to go so we're going to
see how godowski shows The Art of Doing
Nothing in the next few moves or if he
comes up with something concrete that
doesn't necessarily lead anywhere and
gives Jeffrey a chance to untangle thank
you Maurice yes meanwhile we have um a
game which is just absolutely dominant
it doesn't even look like um Alexander
onuk um is just is all over Roat shra I
mean this this position is just
absolutely incredible it looks again
kind of like he must have sacrificed
material somehow to get this position
but the answer is no he hasn't he lost
so much time in the opening with the
poor development of queen7 E4 and look
at White's pieces really excellent you
you mentioned that you get a knight to
F5 good things happen well guess what
that's what's going to happen very
shortly and we actually have like other
options as well I mean this rookie a
rook pardon me Rook to E1 just the wh's
Whit's winning well white is absolutely
winning here this just looks again note
that when you play Knight F5 you're even
threatening something like Bishop takes
D6 because that night on E8 is
overworked it it just looks like totally
dominant here absolutely again a choice
of a choice of too many too many wins
perhaps um I just wanted to get in one
quick comment because uh we had a caller
the other day who had asked a question
how do you promote women's chess and uh
to our callers by the way we really have
enjoyed your questions a lot and we've
been discussing them during the show as
well even at dinner and we made a
discovery all the grand masters of the
world who ever won the who who ever
earned pardon me uh the grandmas title
uh who are women are alive today that's
right and we were starting to think was
it 32 or 34 of them 33 I think 33 33
women in the world are Grandmasters and
we were thinking to have a Gayla get
together inviting them all to one
occasion
and promote women idea a true Queen's
Gala huh and by the time you actually
organize this there'll probably be 40
especially with people like crissing him
shooting up so quickly true but I was I
just thrilled to that idea I thought
that was wonderful and if you think
about how quickly that's happened
remember that Alexander coost did you
because she's such a great promoter of
Chess I remember she did a a big
promotion when she earned the grandmas
title that she was the 10th woman so and
that was like not that long ago like
maybe years ago or something maybe so
that means that in the last eight years
we've tripled it ofmer Grand Master
deservedly so so pretty incredible um
and Maurice an update on the game
between Jennifer you and Nazi pidi who
the way she plays chess no question
about it if she played a lot more she
would get the grandmas title for sure
she her positional understanding is
fantastic her determination at the board
is incredible and her Fitness is off the
charts I went down in the Chase Park
Plaza today the gym to get my workout in
and there was Nazi on the treadmill
running away I mean she works out uh
every single day she is just a workout a
holic she's in the gym all the time and
this position is one of those reasons
why you can see she's about to dominate
Jenifer u in this position she's got a
nice Pawn on D5
making sure that her opponent has no
play you play the move E6 C4 came at her
Rook bc8 Rook A1 Queen to B8 a sort of
Hedgehog maneuver F4 chasing the Knight
Knight D7 B4 looking to dominate the
board look at these pawns the only minus
to these pawns potentially in the
Hedgehog is that you might see a
weakness happen that black can make some
breaks but there are no breaks to be
found B5 is not going to happen D5 is
nothing and there's this Knight thinking
about that juicy C6 Square which is
going to be completely dominating so
Nazi pinzi who has not lost in is it 15
games already in the US Women's
Championship 11 last year four more this
year and this one doesn't look like
she's going to lose I mean she is a
tough player to beat and she seems
determined her training regimen
absolutely just astounding looking to
prove that she's the fittest and maybe
the one to watch to to challenge Arena
crush's grip on the US Women's
Championship and uh I totally agree with
your Maurice um
nausey uh getting her chest Fitness and
her strength training her cardio in she
is really um inspiration they say uh I
think actually the St Louis chess club
put Monday inspiration because you know
people come into work kind of weary on
Monday and it's like look at this girl
yeah and uh we are going to take a quick
break we are going to hear from
Alexander shabala of the US Open
champion and four-time US champion as
well as Hall of Famer talking about
playing chess in a
[Music]
hurricane in 2012 uh I I was returning
from pretty successful tournament in
Argentina uh back to the US and decided
to play a small tournament in uh Bahamas
along the way we just landed 2 hours
before the whole region was closed to
Hurricane Sandy for pretty much a week
we were stuck in a huge Hotel literally
stuck there because you know outside
pressure was so high that you know 10
grownup men couldn't open the door in
the hotel you know outside there's no
power and there is a pretty scarce food
supply in it but we had to play the
tournament and so for the first time in
my life I played entirely by a candle
light from the round one till the last
round and I won that tournament that's
you know something to remember
[Music]
forever
oh
[Music]
n
for
[Music]
n
oh
[Music]
the
e
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round five of
the 2016 US championships and and US
Women's chess championships this is
around before the rest day we need a
special word for this
day the pregame
day something like that but it's been an
exciting round and uh across uh all the
tables I see the games have been heating
up uh gakamsky seems to be playing an
extraordinary brilliancy uh great game
also by Hikaru he's on he's on track uh
on shook is doing great just a lot of
things but we've got a puzzle Sol I'm
sorry that's right before we watch these
guys bust each other up let's watch
shabalov bust someone
up and note even though he's not uh
crushing anybody right now shabalov is
not doing so badly against Fabiano
Carana you know shabalov has won four US
championships he tied or one clear and
so he knows a thing or two about winning
chess positions and chess tournaments
major test tournaments he may be the
oldest player in the competition but we
all remember shaba in his days when he
used to get out the uh the sword and
just hack people to pieces and this
position right here he had against
current uh US Women's Champion Arena
crush this was back in 2009 before she
became a grandmas but he had this great
attack going in this position very
complex position exactly how do you
knock out your opponent here well I'm
sure those among you who studied this
carefully found the only way for white
to make serious progress in this
position was the move that shabalov
threw down Rook to B3 a fantastic move
in the position attacking the queen and
preparing to move the Rook over to the
devastating G3 Square where it's going
to be all she wrote you could throw in
the move like Rook takes with check but
the bishop comes back guards the back
rank you don't need anything but this
rook and queen to prosecute the attack
right now the threat of the queen
hanging on this square and The Rook
hanging on this one is all she wrote
however this move you'd have to
calculate let's see if you went a little
bit further and found a reputation for
Rook to d8 threatening a a mate in one
so you can't take the queen at all
remember the bishop is covered you might
have gotten confused in this position
because if you move your Bishop this
queen is coming down to C1 but the trick
here is the beautiful Rook to G3 check
anyway the point being now that if you
take this Rook the pawn takes and
suddenly the mate is gone so very nice
piece of calculation and what was a
short variation but in a complex
position sometimes you miss moves in
that case so shabalov with the move Rook
to B3 showing why he's known as one of
the greatest attackers well after all he
learned from mik tal from the lvan
school and of tall and shurov so no
surprise there that he likes to play
sharp attacking games thank you Maurice
well in speaking of uh sharp attacking
games I'm looking at this game of Wesley
slow so and verian AC akobian my my
Spidey Sense call Wesley slow don't call
wle so no no no he doesn't get in a lot
of time pressure actually but imagine if
Wesley so got in massive time pressure
every game then his nickname would be
too easy oh boy uh I just wanted to say
my spidey sense is tingling here um uh
Maurice and I was just looking at the uh
I want to sacrifice my pieces maybe it's
something in the atmosphere but Knight
takes F7 King takes F7 Rook takes G7 has
drawn my eye and my attention King takes
Queen takes
E6 uh no doubt I'm missing a key
resource for black uh but boy white
Black's King uh sure looks he's done it
he's played Knight takes F7 in this
position yeah there was something a foot
there it just it it it really smelled
like that type of position White White's
pieces were all primed for the attack
and it has been accepted King takes F7 U
Maurice I'm going to turn it over to you
love the way you found those moves yes
and he has found them as well all the
attacking players will be like hack and
hack and hack away and the prime reason
for that is this bishop on D3
participating in the attack we saw the
way shabalov also was able to move the
Rook over to the G5 hey G files are the
calling cards for attacks and so Knight
takes F7 believe it or not the engine
that Rook de1 was even better Black's
position is so bad that black can do
nothing about just relaxing with Rook
here threatening everything just leaving
all the clouds gathering over Black's
position but that's just a fine point to
make because this attack looks much more
human this is the kind of stuff we learn
from great school break them break down
all the defenses the key Point here that
these pieces hanging out on the wrong
side of the board while everybody else
is attacking and tal used to say like
people say well you know when you're
sacking as long as I'm removing
Defenders it doesn't matter what I'm
sacking actually as long as I'm removing
Defenders each move you can you're not
going to be left with anything to
protect the position with so this move
beautiful shot Rook takes with check and
then Queen takes and this one is bad but
black can try to hold on according to
the engines with the only reasonable MO
Rook to E8 in this position allowing
Rook check to G1 man I hear the computer
saying that this position is not
crushing right away you look at it and
it feels like there should be blood
spilling everywhere let's try a move
that looks natural to me Bishop F6 and
the engine is
giving the miraculous is that legit
miraculous Bishop to G2 as the only
defense wow amazing Bishop G7 is no
longer mate because you're not defended
by anything and getting in there is not
so easy and suddenly your Queen's under
attack yes the engine saying black is
better in this position so hold on let's
back up check he has played Rook takes
G7 and we're going down the line but
it's not it's not according to the
engines again the other move Rook de1
was better he's going into a line that
looks entirely natural must be accepted
now Queen E6 and the key right here is
for him to find this defensive move Rook
to E8 and now
wow Miracle of Miracles as the engines
keep going that line that we just showed
that was not good for white be because
of the queen coming across the engine's
now saying you have to find the
scintillating and very much uh in the
style of tall
C5 C5 in this position deflecting the
queen from the rank if you can find that
as your Intero deflecting the Queen the
bishop cannot leave because the Knight
is hanging and even if you bring your
queen back into the action well let's
just point this line out first queen
takes now Rook G1 check the king can't
move because now Bishop F6 and that's
going to be all she wrote M and seven
counting down there's nothing to do
about this and if you throw in Bishop to
G2 congratulations I'll just take it
nothing there because your queen was
thrown off from the rank so a fantastic
idea to move C5 now what can you do with
your queen is try to bring your queen
back into the ACT and here there has to
be precision as well because the queen
is attacking the bishop so the engine
just says cool Cal he can't do anything
Bishop to C2 first two absolutely
amazing moves C5 and Bishop C2 Wesley so
is almost 2800 he's going to have to
show all of that to find these moves
just simply incredible moves and now big
trouble the queen cannot move because
all of White's position is now ready and
the mate is on after Rook Che King back
and now Bishop takes on F6 and that will
be all she wrote there'll be no defense
to this you can throw something in like
Bishop takes you'll be mated on the spot
and if you can't take then you're just
dead wow that's just like it's hot in
here man amazing amazing line he's taken
on E6 this is the position on the board
we're raiding Rook to E8 and I'm
wondering if there's another move other
than C5 there are other moves being
suggested by the engine Queen G4 Queen
F5 but this is just a killer blow can't
we play Rook D1 check first and then
play C5 is there any kind of that looks
like that looks like a more natural move
order in a way doesn't it is there a
problem Rook G1 check and now C5
actually runs into oh Bishop there's
some kind of Bishop uh Bishop E4 huh
Bishop D5 leaving the queen hanging in
the air but your queen is now under
attack and suddenly the queen is back in
the in the fold we should point out by
the way this game is so crazy we should
point out even here the engine saying
you could slow foot it and play this
move getting your queen out of the rank
as well remember that game uh Arena
Crush the game that Alyssa mahina had
against Arena Crush Alyssa had so many
wins and the most accurate moves were
just like you're dead Okay you didn't
play the death move but that move it
looks good enough too and oh you're dead
again oh but you didn't play the most
accurate move to kill her and and then
slowly but surely it got down to well
now you're you're getting down to a
smaller window that's take a look at
that that game because aob also only has
28 seconds left in the clock he I
totally agree with Maurice about that
Queen F5 because I do think
C5 uh Wesley definitely capable of
seeing it but if he man if he plays the
more natural Rook G1 um he's probably
going to see the bishop G2 tactic at
that
fo we're looking at Rook E8 but Rook E8
wasn't even played R in panic mode
partly probably because of the time
pressure is actually just taken on F2
not even defending his Bishop on E7 oh
no that that is lights out Queen takes
on E7 we don't even have to calculate
this line that just is horrible
situation for him in this position uh
the Knight is going to hang he just
played the easy he can resign yeah this
is just completely he can resign he just
he just played a move that made no sense
back Queen takes check King back to G8
Bishop H7 check as yaser just pointed
out on you can't play Knight takes H7
Queen G7 made and um we're expecting a
resignation right now should resign a l
on time exactly at this moment it's a
time to resign just totally punished in
this game you see him looking over at
his clock right there he will be
reaching his hand out as he looks at
this position because Bishop F6 there's
nothing to look atly there's nothing to
look at and there he goes a beautiful
attacking demonstration by Wesley you
got to give your hat tip that was a
scorer that was beautiful night
sacrifice Rook sacrifice and we talk
about best game of the tournament if got
ends up winning that zugang and we have
this game it's like how would you even
choose between those two say but Fab's
games I have to say guys fabulous based
on what you just said alakin had a quote
where he said uh he was always angry at
his opponents that they played the
easiest defenses right and spoiled his
brilliancies Right Wesley got this easy
win of course but it would have been so
nice if you got a chance to play a move
like C5 and Bishop C2 and then we would
have said oh wow look at that now
everything is hidden in the variations
because his opponent played this move
Queen F2 and just laid down I could not
give this one the brilliancy prize over
other games it requires uh good
uh resistance and unfortunately Queen F2
was a collapse but these two Quiet Moves
C5 and Bishop C2 after sacrificing a
knight and a rook wow he would have won
the brilliancy prize which we don't have
and we've got Grandmaster Alejandro
Ramirez he's outside with some insights
into this thrilling round so
far hello guys we've had a spectacular
round so far of course Wes liso has just
defeated vuan akopian in a fantastic
game he sacrificed pieces and made it
look like black had no defense but I
want to point out something out guys and
is this common in this tournament
especially in this round and it's like
we analyze the position we analyze the
board but that's not all there is to it
this guy is also a big factor the clock
is a huge factor in chess games look at
this position right now if hoban's given
an hour to figure out this position what
are my defenses what are my resources he
can sit down and maybe find this
miraculous resources that Maurice was
pointing out with rookie a somehow
holding on to the position but he didn't
have the time not only did he play a
game that was quite frankly mediocre in
the fact that his peace development was
weird but he just didn't use his time
properly when the key situation comes
he's unable to find that defense that
might have saved the Half Point might at
least have made it much harder on Wesley
so to actually find the winning
continuation and it's something that
we're also seeing in a couple of other
games AKA Chandra today not only today
in all the games of this tournament but
today specifically against Honis chuk is
using his time very very poorly he's in
a very difficult if not lost situation
and you need to use that time to find
defenses he wasted his time in the
opening and now he cannot hold on to the
game also in the women's section the
most complicated game in that section
right now is the game between karisa Yip
with white against Agata vov in a weird
situation where okay one side is up the
exchange but there's a pass Pawn on G7
it's really hard to evaluate but what's
the difference kice is ahead on the
clock by half an hour that's such a huge
Advantage right now I think that the
players are underestimating severely how
fast they have to play and how this
clock matters in the game we're going to
see a lot of games a lot of half points
being dropped because of time
mismanagement great game by Wesley so a
deserved victory for him for sure but
you have to look at the fact that there
are people that are not in shape I'm
looking at acopian I'm looking at AA
Chandra that are not using their time
management properly and for me this is a
huge huge minus in an in a in games of
this caliber well we're going to go back
uh with Maurice Jen andas and I'm sure
that westa will be joining us soon in an
interview thank you alandro wi words
have never been spoken uh the clock is a
part of the game like it or not you it
does spoil brilliancies and um it makes
fools of us all but using your clock
wisely is a key part of being an elite
player and uh VAR uh poor poor clock
management Chandra as well um
consistently poor uh clock management
and so he's he's has a lot to work on
and to improve he will learn a lot from
this tournament no doubt and no doubts
we do have a vovan definitely a popular
Grand Master from our fans he has so
many videos on our St W's YouTube
channel but today they were not happy to
see him squirm he's with Maurice
Ashley with grandmas vuan akobian VAR
today that French you played allowing
him all these potential angles of attack
didn't seem to work out what happened uh
well I think it's very concrete actually
because uh when I took on G2 I could
have maybe even played Bishop C6 I mean
it's just a uh I think it's a typical
position it's maybe white white is
slightly better there but uh I spend all
my time trying to work to Bishop B
before lines because uh but then I just
you know Knight takes F7 and probably
should have still played it since I
already spent all my time but uh yeah I
just missed this very nice nice idea he
had at the end uh with the because after
I play Bishop C6 I I thought if he
doesn't do anything immediately I'm
going King f8 next move and uh maybe
it's not that bad but uh yeah he had
some sacrifice but looks like I had some
kind of Defense but I didn't have time
to find it so that was the question that
Alejandra just brought up the issue of
time why so long looking at all these
variations and then managed to not play
the move that you thought best well I
had 35 minutes when he played uh
again it was very sharp so I had to
calculate like when I
played U Bishop D5 C4 Bishop G2 I had to
calculate the lines for example with
Knight F7 immediate sacrifice so I had
calculated that that didn't work for him
but then he played Bishop C3 very
quickly and I kind of a little bit
overlooked this idea I saw it but it
wasn't my main idea and I think I just
uh should have just played Bishop before
even if it's not working out then just
you know but it's very sharp and if it
works out maybe I'll be find there but
yeah I just missed this nice sacrifice
he had great game by him for sure so how
do you reset you got a rest day at least
yeah yeah I just uh you know I had a
tough pairing in this tournament I block
against all the top seats so it just
kind of tough and U you know I'm
not I had some chances yesterday and you
know I haven't been taking my chances
and uh yeah definitely been struggling
with black so far in the tournament so
hopefully after the rest day I'll play
better there will six rounds to go lots
of ground to make up we uh hope you get
some rest guy yeah thank you guys back
to you thank you V thank you uh Maurice
uh game that definitely has had our
attention is uh the game of uh gakamsky
but I also wanted to refer to the game
of our defending US champion Hikaru
Nakamura who seems to be playing
brilliantly today I think that uh
yesterday's game against Fabi was
definitely a wakeup call for our
defending Champion as he's just playing
a clinic on uh Sam Shanklin looking very
very powerful indeed he's up upon with
well simply an overwhelming position Sam
shanklin's going down in this one Echoes
of round one in the fact that uh so many
of our top seeds Nakamura kamsky and so
um putting on such displays yeah real
master class
and speaking of the master class himself
Wesley so is in our studio that's right
congratulations beautiful game right
before the rest day he's with Maurice
well an absolutely scintillating game
there's no final point to put on that
one Wesley you must have been pleased to
see him just give you these two Bishops
aimed at your aimed at his King the G
file you must have been looking your
chops thinking there got to be something
here yeah I was very pleased actually um
he played today's P line which is the
reinstein French where he a for
exchanges and I played this
C3 which uh was inspired because Kasper
played it 14 years
ago maybe he will play it if I get to
the
blitz but uh I think I did some pretty
good preparation today I have until his
H6 wait instead of Rook d8 I think in my
after Queen a okay H6 castling long
Queen A5 King B1 I think B5 would be his
best move here I remember correctly I
had some notes
and so I thought B5 Bishop E4 with a
unclear position and he was taking a
long time but then he played Rook d8
which uh gave me bless on play I I would
uh were you thinking now that kingside
attack is coming you're going to
eventually play G4 and F4 H4 some
combination yes um that was my main idea
but of course my king is on the queen
side so he has some counterplay like
Bishop A4 or something but he he didn't
he didn't go for it in fact in instead
of Knight E5 I was thinking of even more
brutal ideas like Rook hg1
here with the idea of a quick G4 G5 this
also looks uh highly dangerous for black
and uh he has to go now Bishop D7 G4
Bishop A4 B3 and perhaps after Bishop A4
B3 he has no time to play Bishop C6
because of G5 and sooner or later he
will have to sacrifice Rook takes D4 but
uh to get rid of that B I decide to play
more safely but
at the end of the day couldn't control
myself well let's take a look at that
position and work us through the lines
because they're just so nice uh in what
else could he have done here if we can
bring that position back up when he took
on G2 first of all when he play Bishop
D5 and then and then allow this to
happen yeah yes I was were you thinking
that this was like no I'm going to
destroy your king now well that's what
I'm hoping of course but uh you you
never know I'm not a computer I make a
lot of mistakes thankfully my opponents
also make some mistakes did you what did
you think about this move Bishop to B4
he said he spent all his time on it yes
Bishop B4 and here I have uh two good
options the simple option just to take
and B4 and then play Rook G1 Bishop
C6 Queen E3 and then now he has to go
King f8 and here I have a lot of
tempting options but uh he's still a on
up so maybe it's not so clear so instead
of this I was going to play
F7 and then uh we just found out after
the game by looking at Chris Cher last
computer says Rook D3 is the only move
for black then I saw this Knight takes
H6 check and King h8 Rook takes
D3 Bishop takes
C3 Rook takes C3 and then G takes eight
Knight and this I think this is all
forced
hm uh I'm not sure if G takes Knight
maybe bishop E4 check first and then
King A1
gh6 and I I think this line is almost
fourth I would not want to play this
with the black pieces the king looks
terrible and White's King is just tucked
in the corner yeah that's true and um he
has two pieces but I have a rook and a
pawn so and I Al he also has many
weaknesses so again as in my game
against aad I'm not risking much right
absolutely I would have uh he would have
refer this to what happened to him
though because what he did I mean it was
just a a massacre after you got this
chance to play to this position now the
engine yes gave the move Rook to E8 as
the only way to continue the game in
this position what did you thought about
yes I saw this but I was kind of praying
that he wouldn't find it I mean when I
sacrificed my Rook he has two minutes so
you know he I thought Rook E8 Rook G1
check King
f8 now here Rook G1 King f8 and here I
have to play a bit more careful because
if I take on F6 Bishop F6 which looks
over at first side Rook G8 and Bishop G7
is made black has the amazing defense
Bishop G2 yes we did see this with the
engine and absolutely fantastic defense
this is what I actually missed I thought
black is just lost when I sacrificed
that I see so I missed this so I I have
to be careful so what was your plan then
if if this had transpired
rookie well to be honest my plan was uh
to to flag on
time it's similar to Ray's game
yesterday Ray uh several times went to
one
second so if aan went to one second my
plan was to to scream and
surprise well it turns out that you did
have a fantastic win even in this
position given the position if we can
pull that back up uh you had a couple of
ways actually to go Rook G1 and queen
Queen F5 wasn't bad but the move C5 was
was the move to stop him completely cuz
his Queen gets deflected uh now so C5
Queen dat Bishop C2 ah then now he has
to take my Rook now yeah now you win the
queen because of Rook G1 so I'm sure
You' have found something powerful that
may have caused him to flag but also
Rook G1 and queen F5 was also quite
strong in that position so I'm sure
you'd have found some natural moves to
keep it going I have I have 45 minutes
you know I I got a feeling that when he
let his time run down he was hoping for
a similar thing as what happened to aad
that they would my opponents would go to
one minute and then I would try to flag
them and then I would make a BL make a
I'm sure you've learned from that
already and also it's interesting though
this is the second time you've come here
and said you had a brilliant two
brilliant attacks I mean you two of the
most centilating attacks in the
tournament so far you played against
godowski n of five and you hadn't worked
everything out you just you're you're
very intuitive with your attacks knowing
that they're good and they've proven to
be absolutely good your your positional
intuition around the attack seems to be
quite sound I uh that's very flattering
I hope to do better actually to be
honest I was inspired by your comments
on the game one which you said you're
hoping for a very exciting tournament so
I'm dying my
best well we appreciate that for sure
you play Naka tomorrow well not tomorrow
to after the rest day what are your
thoughts on that matchup well that would
definitely be a very important match and
uh that would be a very exciting match
and I cannot predict what would happen
um you know he's one of the best players
in the world and I have a lot of respect
for him actually he's the fourth time US
champion
um but I'm the same time you know I'm
hoping for my first
so absolutely well playing chess like
this certainly qualifies you in my book
let's hope you keep up the scintillating
we'll call it play scintillating so that
might turn turn to be your nickname
quite soon uh thank you well I had uh 12
consecutive draws in tata steel so I'm
very glad that it's not happening here
no we are glad too congratulations on a
fantastic game thank you very much
Wesley so we got to throw gold coins at
this guy on an incredible day at the
office we all just got presents from the
wonderful staff at the S question yeah
yeah
well no no no don't go away Wesley um
first of all our congratulations you're
you've really been entertaining us and
today was really uh uh very very special
um you've been playing great attacking
chess and I'm sure for a lot of our
viewers how did you develop that sense
uh that you show today that you you
there was something in the position you
look for it you found these sacrifices
how did you develop your Tactical
awareness um well that's not an ethic
question to answer because that's what
all the chess players are seeking to
achieve you know to to improve their
game
overall um but at the same time like
Magnus I have analyzed a lot of uh
classic classical games by the world
champion so it's not really that easy
and
uh actually before the game I
didn't that such a game like this would
happen so it's
um I suppose it's not not really an
answer it's a not not you said you
analyz all the the games of the great
Champions I did I'm sure you looked at
aline's games I was I was thinking tall
played today you must have looked at T's
games yes and also magnus games you know
Magnus interesting so
um um yeah I think Magnus is the best
player in the world right now so of
course I've studied almost all of his
games and uh the good thing about him is
a complete all-around player not only is
is he really good at pushing a small
Advantage but also when it comes to
tactics he is uh ex extremely
dangerous yeah he's played some
wonderful attacking games as well yeah
yes always fa to analyze the great
Champions but I think a lot of people
are going to be starting to analyze
Wesley Soul's
games I also I also admire
professionalism Wesley um and I have to
ask um obviously this opponent last year
marked like the the worst moment of your
tournament um was that on your mind this
morning um well
actually what happened last series the
pass is more than a year already so if
actually fak's good I'm ready to move on
um I wasn't really thinking about it
before the game but um this is I think
this is just another
just another game for me and I had
whites so I felt obliged to to
push
um also he went for this line in the
French which uh I was relatively well
prepared so I I think it it it went well
today um I would say
so but yeah last year was a very
difficult tournament for me but uh as
they say the first is always the hardest
and this is my second year now in the
you Championship also this year is uh
going to be very exciting for me I
believe uh I'm very excited I'm not sure
how I will do but um I've been invited
to a lot of uh big tournaments so again
I would like to thank uh Rex singfield
for um inviting me to play in all the
grandchester
tournaments so uh I'm really excited and
I'm also nervous on how I will
do so for four tournaments I will be
facing Karana and Nakamura so we'll be
seeing each other a lot of times and
uh yeah I'm nervous and excited and
we're we're excited for you too
certainly deserving showing your your
immense talent and it will develop over
time we're sure still young fantastic
games thank you so much Wesley for
joining us thank you so much to the
three of you excellent commentating
thank you thank you Wesley and
congratulations just for a great great
game I'm sure it'll go in your uh best
Games Collection when eventually you get
around to writing a book but clearly he
got a great career in front of him and
the grand chest tour is going to be
fabulous Wesley in the mix and it's also
great for our tournament because Fabiano
Carana having played um so many of the
tough opponents already and also half a
point ahead of the field you know we
didn't we don't want him to run away
with MBA we love Fabby but the more
exciting the tighter the tournament is
the better it is for us ab and so with
Wesley winning this game he's keeping
the he's keeping Pace absolutely because
Bob's probably not going to win today so
that would keep them tied for first it's
still a very blockaded position that's
going on between Alexander shabalov and
Fabiana Carana I've pulled it up on my
board uh the last few moves uh there was
this queen trade uh it's not the shabal
off that he kind of promised us or that
we promised ourselves uh instead they've
gotten into an ending with seven ponds
aside well me excuse me six ponds for
each side so it's pretty blocked but I'm
just wondering if shabby can do anything
here um on a good day you see this
bishop on G7 is really kind of uh well
it is block behind uh its pawns as well
as the White Pond this Knight on C7
keeping the black king at Bay there
might be something here but then it's
two Bishops meanwhile what's happening
in Kissa Yip vers bat well we've seen
some Wild Games already and it continues
in this game and it looks like Karissa
Yip has cemented the idea she had in the
beginning where she could have gone for
that slight Edge after Queen h8 but she
said no no no I want to play this kind
of position plays H4 and making her Pawn
felt to join this Pawn on H on G7 and H5
going down the board after F6 he said
nope you're not getting my G Pawn King
to D7 and now Queen H7 looking to play
H6 F5 the engine still like like black
here Queen dropping back not want to get
buried on that square Knight to F7 not
the necessarily the best move here Queen
G6 Knight E5 Queen A6 they repeated for
a couple moves and she said you know
what I'm leaving I want to play the move
86 and here the engines are giving moves
like Rook C7 nothing clear Rook C5 but
D5 is a no no and that allowed the move
Rook to G6 by the way H6 was very strong
in that position she missed that shot
both of them now down in time pressure
at least that is bov in time pressure
having to make seven moves and here she
played the mistake Knight to E5 and that
move was met by the Monstrous Rook takes
E6 very simple to hit this move down
Queen takes on G7 is on the board and
now we're waiting for the next move in
the position it turns out that after
Knight to E5 sorry back here on D5 that
a move like H6 was definitely stronger
but Rook G6 Knight E5 we have a chaotic
position Queen takes she's gotten rid of
the G pawn and now the engine's giving
the move Rook to D6 with cck you can't
touch it because of this capture and you
have to be careful going on this side so
chaos actually on the chess board now a
wild position as the youngsters are
duking it out in that game thank you
Maurice and real Unity there for Karissa
uh as I'm wondering about the time the
clocks I can't see them too well but
after these results what are our current
standings uh Jennifer well we only have
a couple results in the tournament so
far but we do see that coming into today
Carana had three and a half and Wesley
so winning his game will catch aano
Carana if he does not win this game so K
needs to win to stay ahead of the field
going into the r day so but basically uh
Wesley's in first at the moment Wesley
is in first at the moment indeed and
meanwhile in the Women's Championship
we've got Irena and Tate naazi all tied
for the lead um last time we checked
Nazi's position it was quite Pleasant
and last time we checked Irena and Anna
zamsky relatively balanced of course tth
has already drawn so will any of these
players be able to get to to Four Points
and take a lead going into the
reste very good let's take a look at our
our Champions battle arena Crush vers
Anna zatonski has it
um Arena gotten anything to chew on let
us have a quick Gander at that one even
P slightly better pwn structure but
business color first impression nope so
it looks very very even Steven to me
right so black Anna could even at some
point just try to trade off that pawn
the only weakness in the position right
now C5 very easy uh draw it appears is
going to happen
Maurice yeah while those games are quiet
this next game is wild Ray Robson versus
Alexander Lenderman Ray Robson just a
half a point out of first and making a
bit to TAA first in this crazy position
with opposite side castling I mean the
players are really going for it every
single game now we see the move Bishop
takes on e4 giving up his light Square
Bishop around his King so he can get in
this move A5 the queen in trouble having
to try to defend this bishop so he said
forget the bishop I'm ditching it for
your Bishop a fork here on these two
pieces and Ray went after the best move
Rook takes on C5 Queen takes on F4 and
now this move F3 you don't see this
formation every day the Knight on H4
ready to go back to G2 to protect the
position and now this bishop having to
move and if Bishop back to G6 the
engines are saying that looks like a
pawn I'll take it
of course the king looks a bit weird
this setup with all the dark Square
weaknesses but nothing Concrete in the
position for black so Ray waiting for
the next move we're still on the Move F3
the next move I believe has not been
played as yet yes we're waiting for
lindaman's next move but if Ray Robson
wins this game he leaps frog Carana and
he will be in Soul first no actually
Wesley Wesley he and Wesley were tied so
he'd be tied for first making a bit to
come back and show that he is trying to
win this tournament for sure
thank you Maurice uh just across the
board lots of things going on I think
that nji by the way is winning or yeah
simply winning she's going to capture a
pawn in her game so she will be a
definite factor in case Arena and Anna
draw with one another which looks like
it's um imminent honestly and meanwhile
Nakamura versus Shanklin let's take a
look and see how close our defending
Champion is to reeling the win here it
looks like every piece on the board is
in
tank true that so uh the last uh moves
uh were this move Knight D3 uh it's
funny to say forking the queen and the
Knight right but that's what it does it
attacks both Knight takes D3 was forced
by Sam Shanklin then came Queen takes D7
and oops this Knight on D3 is hanging
this Knight pardon me this Rook on C8 is
hanging Knight F Che that's forced Fork
uh King G1 was was played and we're up
to date the problem is the in between
moves here because if Knight takes D1 we
play Queen takes C8 check and then um at
that point it's over it's just totally
over yeah I mean we we can even make the
position more simple by bringing our
rook in after King G7 and yeah exactly
so it looks like Rook will have to go
over to f8 now again um
basically I I see white as dominating
the game
hereu you know getting out of the attack
of the Knight play Rook D2 with a Tempo
if the queen drops back pardon me if
Queen goes to F6 Queen goes to C3 Queen
to D4 and forcing the trade of Queens
with this fantastic Bishop on G2 the
Knight on F2 this game is really hakaru
to win and that would be
um oh well pardon me there's well I
apologize there still Knight takes H3
I've got to make sure I don't somehow
allow such tricks well in this initial
position we can maybe just go for the
queen trade immediately with the queen
D2 or queen D well probably Queen D2
because uh Queen D2 forcing the trade of
Queens uh oh oops but there is a cute
counter check this one how about Rook to
E7 very very nice hello check and
followed by the queen coming to G7 check
and M oh but Queen D2 threatens Queen H6
so we can play Queen D2 and then after
Knight D1 Queen 8 chicks and Bishop
D5 so Queen D2 so Queen D2 if you take
on B uh D1 just a second Jennifer I'll
catch up with you Queen D2 take on D1 I
have Queen H6 Queen H6 and then after
King G8 there's a bishop D5 and I
yeah you definitely well that you
definitely the other Rook probably but
then you then we have Rook e eight check
so either way you're good point that's
that's actually just mate that's just
mate and it looks like all of the
tactics are actually facing white yeah
and if you trade if you trade the Queens
your Knight's actually trapped isn't it
I mean you could play you can't go to E4
or H3 so youd have to just go r eight
and uh Maurice yeah you guys are
choosing about whether or not you shoot
him with a G or chop his head off with
an axe I mean that one's over and both
lines you guys suggested are dead so
Nakamura knows this game is over he's
going to get the win but I've got to
tell you this game with Jeffrey Jang and
gakamsky that fascinated us earlier I'm
even more impressed now by Young Jeffrey
Jang playing against the top players in
the country in his first tournament and
he is just showing that he belongs the
moves gakamsky played the rest of us
lesser lights we would have fallen down
a long time ago
but Jeffrey is holding on for dear life
and is showing that he's not prepared to
lose this game anytime soon well he is
in a little bit of time pressure so he's
going to have to gidy up but in the
meantime he just held on so powerfully
rookie one Bishop E6 Rook to C3 guarding
as much as possible and now Bishop F1
and Nakamura has won the game has
concluded in that game but we expected
that Bishop B5 Knight D4 Bishop back to
F1 Knight F5 Rook to D 3 D4 G3 Queen F6
and now King to E2 preparing to bring
his King over the engines are saying now
that the position is equal triple zeros
hard to imagine how you assess all of
that right away but the main point is
this king is ready to come to this side
right now black is going to have to be
careful to get back some kind of
exchange soon because he's only up one
Pawn for it and white is stabilizing so
young Jeffrey Jang playing like a
worldclass Defender he's resembling Kaki
right now the way he held on in this
game completely impressive 15 years old
but his clock is a problem with only 6
minutes to play 11 moves it's going to
be for move 30 actually we'll see if he
can somehow hang on he's going to get
the 30 second incr as well but man
impressive defense from this 15-year-old
we're seeing it all here at these
championships aren't we great attacking
uh games and a marvelous marvelous
defense I mean lesser play lesser
players would have collapsed a long time
ago against uh the pressure that uh
gotsky brings to the game and for 15
years old you just got to tip your hat
and say Well done young man uh to
stabilize his position is quite an
achievement and again that clock that's
that's a factor uh to watch out for the
young Fighter versus the veteran fighter
got kensky of course known for his
incredible fighting spirit and there's
God's time too God's uh clock is ticking
down now you were mentioning Naji pidi
might take a lead going to the rest day
in the Women's Championship right she
against Jennifer U she looks like she's
going to go over there and snap o that's
interesting I thought she was just going
to snabel a pawn we we got to this
position Queen B6 Queen
C7 uh by Jennifer I didn't anticipate
this move Rook D4 I thought she was
simply going to capture this Pawn on A6
first um that was not her choice she
played Rook D1 now Rook C4 Rook takes
Pawn takes we're up to date with the
position and now it's
still now I'm confused well there's
still some tactics so like you can't if
we take on a A6 we've always got that
that back rank idea so if Queen C6 here
we have a rook to d8 check um picking up
a rook or a queen right um so
Queen takes A6 will just simply grab the
pawn then yeah so Queen takes A6 anyway
grabs a pawn but is there any
counterplay for black with the move C3
well not just that but I mean the king
the king is your Rook is hanging at the
moment oh I beg your pardon so you have
to play C3 apologize but it this does
seem like it it perhaps requires a
little bit more Precision from uh naagi
and so now what if we go for the same
idea with Rook D7 do you have some kind
of evil intentions here probably C2
because you got kind of Runway Pond
there that have to so there is counter
place not as easy as we thought and we
have a special guest in studio that's
right we've got Grandmaster Sam Shanklin
and he is with Maurice Ashley about
today's difficult
loss Sam Shanklin Sam this was a tough
game to be sure what went wrong H I
don't know I think I just approached the
game all wrong um I wanted to get some
super fighting position and I somehow
ended up really passive and just bad
opening choice I think after G3 I should
have done something different I just
sort of feared his preparation probably
too much because he was blitzing out
moves I think it just got really bad
really fast how how hard is it give us a
sense those of us who have no idea how
hard is it to have to prepare against a
player who's one of the top 10 in the
world funny funny enough I've never had
issues with preparing for Nakamura in
the past I think I've prepared him
almost every game we've played uh there
was one exception before that and that
was the one time he beat me um and then
uh yeah I guess this makes it too so if
I prepare him I hold and if I don't uh
oh I lose but I don't know somehow I
thought he was going to play E4 I even
checked this um this Knight C3 Knight F3
but I I hadn't check this G3 move and I
of course black should be totally fine
but I just couldn't figure out the way
to put my pieces at the board going into
the rest day how do you assess your
situation in the tournament it's I mean
it's a tough loss today obviously it
could be better um but you know what I
have an even score against like the 2680
average or something it's you know it's
certainly far from a disaster it's just
sort of a normal result for me um uh you
know there's still a lot of chest left
to be played and you now now that I've
got the three big guys out of the way
which they they dealt me some pain but
uh I think I can start coming back and
uh I think I I think get shal after the
rest day so uh who's been a tough
opponent for me in the past but I beat
him at millionaire so maybe I can
hopefully make it two in a row
all right well get your rest and get
back on track thanks for joining us
thanks quite a roller coaster right for
Sam he mentioned last year he had quite
some lot of draws only three decisive
games here he is after five rounds with
four decisive games out of the five
rounds so quite a roller
coaster let's let's take a look at Ray
robson's game because he's almost um
he's only on 30 seconds we do have two
um results in the tournament so far so
has won against akobian and Nakamura has
won against Shanklin so two
pre-tournament favorites prevailing but
yeah Ray Robson another pre- tournament
favorite he's playing against Lenderman
and it looks like he's got 38 seconds on
the clock with 15 moves to make um
position not looking too shabby he's got
um well this is uh typical of Ray Robson
I mean I know John Donaldson team
captain was pulling his hair out because
uh was obvious getting into Perpetual
time trouble in many of his games but
Alex Lenderman is facing a problem as
Maurice Ashley was showing that as soon
as the bishop moves back there is this
Pawn on D5 hanging it's all about the
clock uh for R and instead Queen G3
check actually occurred followed by
Knight to G2 so even though it looks
like that Queen's getting in there you
don't have time to uh snack on a pawn
you still have to move your Bishop out
of attack well there is and instead
rookie eight happened lender um yes
there's has played the move Rook to E8
there's a pin on along the third line no
the other Rook oh sorry Rook on hd8 Rook
on H this move has been played so not
easy for Robson considering that he only
has 45 seconds in the
clock but we do have a special guest our
defending Champion hikaro Nakamura he
won today and he's wearing a beautiful
purple
shirt style matters yes with Hikaru
Nakamura and Jenna always notices the
fashion stuff so we don't talk about it
too much uh yesterday you had a tough
loss but today you bounce back in fine
style how'd you get your head clear so
that you can play today's beautiful game
um well you you you kind of just have to
keep going uh there there are many
rounds in this tournament and uh it's uh
even after a loss like yesterday you you
always have chances so you just try and
play good chess and uh today I I mean I
I got a very nice position on the
opening against Sam and uh and after
that um it was just difficult for him to
play and so I I got an advantage and I
was able to convert it pretty smoothly
did you feel when just right out of the
opening like this one's going to be mine
like really confident just from the
opening moves well once once Sam didn't
trade Queens in the opening uh I I had a
good feeling I mean I I kind of didn't
want to play something super slow today
so when he didn't exchange Queens in the
opening um and instead he just you know
played a game uh I was quite happy and I
I had a good feeling throughout so I I
don't think I was ever in any danger
going into the rest day what are your
thoughts there's still six rounds to go
um well overall I mean my result is okay
I mean I'm I'm obviously uh very unhappy
with the third round game especially
after seeing seeing what's transpired in
onos scheme against the aforementioned
player so uh I mean I'm I'm not very
happy but but still uh there are many
more rounds to go and uh I think I play
Wesley next round so uh anything can
happen but but more importantly I'm just
going to try and play play good chess as
as I've said before because uh that
that's really all you can do and when
you start worrying about the tournament
situation or what's going on I mean no
nothing good can come out of that well
thanks so much for joining us and enjoy
the rest ofday
thanks guys thank you hikaro thanks um
always great to hear from our defending
Champion one of the best players in the
world but back to Ray Robinson because
man um he's got a great position but 133
moves he has to make with um the
increment so he better not slip up and
he just played this combative move
A6 uh so black to
move well you're hesitating of course
because whenever you see this Pawn on A6
you know lurking next to your king but I
just can't imagine that uh black could
allow white to play the move B7 takes A6
without serious consequence so B B6
forced Jen B you can't go to C7 that's
the one good thing that black has going
for him he does have the C7 Square
covered right so probably we got to go
back to C3 or that might allow me to be
honorary and just play the move d4 so I
I need a better suggestion than my own
Rook C3 so let's see Rook C6 let's just
yeah Rook C6 we could play so let's
let's let me review that again though if
Rook C3
um if you play D4 all sorts of things
are hanging in the position I'm just I
just want to make sure I can't play like
takes on F3 and takes on F7 or something
like
that whoa um not sure takes on F7
because you're looking at that SP how
difficult it is for you to defend
against that Checkmate I mean you of
course you can always play play some
piece to B8 right like The Rook or or
the queen and maybe that's efficient
well The Rook
uh has a draw Queen B5 yeah so so you're
playing I had to play Queen B8 so now do
I have any little uh tactics or tricky
as you like to say
um I'm even just thinking about the slow
the slow bur trying to move the night to
to C7 but um he's got 30 seconds on the
clock uh and it looks like uh Lenderman
did not heed your advice and did not
play the move B6 instead just retreating
his Bishop to G6 maybe not liking some
of the way that these lines look
Ray snaap the pawn off on D5 this looks
terrible for Alex now he's a pawn down
and he's under attack that's right so
this just looks game over this is too
this is acing easy you think too easy
even in time pressure a little bit like
VAR uh yeah Maurice you the best uh
resistance well as I just punched the
boo into the engine and it went
ballistic Ray missed a complete win
completely crushing blow after the move
Bishop to G6 the move B6 very
picturesque move just opening up the
entire side forget about what's
happening over here because it's going
to be mate down here if you try to play
Rook takes E2 hoping for your own
Checkmate then suddenly this check and
the king is just ripped to shreds King
takes on B7 just runs into takes on A7
and if you move your king back look at
this beautiful line Rook to C8
check wow deflecting this Rook so that
you can play the move Queen takes D5
with check now the move King takes is
forced and the King just gets hunted
down with Rook to Rook actually no even
stronger check 4 seconds left he's
finally moved Ray missed a complete win
he must a crushing win in this position
if you look just looking at this now he
had a completely devastating blow now
he's in heavy time pressure having
played the Casual move Rook takes on D5
and after Rook to B8 he's played his now
he's winning again Rook to D7 Rook to B8
was a big mistake now he's winning cold
so Lenderman with five plus minutes on
his clock should have thanked his lucky
stars after Rook takes D5 the engines
give this defense Queen C7 coming back
controlling the side he played too
quickly as often happens in the other
person's time pressure play too quickly
with Rook to B8 excuse me Rook to D7 and
now he can keep looking he's busted this
diagonal is going to be too strong if he
plays Rook takes on E2 thinking he has a
shot here it just ends really quickly
and bloodily after this check because
you cannot back up because of Queen D5
and mate so Lenderman moving too fast in
raise time pressure now he's slowing
down but unfortunately he's
gone and let's see remember Ray got down
to three seconds last move I think it
was last year's championship they
actually got down to one second and trly
his uh teammates at Webster were having
um some heart palpitations cuz we don't
like to see here our friends with a 5
seconds left of theck do we well there
was uh earlier in the tournament already
he had uh two occasions where he was
down to a second in one of his games
already in this event so 3 seconds no
big three second seconds all the time
he's casual at three at one he speeds it
up plenty of time he's definitely got
that clock in his peripheral vision as
um Nakamura likes to say in his bullet
tips so just
um the last past him to the attack he
played Rook to C1 and uh oh he's already
played he played Rook C1 and Lenderman
claps well if he hadn't played it yet he
would have been crying because he would
have lost on time oh I see yes of course
within 30 seconds so clearly uh Ray has
one objective in mind right now and that
is to Checkmate his opponent's king
Alexander Lenderman in a world of HT
won't be able to find a defense here as
Ray Robson should he win this game um oh
he'll be he'll be tied with Wesley he'll
be tied with Wesley and half a point
ahead of uh Fabby well yeah but Fab's
probably going to draw right so they
would most likely be tied tied for yeah
most likely tied for first at the end of
this round yes so big game still here uh
going on and Ray Robson is really
acquitting himself very very well in
these US championships that's right
staking his claim for the championship
title and we were looking at nji pid's
game earlier we thought that uh how are
we doing on the poll by the way um I'll
I'll check on that but n pidi
is now trying to figure out what to do
after perhaps some inaccuracies I think
she may be maybe she missed the the
strength of Queen A6 C3 or something cuz
I I think she thought she was just
totally crushing in this position
otherwise she wouldn't have gone for it
by the way uh after the move C3 Queen
take C3 check has appeared on the board
and oh have more moves okay yeah Nai is
actually a PA ahead with a dominating
position and she looks to go uh we were
looking at a different variation I say
yeah we were looking at something with
Queen A6 she tried Queen C5 so she moved
her Queen back to C5 I see because she
saw that those variations were a little
risky so smart by Naji to to calm down
and and Retreat uh Maurice what do you
have for us well in the game between two
of the youngsters actually the Young
players are playing Amazing chess
certainly Fighting Chess in this
position the move Rook to D6 was played
by Carissa and after King to E8 she
should have played B3 right now she went
back with E6 checked King to D7 and now
she decided to play the move B3 and that
ran into the move Queen to G1 check not
totally bad for her but she might have
overlooked this move Knight to C6 and
suddenly her Rook is hanging on the E6
square with no more checks to play for
she is is down to 10 minutes her
opponent at 2 minutes on the clock and
she's staring at the board now wondering
what to do the inches are giving her
only move only move as Rook takes on C6
an exchange sacrifice and saying that
Rook takes is best if Bishop takes
either way this Queen's going to pick
this one off on B4 and the engine's
actually like white here still white for
choice in this crazy chaotic position
black pawns have no meaning and the King
stuck in the center of the board not
really a place you want to be another
game that's really fascinating we
haven't really paid attention to this
has been for the ca the case for a long
time Ash gorti the 13-year-old with the
black pieces against Alyssa mahina she
has created this position on the board
where she's been down upon for the
longest but she got compensation down
the file she's kept her Elder off her
back for sure and now she's saying trade
Queens I'm down upon maybe but my pieces
are better than yours I'm winning one of
the pawns back and she is back in the
game and even slightly better here so
exciting games from the youngsters as
they show that they can equip themselves
well here are the Championships thank
you and just looking at the game between
Arena and Anna so important to the
outcome for of the tournament uh it's
been pretty tame draw throughout um I'm
just getting a little bit worried did
Arena uh slip up and maybe see the
advantage to her opponent or is it just
still dead enough uh for a draw I mean
the reason why I bring that up is look
at White's King in the center of the
board here on D2 uh Black's King is a
lot more sheltered and there's a lot of
heavy Firepower still in the position um
one thought that I have in mind is you
don't really want to suffer this pin so
it would make a lot of sense to play a
check Bishop back to d8 exciting things
so we've got a shocker for Maurice a
complete shocker gakamsky has blundered
horribly and is now completely lost he
is completely lost Jeffrey Jang I don't
know
and and look look at that look at
gakamsky he is devastated seeing that he
has made a serious error walking into a
line where he is now losing and he knows
it and Jeffrey is cool as a cucumber
just has to find the move but got to
sees that he is dead and it's a simple
move at that look at him shaking his
head unbelievable incredulous at his
mistake now changing colors even an
amazing turn of events the pain of the
former US champion four-time champ he's
going down against the youngster and
it's going to be easy it's nothing
difficult look at him now amazing
situation the youngster just showed his
tenacity in defense gotta can't even
look at the board guys I don't like this
though I feel like he's got to use a
poker face you never know it's too easy
the next move is it's too easy there are
no threat chance there's no chance he's
just dead I mean he now for sure busted
on the board when he makes that face
that's 100% sure but like with two
minutes in on Jeffrey Jean's clock I
think you just got to pretend that you
don't blunder you never know is there's
that 1% chance you you throw it away by
showing your emotion but you know cuz
people are always asking me from from
poker like oh is there any kind of like
psychology or Poker Face need and chess
and the answer is almost never but this
would be the one case do you want to
break down the blender for us so let's
take a look in this position right here
and Jeffrey look at je Jeffrey's like
I'm not rushing I don't care what you do
I am not rushing I'm going to think
about it I have enough time to make sure
that I'm doing all right but it's simple
it's just this moment right here it's
and if we just take a quick look before
we get back to the action just right at
this moment Jeffrey played the move
Bishop to D1 and God could have played
any waiting move any waiting move Rook
D7 H5 he took on F3 and that's just an
instant blunder takes takes and now just
Rook takes on D4 hitting the Knight
hitting the Rook you have no move you
just have no move your only move
actually is Rook to E8 but now Rook to
F4 caging your queen telling it to leave
then Rook takes E3 game over that's all
he has to look at Jeffrey now down to he
said
135 he didn't play it did he he played
something different and he played
something different but also wins but it
looks like it's winning as well let's
two wins maybe that's why why kind of
was shaking his head he figur the guy
has two wins does he does and he played
he played another win with Queen to B2
check and now after any simple defense
like this he's just going to take the
rook and this Pawn on E2 Rook check you
know he did make it a bit more
complicated than he had to uh in this
line check King Pawn up and then
bringing the Rook behind he played the
much more complicated line Rook takes D5
was so easy there's nothing to calculate
yeah was mean very simple but is still
shaking his head he still knows that
he's lost here no there's no move
there's still still bad but if the guy
didn't find the simplest win maybe he
might slip somewhere Jeffrey is studying
the board right now to make sure that
doesn't happen um and onik has won his
game so we've got a a lot of blood
spilled in the championship this round
three games finished three decisive
results I all wins by light by the way
yeah I expected a very combative round
uh before our show we talk about the
free day coming up and the players
really try to give it their all knowing
that they'll have 24 hours to recover
and G I've played G so often in the '90s
and he had such a great poker face this
is so shocking for me to see G you know
just shaking his head and revealing his
emotion because he was very very good at
um keeping uh that inner control that
Cal uncharacteristic I haven't seen this
at all before so it's like it's almost
like Nakamura and ksk has switched faces
is cuz remember yesterday when Nakamura
lost i g to Fabby he was actually rather
stoic right so they they had some kind
of face swap you know there's that you
know there's that you know the thing
face swap it's like an app where
no oh by the way by the way guysbody
have face what important to take a look
at the game with Robson and and
Lenderman because Robson is now up a
piece he's up a piece and should be
winning although there are some
technical difficulties don't adjust
adjust your chest set this one is still
a fight a little a little bit a little
bit of technique needed but I would say
Robson having 39 moves made now and I
think he's about to make move 40 that he
will have no problem reeling in this
point so Robson winning we got Robson
winning going to a tie for first uh
Fabiano is in a battle still Nakamura
winning giving Chase and also Jang
winning and giving Chase as well after
five rounds undefeated defeated plus
gakamsky as a scalp in his pocket
Jeffrey J I don't know if anybody wants
to play this young man at the moment we
see this SC which I think is not yet
this can updated this is coming into
today but since Wesley won he's at four
Ray should win he should go to four
Jeffrey Jong will win and jump to three
Nakamura will jump to three as well so
definitely some shakeups Onish shook
will jump to three and Onish shook will
jump to three so
the leaders are making Chase certainly
the at least the contenders are making
Chase for Carana saying hey nobody's
going to write your story yet son we are
after you and shaba still trying to make
something happen in that game as
well and that does look uh totally drawn
as I'm looking at that position we
haven't seen it in some time but um
neither player I think Will and ksky has
resigned and Jeffrey jeang trying to
hold in his emotion here you can see
inside he's smiling trying to keep his
cool he's actually suppressing a smile
looking down well what a debut four
draws and a win uh for the youngest
participate participant in the
Championships wow trying to keep his
cool here still not cracking his smile
but when he comes down here for be SM I
think I think we're going to cope this
model out of him a big uh Championship
debut by Jeffrey je yeah hearty
congratulations to the very one we we
saw him we saw him in the midst of crazy
time pressure but it seemed like he had
everything under control has he made
move 40 I don't know about that but he
has a piece
up he's a piece up if he hasn't lost in
time it should be the one to the left
yes okay got you got it uh so Ray Robson
oh
what okay yeah this one uh looks like it
it should be resigned soon um okay black
maybe is going to play around a little
bit because he's about to win this this
Pawn on B5 and and try to push the a
pawn and test uh play a few more moves
but yeah yeah Ray robson's got the extra
30 minutes and with it he will soon get
the point exactly and we have a very
special guest in our studio five-time
Champion as well as Hall of Famer gotsky
yeah we're getting him set up right now
and uh oh I'm sorry and meanwhile it's
like what other games do we have still
going on it's just in the in the
championship it's just that game against
Rob Sid which he looks like he's going
to win in the the drawn game um between
shabalov and Carana most likely so we'll
have five decisive rounds most likely
this round we're been spoiled and here
he is gotsky Hall of Famer he's with
marce Ashley about today's unfortunate
turnaround yes we were with four time
Champion got five time excuse me five
time Champion gotsky got today you
played a conception that was absolutely
beautiful we loved the idea the way you
sacrificed the peace but then this
blunder at the end we saw the emotion on
your face what went wrong what did you
miss everything I missed everything well
I was frustrated that you know at some
point I thought I was close to winning
the initiative was really strong but
then I just couldn't find the moves and
then I were pressed and that's what
happen now the engines are saying that
he defended tough too you had a slight
Edge you were right not to be a to find
the moves because he seemed to be
defending W were you surprised that at
how much resistance he was putting up
well I played him several times before
so it was all draws and was very tough
and I knew that you know this guy was um
you know getting up there I mean he's
really young and uh he's already playing
like that and I if you see his games in
this tournament it's like all four draws
before that all very tough so you know
it's um no surprise that that he
defended really well but I was so
disappointed that I plundered at the end
I
mean it was probably a draw if I just
save my knight on E3 because it's very
strong and he can get to my Pawn on D4
so he just you know just stay in one
place white cannot get uh cannot improve
so it's draw but I just wasn't satisfied
with the draw I over pressed and I wered
so story we all get go through at some
point uh this take it on F3 did you
think he was winning he just missed his
well I missed everything Rook D4 also
wins wins yeah but Rook E3 and then I
miss queen B2 and then you know it's
like okay getting too old for
this well we hope not uh going into a
rest day your final thoughts on that oh
we have a rest day yes you do oh that's
great okay something to look forward to
well because the tournaments that I play
in the open tournaments we don't have
rest day sometimes we have two rounds a
day but the rest day no so that's nice
okay okay well we appreciate your good
spirits uh and the sportsmanship after
this loss great all right thank you to
you guys for quick question for G I
don't want you to escape because really
G I thought that you were on the verge
of making an absolute brilliancy a
fantastic conception by you way back
here when first of all this was a really
sweet move Knight C6 followed by Bishop
D4 this is an remarkable conception of
sacrificing a pieace getting a bind
where Jeffrey was virtually
paralyzed um how did that come into your
mind what thoughts Drew you to this
remarkable conception it really was
something instead of Rook E8 Queen H4
was also very interesting I mean taking
Queen H4 instead of Rook E8 you know
without giving up the piece because I
basically get the same thing but uh with
the Knight on B6 alive because white is
paralyzed he has to play something like
Knight E2 here yes and uh black is just
better I believe yes no question about
it right with the Rook E8 I thought that
you know I had some strong compensation
because both of my Rooks playing his
King side is underdeveloped but um you
know I figured I had compensation here
but I just wasn't sure if it was enough
but at least you know it was fun game
you know I tried to play Fighting Chess
here because you know I I needed to try
to play for a win because it's uh the
tournament is halfway down and I was at
negative score so you know I had to take
some risks so that's what's going on but
you know he defended really well I like
his King D1 and Rook E1 and Rook C3 and
then his King goes back to F2 which is
like uh you know which is incredible
because first he played King D1 here and
then later on the game he he goes back
to E2 and F2 followed by G3 so that was
uh yeah so uh instead of Knight F5 of
course I can repeat the position was
Knight C6 I mean again it's a draw there
so many ways for black to make a draw
here but and and and here he played King
E2 which is incredible I mean look at
this position white is so passive but
there is no way for me to get in so um
okay so kudos to the youngster for
finding great defense great defense all
right thanks thanks for sharing your
thoughts got thank you
got really I was just you know so
impressed by this whole concept
sacrificing of Peace paralyzing your
opponent and to get that kind of a
reward H that's
hurts this is why we y of Chess right
here this is really you play hour after
hour after hour you make a brilliant
series of moves uh plans virtually you
know I played a career of Chess and this
was one of the great uh strategic
masterpieces being woven and one one
atrociously bad move and everybody
forgets uh what you had done and poor G
I can only understand what he went
through right here right now it's tough
that's right and this is what happens in
US championships by the way you get good
resistance and that good resistance does
pay off we had a caller earlier ask us
is what not blundering the secret to
playing better Jaz and you see that even
at the very highest level it's still the
case it's still the case it's uh to
error is human as long as we're human
we'll always make mistakes weren we
Jennifer and the contender of the hour
we've got Jeffrey Jong youngest T
youngest player in the tournament he's
with Mar Maurice Ashley about his uh
huge win today before the rest day
Jeffrey Jeong defending like a cornered
beast and coming out the Victor Jeffrey
how does it feel to defeat gakamsky
today uh feels incredible because uh
you're talking about a guy who has been
competing at the highest level before I
was even born
so and also uh today I felt he became
very motivated because I thought he was
playing a brilliancy basically and I'm
actually surprised that uh it was pretty
much never losing for me yeah it was
really close throughout he was he gave
up a piece when you saw him sacrifice
this peace what were you thinking at the
board um I was pretty much unhappy I cuz
I thought it was close to busted already
especially because I felt that earlier
what I did was very suspect uh should
have just tried to Castle in instead of
maybe D5 so you're thinking you're going
to die and then you come up with this
conception of playing King D1 he sacks a
rook on E2 and then you realize and he
realizes that it's not so easy to break
through yeah I thought maybe Queen F2
wasn't the best try because then later
he wanted to come back Queen H4 so maybe
instead he could have done the same
concept except my Rook is still on H1
and then it's hard to bring my king back
to safety the funny thing though is even
the engines are saying after your king
D1 idea that it's a tough position
slightly better for black but you were
still fighting throughout uh you played
very
tenaciously when he blundered were you
shocked were you CU we saw you stop and
really look and I know in Blitz you
would have found those next moves but
you stopped and really looked at the
position right there well the main
reason was cuz I didn't understand what
he missed really because I thought Rook
e takes E3 wins completely Rook takes D4
I thought I'm also winning The Rook so I
just couldn't understand what you
thought it might have been a trap there
yeah I thought maybe he wanted Rook
takes D4 and then something but I
couldn't see it either so I just decided
okay pick one and
then and take him down well you are plus
one in the US chess championships having
not lost the game what how can you
reflect on that yeah I'm very happy so
far but okay still very long tournament
and here I'm very fortunate so hopefully
I can play better and then get the same
results but without needing much
luck well you have created your own luck
young man fantastic play We're impressed
and we hope to see you doing continuing
to do well here at the Championships
thank you Jeffrey Jang 15 years old oh
folks 15 the future of American chess is
indeed absolutely bright uh Jeffrey our
congratulations from our side of the
room really uh your first win in the US
Championship I know it's not going to be
your last well done young man well done
and enjoy your resting and enjoy the
rest I like how he said he just had to
pick one that's why he was thinking for
a while it's like God if only you could
flip a coin in your brain
right I don't think and do by the way uh
our tournament leader Fabiana kariana
has drawn his game against Alexander
shabalov so we are going to uh have I
think a three-way tie for the lead at
the moment yes assuming that Ray Robson
uh emerges Victorious here which looks
like he will shortly we will have three
players tied for the lead in the
championship in the Women's Championship
all we know for sure is that Naji pidi
is going to be one of the leaders
because she has won her game and she's
reached four points now um will Irena
Crush uh be able to somehow win this
even game against Anna and join her
probably not but of course it's making
the tournament very interesting Naji
pidi yes indeed we're with Nazi pidi
Nazi you won a good game today pretty
dominant game uh you might have uh well
let's just call it a dominant game uh
what happened in the game um so I play
played E4 even though I usually play D4
um so she was surprised and I think
neither of us knew the opening very well
but I got a really good position and at
some point I think I overestimated my
position and I gave her
counterplay uh could have played a
little better but um in the queen and
Rook end game she had almost no time and
she just gave me a pawn and um I won
easily after that five rounds first
place uh at least a tie for first M how
does it feel it feels great it um
especially it feels great winning right
before the rest day and I think I'm
going to be the only leader since crush
is probably going to make a draw and how
does that feel even
better imagine I know that you're a a
gym rat you guys were I saw a picture of
you on I think it was Instagram with you
working out with your good buddy tev
abraam you guys were doing like a muscle
Flex photo um how do you contribute your
workout regum to your success in
tournament play um workout is my
lifestyle I do it every day and it helps
me after the game to relax and forget
about the game doesn't matter if I won
or lost
and it's a really really big part of my
life so you're all well dressed you're
not going to go out to dinner you're
going to hit the gym right now yes I
usually go to the gym and afterwards I
ate dinner wow wow that's a great
formula for all you out there who don't
work out this lady is uh on overdrive
but we thank you so much for your play
and your time with us your dedication to
this activity best of luck in the rest
of the games and enjoy the rest although
I suspect you're going to be working out
on the rest of
yes guys probably doubling up no doubt
yeah thank you niji and congratulations
for your success uh and being in first
that's right we talked about how the
young women in this tournament or not
even the young women the girls in this
tournament teenagers even a prean are
making it more exciting but Naji also
one of the reasons that this tournament
is so exciting having this deep
understanding of the game and uh really
making it clear that Irena and Anna
can't just come in and kind of like okay
form and win the title they have to be
good form exactly no definitely putting
pressure on both of them I'm looking at
the game of Karissa for a moment when we
had left it she had made this really
nice shot Rook D6 check King back to E8
and now was the time just to make look
for her King she tossed in this check
putting her rook in capture which
allowed black to play this move Knight
C6 even and this is where she didn't she
played this poor choice Rook E3 I really
like White's position by the way after
this exchange saice with Queen takes B4
those minor pieces are doing great job
and black King is just uh still in the
center of the board so I really like uh
White's chances of winning this game
after the exchange sacrifice a little
bit too much
material approach by Carissa and she's
got herself I believe into troubles now
she exchange yeah she's an exchange down
and give the back yeah exactly
definitely definitely not now black for
Choice um as um she's let her what I
thought was a winning Advantage slip we
have another guest in our studio that's
right yesterday we were promised the
shabab smash but today he did stop
Fabiano carolana from smashing all of
his opponents he's with
Maru well not too shabby a result which
one do you prefer shabby or
shaba either way is fine either way
always casual so you had a big game
today against Carana did it go as you
expected uh
well first move already it was not what
I expected and I don't think Fabiano
played D5 on Knight F3 uh the last 10
years maybe so that came as a complete
surprise so I had to improvise just uh
played something solid uh well after all
you know you're not playing number two
in the world every day right so that
Tred to make it a game and I thought I
was present for the most of the for the
most of the game and uh just really
don't know where I went Ron I felt like
you know I had chances and U he just
like equalized do you feel you went
wrong or just just couldn't get the the
right thing going because of course you
did draw the game well I I thought I was
much better let's put it this way yeah
and uh but the way for be equalize I
mean like now I'm starting having doubts
that that was better guys can play huh
yes I mean I mean to beat this people is
just like it requires a completely
different effort yeah absolutely well
you are going into the rest day are you
on minus oneus one so what are your
thoughts going into the rest day uh I
need to shake things up somehow I don't
know what it's going to be um well
that's what the rest day is for you know
I'm hope nothing like too wild you know
that uh no wild parties no but uh well I
have to start uh the second part was the
black
against uh hikara oh boy so that's how
fun a lot of fun okay so well who knows
maybe that will be the game that will
change everything well good attitude
absolutely thank you so much for joining
us okay
shaba stopping the Fabiana Karana
Express uh tame game but what can he as
he said he's the number two player in
the world and uh when na the player
makes mistakes in your top Grand Masters
a likely outcome is going to be a
draw interesting also about uh What uh
shalof was saying that he thought that
he had an advant but I was really
impressed by this move H5 by Fabiana
Carana well-known Motif in the position
but it
just it it it it was later in the game
you saw how ex exceptionally useful the
move H7 H5 uh was and here he is Fabiano
Carana still leading the US Chess
Championship but with some contenders
catching up to him he's with marus
Ashley well I think we've all agreed on
Fabby as this nickname that has settled
with him what about today's game
shabalov said he thought that he had a
big Advantage at some point but now he's
starting to doubt himself how did you
assess the position when you were
playing I wasn't so happy with the
opening um I thought I was slightly
worse I don't think I was ever seriously
worse um and I didn't see anything
clearly good for him I thought that um
after Queen A5 maybe A4 was more
accurate um for him you mean yeah he
should have played A4 okay yeah around
here I thought A4 although I don't think
my position is so bad slightly worse but
what what attitude did you come into the
game with did you were you looking for a
big win before the rest day I was hoping
to get a game and try to win uh but I
just didn't get any chances from the
opening he said you shocked him with
this move D5 right away because you
hadn't played it in his database uh on
the first move
mhm I think I've played it
before it's not the most shocking move
no I wouldn't have expected expected it
to be the most shocking move move one he
must have known what to do about it in
in other line I mean in his own line as
well but uh did you play this especially
to surprise him or no I I don't know I
mean it's um I wasn't sure what to
expect from him he he plays quite a wide
variety of openings um and KN of3 came
as a bit of a surprise not a big
surprise but a bit of um a bit of one
and I I don't know I just uh I decided I
mean I normally play 06 but I decided
against it over the board
um yeah I it's just I mean def I think
I've played before and it wasn't it
wasn't huge thought process going be
behind that move now you were the clear
leader before this round but now you've
been caught uh once more what are your
thoughts about your position in the
tournament I think it's still a good
position
um I I mean I don't think I had any real
winning chances today so I can't be too
upset with myself um and it was just a
very strange day in terms of all the
other games um how
so uh well Nakamura and and so won
without any particular difficulties I
mean the winds were just so smooth that
kind of surprised me
um and csky game was bizarre to say the
least um so you you were paying
attention to these games while they're
going on aren't you supposed to be
paying attention to your game yeah there
was no excitement in my game so I I had
to look at the other one ones for um for
some
fun I mean what can you do when when you
get this opening I was really not happy
with it you know it's just slightly
worse with no chances to win or I mean
maybe some chances if um if in a long
game you slowly outplay your opponent
but it's very difficult and I think he
just played um very reasonable moves the
entire game he didn't prove an advantage
but I he also was never in real danger
so you got a rest day now you're used to
having rest days in high Lev tournaments
what do you do on on a day when there's
nothing to
do uh I don't know probably get a
haircut um yeah I I I do want to take um
take the chance to rest of it um because
I I think the end of the tournament will
be pretty tough with six rounds to go uh
you've gotten your biggest contenders
out the way right are you looking to now
just pick up some
steam I won't complain if I
do well we look forward to seeing the
rest of your games and get your rest
thanks Fabiana Carana the number two
player on the planet uh looking still
pretty
relaxed thank you thank you Fabby thank
you Maurice well I'm journeyman
performance today I mean easy day at the
office was a little work but um no big
pressure for Fabiana and he's looking
really great as we finish our uh five
rounds of and going almost at the
halfway point he's definitely the man to
beat though I mean he's played just
about his toughest competition I think
he has Ray still in the picture but uh
he's he's really has impressed so far uh
in this competition we still have Arena
and Anna going at it despite the fact
that the position doesn't look like it's
going to be decisive you do never know
especially with the the final time
control and these two um players who are
both so so ready to take a point off the
other one right right um they are
combative contentious players no
question about it but which way if it's
going to go either way which way do you
think it would go here so an has played
this move
F4 yes uh so again U Bishops of opposite
color uh position very very notorious
for the high number of draws but with
this move F4 I was looking at uh you
know trying to uh get some initiative by
moving this Rook but this Pawn on G6
really is annoying so this move F4 I
thought was a very good move by Anna to
break up this nice chain of Pawns from
F2 to
H4 and if the pawn is captured then this
nice move Rook F6 getting this bishop
into the game with Bishop takes F4
looks well what can I say drawsh drawish
U perhaps a little easier to play with
black white has to check a few more
variations right I should I shouldn't
play Bad moves for arena of course but
yes I'm just saying that if you did
capture the pawn then Rook F6 and it's
very easy for black to play through that
now another game that uh is still going
on in the Women's Championship Alysa
mikina versus Akita gorti and um the
13-year-old seems like she's actually
got Alyssa in a little bit of trouble
here so Alyssa just played this move
Rook to um
D7 um making use of the skewer trick
that if a rook takes
C1 Al can just play Rook C7 and win an
exchange but is that the end of the
story even in that situation the black
king are going to start taking some
bonds
yeah I'm not 100% sure that that's the
end of the story because this Pawn is so
powerful but the question exactly that's
probably what AET is checking actually
but to me the question is also like well
maybe you can just play um for those
pawns without giving up an exchange what
if the king just starts Marching In in
this position with King to B3 and then
um I you know looks great for black
actually right well Rook D3 check I
don't think um accomplishes much we
could even even play um Bishop C3 and
Bishop D2 We have a rook A2 so or King
C2 rather it's just totally winning yeah
exactly is that that's almost trapping
the uh that's almost trapping the bishop
you'd have to play like Bishop E3
perhaps and then we can we you always
have to check these variations with
rookie one um with our King being so
much more advanced I think it's over
we're going to be gobbling the pawns off
yeah and the bishop endings where all of
White's ponds are on dark squares I
don't think white has any chance of
holding that particular ending but so um
so AA went for a similar line but
decided she really wanted she didn't
even want to check those tactical
variations with checks so she just
played Bishop C3 first kind of making um
also a great move just making herself a
um first of all she's tring Rook takes
you1 exactly and when that Bishop moves
again the king is just going
to well in fact just Rook takes A3 and
that pawn is going to Cho you yes
exactly so just a pretty pretty terrible
for Alysa who's going to be um happy to
have a free day to recover from some of
this disappointment in the first half of
the tourn I think that uh easy for me to
say but that loss to uh that it feels
like a loss that draw with Arena really
took the wind out of her sale she played
such a great game and uh came out not
with a victory but with a draw so she's
not looking very good here today no this
the only time I see her where she's
leaning back a little bit I mean a
really must have her squirming if uh her
posture is anything but perfect Al of
course having a background and dance and
ballet um and always just looks uh so
statue asque while playing chess well
many of the other players are hunched
over the board while they play exactly
now this was the game I think that uh
Sabina uh was up upon very very early
the players have fought themselves into
a rook ending
um shria very impressive uh she
blundered upon on early and she's still
making it hard for her more experienced
opponent uh to reel in the victory all
right could you take us through uh the
situation uh as of this moment before we
take a break um in terms of uh standings
well in the US Championship it looks
like we are going to have a three-way
tie for first as we've been protecting
throughout the round that Ray Robson is
going to win this end game up a night
for a pawn and if that happens he'll be
tied for the lead with Wesley so and
Fabiano carolana so very exciting
contest in the championship meanwhile in
the Women's Championship the most
likelihood is that we'll just have one
clear leader at going into the reste and
that is Naji pidi because doesn't look
like um Carissa is going to win she's
actually on the ropes and it also looks
like Irene is probably going to draw
exactly so it seems like it's going to
be nii and the women's and three players
in the championship so both tournaments
just completely wide wi open very good
all right well we'll come back after a
short break and maybe even open up our
telephones for callers that's right get
your questions right because looks like
we might have a couple end games that go
the distance and uh while we look at
those finesses we'll also be happy to
take a couple calls from you guys and
check out that poll I'm still curious
about the poll back in a
few
[Music]
I'm Mike maeni manager of the Cardinals
and chess fanatic many people don't know
that St Louis has a chess history as
rich as its baseball at the
world-renowned chess club and Scholastic
Center of St Louis across from the World
Chess Hall of Fame our goal is to teach
play and promote the sport come to the
Central West End and experience all the
chess has to
[Music]
offer welcome back to the 2016 US
championships in US women's test
championships here in the beautiful
Central westan it's great to have
support of so many prominent members of
the community including Mike maffini
manager for the card yes and mayor
Francis slay has just been terrific for
everything that we do here at the club
he has really been one of our greatest
backers it's a pity he's not running for
reelection I ran into him with Fabby and
uh Lawrence the other evening and we
chitch for a while and I said why why
maybe he'll have even more time for
chess and he said 15 years he's already
done it so anyway we do have a a very
important game still pending uh that is
going on between Ray Robson who is
fighting for first place against his
opponents Alex Lenderman for quite a
while Ray has been a a full night ahead
and I'm not sure I really like his
technique so far but they have reached
this position
at the moment Ray uh pardon me uh
lendman has just played the move F7 F5
white to play no play Oh King D3 yeah uh
King D3 King B3 what's really important
to note is that what black doesn't want
to do black does not want to uh move his
Pawn too soon with A3 because then
you're going to get into a king and pawn
end game where the king is White's King
is simply too fast and will start
gobling pawns up on the king side now
Ray has already gotten into time
pressure not again so he he played the
move at E3 but he's got a well he's got
about 3 minutes left so so he he's only
playing in the increment there is no
additional time so it's funny how that
30 minutes goes by fast especially for a
time pressure adct he really really did
burn through it very quickly and um
again I think he's making it a well he
has made it more difficult for himself
than it need be I sure he still well
within the winning Zone uh but if I were
black I just try to keep my opponent
occupied with that uh kingside Pawn uh
King B4 for example if you go Knight E5
which looks very natural with the idea
that you want to meet the move A3 with
bringing your king back and corralling
the a pawn well there's that annoying
move King B3 once more and Black's idea
is very straightforward he wants to uh
use his
Aon I'm not really sure that's right so
we have to go back and then you play
King V4 again exactly so uh E3 has been
played and again I'm just expecting that
Alex Lenderman will play the move King
B4
and say to Ray okay just show me how
you're going to win if we go back to
this
moment um hold on I think it was
actually this moment I really don't like
this move Knight C4 at all I would much
rather have just put my knight on C2 at
the
start if I could and play it like this
King B uh that way you don't get you
don't get to play King B4 you'll have to
go King B2 and I can always if I ever
wanted or decided to transfer my knight
here I and first of all I think it's a
really good idea to get an E4 keep those
black pawns you know way up the board
and Ray's gone under a minute so this of
course shows that he's not that
confident because I don't think he would
have let himself go under a minute if he
thought he was he was uh easily winning
or like that so it's sort of like he's
tying himself into knots and we we do
now see the move King B4 as
expected um by black the problem for Ray
and his time pressure is Alex Linderman
strategy is to just play quickly because
most of his moves to be frank are pretty
obvious like you don't have to spend a
lot of time playing G before right
nothing nothing for me to think about
not not at all so 22 seconds 2 oh he's
he's already and we know he has that
clock in his peripheral vision but this
is not fun for Ray Robson fans to see
him get down to 10 seconds all the time
and he plays calmly as if it was all no
problem that's hardening so this 95 move
do you think he's trying to perhaps
reroute his Knight to C2 well pardon me
has 95 been played yes it has been
played okay so this is this is the point
where I'm expecting Alex to play the
only move in the in the position that
doesn't lose it once once again A3 is
too early wh's King gets back in time to
stop the a apron from promoting so what
you've got to do is prevent King C2 with
the move King
B3 and no we don't have timeing we don't
have time to snack on G6 because then
after A3 A3 there's just a lot of times
we're looking for ways to get our Knight
back into the game with check but it
doesn't exist here correct so no time to
snack on a pawn which would of course be
lovely if we could um but is there a
benefit to rerouting our Knight at C2
via the C6
Square I'm not sure I'm thinking that
maybe what Ry has in mind is something
like King
B2 uh pardon me King D2 A3 Knight D3
again you don't want to play A2 because
that allows me to sacrifice my knight
and again we're in those King and pwn
end games
which that's right so King B3 has been
played now Ray we're going to see this a
lot in this game uh underneath the 20
seconds again he's got his head in his
hands like he's got all day because hey
for real great 20 seconds is a lot of
time sorry Jen so you were suggesting
that maybe what he what white has in
mind what Ray has in mind is to Route
the night to see2 I don't see how that's
going to be helpful 8 seconds 7 Seconds
no don't do it to your fans Ray in here
he's got two seconds left oh look at one
second 31 down to one
31 oh my gosh don't try this at home
guys please don't do this don't do
oh my goodness and what move did he play
after all of that with our
heart so he came back he has to be
worried about a three time repetition or
does he not the last pawn move was the
move E3 now he played King D2 oh I'm
sorry what where is his what is the
current yeah yeah yeah sorry sorry I
thought I was looking at your board King
D2 was played King David 2 in this
position mhm whoa okay which now the
engines are giving as a draw you see I
thought he blew it so how is that after
what is it after how do we draw this
let's see A3 and now after Knight
D3 Knight D3 and then I'm just going to
let's see what am I going to do are you
going to check the pawn end game or is
it cuz I I think we we have to always
check the pawn end game let's see the
problem it's not that clear because
you're you're also kind of close to re
Pawn right well problem was was that I
think Ray allowed black to get in this
move F7 F5 completely unnecessarily and
the difference is oh sorry let me do it
in a better way you want do king C3 yeah
a little bit better but still is it
enough let's check King C3 no it's not
enough yeah not at all and if you're the
kinging games aren't
winning that awn the night is not a good
stopper of an Aon and if I play E4 here
Jen
let's see is that is that going to do
the
trick I'm not sure I don't know well
obviously aren't aren't I playing Just
E5 oh yeah yeah take it take okay so
I'll go here well and then we'll Shadow
each other for a while or actually I
should probably play King C3 yeah so
that you have the chance of going after
the H Pawn in some in some cases well in
this particular case what's going I'm
losing this this is just a lot his time
is ticking down I mean incredibly so as
his time ticks down and he's finally
made a move but so this one's no good
right the opponent game is easy winning
he's blown it cuz of V4 okay why did he
blow it after whoops sorry I've got to
refesh we missed this one but he he made
a move with 3 seconds this time oh
that's so much
better you made to move Knight F3 um so
he played King D2
and instead of playing our expected move
Knight D3 He played Knight F3 and it's
black to play well again from Black's
point of view there's really not nothing
else for him to do other than to play A2
right and check nothing for white to do
now I think he has an interesting
idea but does it work no it doesn't work
I thought it maybe he might put his
Knight on
A1 in
stalemate yeah in St made the king but
it doesn't it doesn't
work it just doesn't he he needs to move
H4 and then no but even H4 wouldn't have
given him H5 no so he doesn't have this
idea
so so how can he do it he's seeking some
kind of these are my favorite Endings by
the way n Knight versus pawns
particularly with the a pawn I've done
some studies in this ending and the the
win he has passed I mean the the clear
win passed he had a way of getting zong
in the position earlier and creating a
clean win for himself and that involved
playing the move H4 earlier but now
because he can't because a knight on C2
doesn't do anything with a Pawn on A2 so
we go A2 Maurice A2 absolutely and then
Knight
D4 and King down and Knight in Knight to
stop and then if you just stay there
what what does he do right that's the
big
question so actually what's wrong with
King B1 here
even
um King B1 here
um well I don't like bringing my king
over well okay actually you might have
H4 your H4 move would be the zukon move
but okay so King so King C3 King
C1 King B3 King
B1 and now H4 this is his only hope
right cuz he has nothing else to do so
now King over and now how do you how do
you how do
you looks dead actually and more more
moves have been played but I think that
R
has he's gone for this position but I
don't think it's
winning whoa this is really shocking um
you know we love the players on their
phenomenal defensive skills and their
attacking skills but technical play is
as critical as those others and not to
win this ending is really really
shocking how did he I mean it was so
winning at the start that I don't even I
don't even
understand how he messed it
up you mean he could have even just
simply used his King to block the pawn
and uh started absolutely he could have
just started with the move King King C3
way way earlier and just said okay I'm
going to Coral the a pawn so first the
Knight got in the
way then G5 relying on the Knight to
stop the pawn I I don't like that
because it's known that the Knight is
really bad at stopping Rook pawns
definitely they're the worst pawns h and
a pawns are the worst Pawn still winning
to be sure but is there anything like so
how easy is it after King B5 King King
C3 here is there some way maybe for um
Black's King to get to make it a little
bit interesting like suppose A4 to start
well just think about this Jen imagine
that you got your king here where are
you going to go next yeah so I can I can
literally just take the pawn off I
literally take the pawn off and wait I
mean I guess you could get around to D
you could try to get in for D2 but so I
mean if you starting with A4 right and
just let's say I go King here and then
I'll say King C4 now King C4 oh now you
might go to C3 that might exactly that
might be a little bit annoying still
I've got to feel that this is winning
for white I just amazing maybe I didn't
have to put my king on C3 of course I
could have tried something different and
he's repeating moves now but the
position he's he's blown the position
guys back here was a critical moment in
the game and when you see the movie he
should have played you'll say come on
this move right here the king is the
pawns are pushing it looks like he's
trying to make some counterplay and all
you have to do is just do this with your
Knight Knight
to you can't go here you can't go here
you have no counterplay you're done and
we're just going to use a king and
Knight to box you out yeah what is G5
and G he was worried about a move like
G5 but this doesn't do anything King D5
and look at the harmony between the
Knight and and King and this king is
just out the game and you just own the
board simply Knight C2 now Knight C2 was
move 44 so no question he had lots of
time in the clock if you just played
night C2 In This Moment the game is done
the game is done it's just over an easy
win he had other wins as well but he
decided to play G5 and allow King B4 the
only chance for the king to walk into
the
game really unbelievable move and now he
had a technical battle ahead after the
move F5 in this position even here he
should be winning but it's still now
it's like okay I have to work it out
because I allow the king to get to this
Square he play King D3 King B3 E3 King
B4 as I King couldn't make any real
progress and even here he could go with
H4 in this position not to put a fine
point on it but the fact is this is
still a dominating position why because
this king is in trouble this this Knight
is able to reroute itself while using
the king and looks like they've shaken
hands and Ray Robson has thrown away a
full Half Point wow this is going to
feel like a loss to him as well the same
where Alysa
mahina Drew her game against Arena crush
he's going to feel like he lost this
game just up a
piece when you're up a piece you think
this is done this is this is over to
have thrown this game away and giv the
awn flight just not responsible of him
and look at him right now he just can't
get up from the table he knows he had
this game and he just feels absolutely
devastated for throwing it away poor Ray
it does make you feel some sympathy I
mean the amount of and that's one of the
things about getting into that much time
pressure I think like the emotional toll
that it takes on you leaves you with a
little less energy for the second time
control and we saw evidence in this case
that he was he was a bit spent if you
will the second time control just out of
gas and hope trying to make uh quick
moves but uh not the right quick moves
yeah there's no question you're burning
up a heck of a lot of nervous energy
when your time when your clock is
against you I mean you could just go
back to these moves after F4 totally
dominating position I mean black is
almost in the state of zuk Swang if you
would like uh maybe the simplest win was
Rook takes E7 obviously what Ray chose
Ray chose uh was simply winning as well
and you know just a dominant game you
just had it in your mind that black was
going to be resigning at any single
moment but I mean give uh Alex Lenderman
a heck of a lot of credit if his
opponent's going to give you chances
well you got to go for him and I a
remarkable save I just didn't see this
happening I thought that Alex was in
trouble for you know better part of the
last two hours before draw was agreed
and to
explain that's right so what happened is
Mr Lenderman in our studio with Maurice
Ashley well Alex L been suffering for
quite some time but it seems a gift Alex
came from from above an incredible
finish what did you think when you saw
you were actually going to draw this
game um I didn't think I'm going to draw
this game until almost until he offered
me a draw I mean basically the main
reason I didn't resign is because I okay
I figured I wanted to show the fans how
the you know the game is won the
technique and okay and then he started
thinking like two three minutes a move
and then I realized okay maybe it's not
so easy so I'll just keep playing and
then suddenly I just got chances out of
no it's it's completely a miraculous
safe I don't know what to say it's it's
really a
gift uh incredibly so your your game it
was it looked like you wouldn't even
survive the to the end game at some
point when he played A6 and his Rook hit
the seventh rank I mean even even
getting to the end game seemed uh
unbelievable well the end game is
completely lost probably down a piece
but no I I was just I was just making
moves because you know he was a low on
time so I figured what if an accident
happens and he f fls or something or or
he makes some weird mistake but and then
okay once we made 40 moves I realized
okay have this pass pawn and the nights
are kind of clumsy against the Aon and I
figure okay I'll just make a few more
moves and then you know resign but is it
funny how we learned the basics very
early on Knights are clumsy against aons
something we learned in grade school and
then in in a US Championship it turns
out to be the thing that saves you yeah
I mean okay if if if it was a bishop
obviously I would have resigned like
many moves ago so you know the only
reason is the night and okay there were
only three points each so I figured okay
maybe miraculously I saw some lines of
where I'm drawing so I figured okay I'll
just keep playing second big save in
this tournament we see in an endgame
that was completely lost your good
friend from Brooklyn Arena Crush also
had a game that was a big a big miracle
too well I think in that game though
um um basically once it got to an end
game it was already a dead draw what uh
whereas she was lost in the middle game
but the end game was already a dead draw
whereas in my game I was lost and then
the end game probably was lost too so
you know and should be technically lost
so you know for me I I feel like my save
is much more significant not only that
I'm obviously playing a a top GM it's
really a miraculous save I definitely
did not expect that but okay that's why
you have to keep playing I mean you know
sometimes it's never too late to resign
that's the idea
I I remember one of my students you know
Al like she saved an end game okay they
were playing in the under 1600 section
but like the uh she saved the position
with like night and three against like 9
night and three pawns against just three
pawns and there was like even more loss
there was not even a counter play and
somehow the pawns were traded off and
there was a stal matrick so like with
the Knights you just never know they're
so clumsy you know I figured okay I'll
just keep playing because you know you
just never know what these nights you
know it's so with such a save what does
that bring for you going into the rest
day well it's hopefully some momentum I
mean uh obviously this this is a
difficult tournament uh and uh I'm just
doing my best I'm battling every game
obviously there are a lot of things I
need to work on but I'm doing my best um
and um you know either way I was going
to I was going to continue playing as if
nothing happened you know even today I
had a bad start but I I wanted to play
the game as if it's the first round as
if nothing happened before and uh that's
how I plan to play my next rounds to
play as if nothing happened before and
as as if it's my first game and I think
uh that way you can just get rid of
these bad thoughts and um why I lost I
can figure that out after the tournament
hopefully um but we'll see very good
advice for you and for your students who
are listening as you show what it means
to never resign to too early congrats on
your save and have a good rest day thank
you thank you Maurice and thank you Alex
wow um time trouble time trouble it's
unbearable uh it it
really makes you cringe and Ry has
twice um gotten himself into a position
on the clock where he was down to a
second and made the move before losing
the game so all of Ray's supporters I
mean must at this moment be thinking
I've got to turn off the broadcast is
too uh nerve-wracking to watch Ray play
chess and here he is in our Studios to
explain what happened today with Maurice
Ashley yes with Grandmaster Ray Robson
Ray you were obviously just winning what
happened yeah well I was winning in the
middle game completely but um I decided
kind of before the time control that it
would be easiest just to go to this end
game um because I didn't have much time
so and I I knew it wouldn't be so easy
because he has the outside a pawn and
knight's not really good in the end game
but I figured it has to be just winning
um and yeah I'm sure it is um but
somehow as I was thinking um after the
time control I I thought it was an easy
win then I kept finding some lines where
he could where I couldn't find a clear
Force win everywhere and
um I well probably the easiest maybe
after he played A4 I think Knight C2
should probably beier crushing and I
mean the only reason he didn't play is
because he can play put his Pawn on G5
and um I thought that's a better place
for his Pawn but uh I don't think it
really matters I think it was more
important just to keep his King out um
um and then after I didn't play that and
then uh I had missed something in the
game and after that it wasn't so clear
um probably was still winning but I
didn't really see how and uh it's really
tricky with these uh these end games
even if you're up a full piece um the
knight in the corner is completely out
of the game sometimes and the King can
just uh snatch up a bunch of Pawns
so yeah so obviously still shouldn't
still should have won the game what's
the deal with the time pressure you it
seems like it's it's something that you
can't shake and you end up not winning
games that you should because you're
getting to this serious time
pressure yeah today um I was doing well
time wise in the beginning of the game
um I had a little bit more time than him
and I thought I had a very good position
but after he played Castle Queens side
um that's when I started spending too
much time
um because I thought I should have a
really good position but I didn't find
anything clear um maybe I should have
played Rook fc1 instead of Rook ac1 I'm
not sure and then um I just became kind
of disillusioned with my position I
wasn't sure I was even better anymore
and still even if you're not better I
still have to play much faster and then
after the time control uh I got in time
trouble again I was just looking for a
clear win and somehow I kept not finding
it maybe I was just too tired I don't
really know but obviously that's a
problem I need to improve on for the
second half of the
tournament how do you bounce back into
the second half this is certainly an
important half point that you didn't
get um just have to move on I mean still
doing all right overall obviously I
should have at least half a point more
but uh you know I'll have you know more
chances in the second half of the
tournament um my still haven't lost a
game Ray there it was a beautiful moment
you I actually thought you played a
really really excellent game I've got a
the situation on our screen and I don't
know if time pressure had kicked in
quite yet you've just uh made this move
A6 which was the start of what I thought
would win the game on the spot here you
you took Rook takes
D5 and Maurice was showing some very
nice variation that began with B5 B6 a
move I think you would have played in a
Blitz game uh but you didn't play it did
you consider this move B6 which is looks
visually so very good um I definitely
considered B6 um just I saw Rook six D5
as just a pawn and still looks like I'm
winning B6 um I assume is also just
breaking through but um I just decided
to play the move that was slightly safer
all right fair enough all right R we'll
let you go a tough day today but we'll
show you boun back thanks guys thank you
well that was just such a big Miss uh
these in these events half a point is so
very meaningful that it's um uh I'm
really shocked uh by Ray's uh Mist here
today but we have a phone call yes that
is we have a young phone caller um let
us know who you are and where you're
calling from um hi my name is VES I'm
calling from Seattle Washington I just
wanted to know how um Grand Masters
prepare for other Grand Masters like
when there's so many openings and
novelties well thank you from Seattle uh
good to hear from the home city um how
do you prepare well it's very simple
find your favorite weapons opening
weapons you're opening defenses you need
you you need a good defense
to the King Pawn opening so when you're
black and your opponent plays
E4 you you need to have a a good defense
to this opening by white and when white
plays D4 you need to have a good defense
to this so you just hone your weapons
the the the openings or defenses that
you like best to those two opening moves
and then when you're white you settle on
an opening yourself whether you prefer
the E King Pon open or queen Pond
opening or even the English opening one
of my favorites uh find an opening setup
that you really like as white and two
good defenses as black and play often
and win thank you for calling M Nash
though very very good to hear from our
young callers and um we do have another
result in in the Women's Championship
Carissa yep has gone down to AGA batv
now both of them have even scores going
into the reste two and a half out of
five certainly um being ranked among the
second half of the table both of them
would have been pleased with that before
the tournament sure but uh Carissa with
her two- start obviously not so happy
exactly I was looking forward to
something more today
Maurice yes and it gets harder and
harder as the tournament goes on you
know Carissa hasn't played against this
kind of top opposition consistently
throughout so to play 11 rounds is going
to be rough we playing five rounds at
you might be thinking oo I'm tired but
gets a rest day gets a chance to relook
at things certainly she had great great
chances today to pull off the victory
but just could manage to do it exactly
and talking about uh players
who didn't manage to do it we have the
game between Anna zatonski and Arena
Crush still ongoing and I I mean it's
it's rook and Bishop versus Rook one
Pawn a piece but they're so focused
nobody's offered draws uh anything to
make out of that Jennifer they like to
play King vers King indeed but uh Irena
did just play a move that I'm sure will
result in a draw if she gets to play
Rook C4 Jack then I think they will stop
playing after Rook C1 Rook H4 it is
Black's move but for some reason um Rook
C4 is found in the position and it's
Bishop of opposite color versus Bishop
ofite color and pawn vers Pawn there
will be a handshake that okay
reassure that it's nothing personal oh
there's something personal between these
two but even then like I mean you can't
squeeze left from a stone well yeah I
mean maybe in this tournament
occasionally you can but not the stone
no this is this is really really really
dead and uh meanwhile it looks like
Alysa maybe has a bit more of a chance
than she used to you want to pull that
game up I sure I thought it was Maybe
not maybe not I just thought I thought
it was uh over over over some time ago
so I kind of lost a bit well I thought
so B7 how did she get her Pawn to B7 so
that's a cute little move by the way um
but A2 is a cute re A1 threading Rook B1
check and then takes and and queen um A2
preventing it and now uh Alissa has
simply moved her Rook to E1 here Rook to
E1 makes sense now how H you you have to
no part since they're still a Pawn on H3
I was about to say you have to be
worried about a mad rook in a situation
where I'm in a stalemate that's not the
case here so uh I guess we have to take
the PA yeah but definitely Alyssa's
fighting her way um
still maybe she's blown it maybe black
has actually blown it I'm I'm not quite
sure yeah it it it looks possible to
perhaps some gor technique in the
situation um leaving a lot to be desired
in this game might end up being a save
for Alyssa which she kind of deserve you
think about it but we do have Carissa
Yip our youngest contender in either
Championship um with a tough loss today
is with Grandmaster
Ashley yes Carissa was leading the
tournament after three rounds but
Carissa these last two rounds have been
difficult and today's game looked like
you had a Fighting Chance what do you
think happened yeah I think I was like
like winning but then when I played B3 I
think it was just over for me and she
could have just won really quickly after
Knight takes D4 Queen takes and Rook
C8
but I don't know I was just like winning
and then I just blew
it uh how is it to play against these
players round after round knowing that
you have a tough game every single game
it's not like a Swiss tournament where
if you lose you may get an easier
opponent in this this tournament it
doesn't matter if you lose you're going
to get a tough opponent every
round it doesn't really matter to me I
guess it's the same thing either way
still play
people
just so you're sitting at 50% before the
tournament 50% might have seemed like a
good result uh is there any
disappointment about being up and now
being back
down yeah definitely because in my last
two games I just had like good positions
and I just blew it just feel really
disappointed in myself so uh you get a
rest day that's nice you know often get
AR rest day in tournaments and you're
doing great still I mean 50% is a very
nice score there's six rounds to go and
we hear that all the players say one
game at a time so what do you do on a
rest day when or a day when you not
don't have anything to do um I prep for
tomorrow's a pull it um
like on the rest I usually prep and then
my dad likes lets me textt my friends a
bit beyond texting is there anything
else You' like to do for fun movies
music or um else I like
reading um is there a good book you're
reading right now no no my dad didn't
let me bring any don't want any
distractions in the middle of the
tournament yeah well you know there's a
froo uh place right next door that has
the best yogurts maybe your dad will let
you you enjoy a little bit of FR froo I
don't know all right Dad you know come
on she's 12 she had a bad tournament
she's she had a bad game she still got a
long way to go we know you're going to
come back in this tournament so get your
rest uh there's lots to play for and we
look forward to seeing you do all from
this moment on thanks Carissa I have a
question for you first of all hearty
congratulations I think today's game you
played great honestly you it was really
entertaining and everybody in the studio
really enjoyed following the game you
mentioned the position after B3 and I'm
just going to pull it up on the board
because at this exact moment when you
felt that something had gone wrong and
maybe it had I still really like your
position I would rather have had white
than black did you consider the exchange
sacrifice Rook C6 Bishop C6 Queen B4
hoping that the compensation of Black's
King in the center would give you some
kind of an attack did you consider
sacrificing a shame you already
sacrificed one why not go for two yeah I
looked at it but I'm not really sure how
I could like exploit the king in the
center I guess well don't forget that D3
to five is going to be tough for black
to face plus your queen is also going to
somehow show up on the dark squares
Queen Maybe Queen B6 might might show up
at some point yeah not so easy this
position this one's hard anybody could
have misevaluated this one it's two
exchanges down and nothing totally
concrete so this one was definitely a
tricky position so lots to look at and
it's easier for us cuz we have computers
we cheat we sure do but again
congratulations I thought you played a a
really really exciting game and you were
so close to winning even earlier so
uh keep up the good work young lady
we're we're you you're you're making
lots of admirers let's put it that
way thanks Carissa
thanks plenty of Carissa fans out there
you know you asked earlier um who people
were voting for in the poll and one
person hashtagged us and said that if
you have any heart you pick Carissa if
you have any head you pick
fabiio got it got it
agreed good Twitter uh answer that one
now in reality though Arena the the um
big uh favorite in that poll that was
before Nai won her game and before Irena
looked like she was going to draw
against Anna so people just using the
information they had at the time exactly
and then of course in the championship
it was Fabby by a big margin right but
he also came into the round um half a
point ahead and having played enormously
strong um expected Rivals for the
championship I'm playing fantastic and
we've got another guest AATA byv she won
her game and now she's on an even score
she's with marce
Ashley Thanks Jen well AATA today's game
was wild she played Bishop H4 she played
G5 she played Bishop E2 F5 and she was
like Boom coming after you what were
your thoughts at this moment that was
part of the Theory actually I kind of I
know the Bish B to it's somewhere in the
theory that I prepared I just kind of
forgot cuz there just so many lines that
I Was preparing ing before but G6 was
all prepared all that and then like the
f595 queen F2 right well Bishop E2 was
not in the database that I found maybe
you analyzed it yourself Bishop B2 was
certainly a very sharp move and the
engines started liking her position
pretty quickly after that uh especially
when she got her G Pawn well actually at
the moment you play Knight F6 Knight D2
the engine said what would have been
very strong for her as opposed to
playing uh ftes G6 looked like you might
have been in some
trouble yeah I know it was really
licated there's a lot going on a lot to
calculate but yeah I wasn't exactly sure
there I definitely I'm not exact what
was the evaluation though after she took
my knight W in which position I took her
rook and then she took my knight because
I thought that she just play Queen HH
right Queen HH was the right move I was
calculating Queen HH was definitely the
right move for her she took on G5 you
had F6 was the was the move but that
seemed very sharp because of Bishop H5
check yeah I was thinking about that but
decided not to completely Wild game uh
this Championship is wild every round is
up and down we've seen so far how are
you keeping your equinity as the
tournament goes on well I
guess I I haven't had very many good
games like this one was my first like
kind of there was play in this game
other games there wasn't very much play
going on and I
guess I'm just trying to play are you
having fun yet I am this game I had some
fun it was I it was a bit scary at some
point but I definitely felt happier with
this game cuz there was like Irena
crush's game I just completely messed up
and there was no fight it was just like
completely passive and there was no play
but here there's like some play and
there's calculation and these are the
kinds of positions I like to play two
Sicilians back to back as well so really
sharp chess you're going into the rest
Daye now what are your thoughts U what
are you going to do tomorrow homework
homework yeah last night was 6 hours
straight of math what 6 hours of math
how are you doing so much work don't
they give you a break during the US
championship nope no break I had to
email my teacher my my homework had to
take pictures email it all that wow what
tell us the math you're doing right now
I know you're a junior in high school
yeah I'm taking Diffy Q differential
equations Diffy Q they call it these
days right right okay differential
equation at this point I know you've got
uh a lot of math already underne so
you're going to spend the whole day
doing homework yeah have I'm actually
missing a physics midterm so I have to
study for that too wow how are you
combining this with the championship um
I mean I actually think the homework is
kind of a good distraction like working
on the homework last night to get over
the law it was I think it was good a
good distraction for me yeah I I was
always distracted by homework when I had
problems
that's well we won't keep up too much of
your time since we know your teachers
are screaming right now go get to work
but congratulations on your win today
thank
you thank you well I hadn't heard that
one before and how do you prepare
Jennifer for a big game well I do six
hours of differential equations what do
you do really relaxing right if I have a
disappointment I have to get over
something I was watching the playoffs
games last night that was how I Was
preparing for our broadcast but we have
a caller let's get to it hello caller to
the show U my name is Arian and I'm from
Columbus Ohio hi I met Maurice at the
Queen City Classic and I've met
Jennifer's brother Greg
before and I question why is the
Sicilian con not as popular in the Grand
Master Level why is the the Sicilian con
the Sicilian con popular the grandm
level all right well of course uh last
year in that very key game between
Hikaru and gakamsky he did play the con
Sicilian that was that great game with
Knight D5 that uh uh hikaro won I think
it's a a question of fashion mostly I I
don't find anything wrong per se with
the con uh Sicilian you do give up a a
bit of space but you do that in a lot of
defenses and I think it's just a
question of style and in truth we've
really been lucky that we haven't seen
Berlin's uh because Berlin is a real way
of shutting down whites 1 E4 no um and
we love to hear from The Young haulers
and I know Maurice always tells me he
has a great time at the Queen City
Classic um but can I draw your attention
to the IR crash tansy game because I
think we might have called this one too
early I mean let's just face it both
these players are basically playing on
increment and they do both have a pass
Pawn they haven't agreed to one of those
very um uh just dead draw trade the
Rooks lines something could happen here
I mean because of the clock because of
the clock exactly and the fact that they
haven't drawn the position yet there's
always that potential for blunder
hopefully both players keep more than a
30 seconds on their on their clock
because that's when you really get into
the potential for blundering Zone yes oh
absolutely as we saw in the case of Ray
games although actually he blundered
before he got down to that little time
unfortunately it was the reverse if he
had thought and found that simple move
nicey too he could have one second on
the clock and he would have been a okay
right right so that's why it's hard I
mean you can't just tell people play
faster because if you just told Ray well
play faster and never get into time
pressure in that game where you're
actually like well yeah he should have
thought for a while because
then he would have found ny2 so it's
it's more complicated than just telling
people to to to speed up yeah and often
times they don't hit your advice then
what do you
do uh but is there anything actually in
this position is there any pitfalls for
anybody to fall into except for you know
simple like just hanging a rookie five
like earlier there was a bishop on D5
maybe hanging a rookie five ATT right
other than the horrifying blunder I mean
the worst I can ever imagine as a rook
and Bishop versus Rook uh outcome and
that's the absolute worst and that's a
draw so I'm really amazed that the uh
ladies keep playing but maybe there's
some traps uh Maurice up and down games
disappointment will abound today on the
L side especially as Sabino forer has
simply blown her wi it looks like
against a San unless I'm not seeing
something after what we've been here for
about 6 hours or maybe only five but
guys take a look at this she's up the
engines are giving her
11.56 edge that means Queen a couple of
Pawns just just just hand me the game
you know get out of here instead look at
what happened here H4 now the engines
are not happy at all from this last move
it's say okay we're still winning Rook
G1 King F3 Rook F1 and King G2 Rook to
F4 King to G G3 Rook check and still in
the winning Zone except this move King
H3 and suddenly the king is on the wrong
side and that was actually mystifying
what just happened yes Rook G4 check
gives King F3 as the winning move but
King H3 burying the King on this side
and now suddenly the king is cut off and
it's not easy to advance the pawns that
was the moment now suddenly it's work
King H2 Rook G4 your king is stuck on
the side and you can't get the pawns
going she played Rook 87 King E3 Rook to
F4 and suddenly the engine screaming
draw after F3
G7 give me this pawn and now the two
connected passers you had a second ago
no longer
exists you you can't even push your Pawn
check that out you can't push your Pawn
because you get mated so suddenly The
Rook has to go back in front of the Pawn
King E2 threatening to push and the win
is gone so beao after all this work in a
dominant position easily winning has
blown the game against the youngster and
what can you say what is going on she
she knows it she has thrown away the win
entirely in this rook and pawn ending
what a turn we saw Ray Robson throw away
a half point just ridiculously so now
we're seeing this happen yes please tell
me what's in the water yeah bad
technique today and again uh a different
virus infecting the uh playing Hall
today uh very strange total lapses of
technique inexplicable in both sections
I don't mean what about Gordy is she
going to get the job done against Alyssa
let's take a look at that because it
looks like she's just maneuvered her
King to a square that's putting Alyssa
in a tricky situation so um what
happened here look like how did this how
did how did black king ever cry
cross so now Rook
H2 terrible what the heck is the same
principle cutting off the king Rook H2
was just a bad move just played Rook G6
is still equal absolutely and the moment
you go King G8 well we'll trade
everything with H6 she play a really bad
move with Rook H2 looking to trade early
and now King up and interestingly the
king willingly goes to this file but now
your your Rook is in some kind of zook
and also black is thinking about that
end game that's right taking that pawn
giving you the a pawn but gaining this
Pawn with Tempo by the way so in fact
we're not even going to give you after
Rook A5 let's take a look at that
interesting position I think I yeah okay
Rook H2 so Rook H Rook H2 Rook A5 Rook
G2 and now Rook G2 right it was a key
move so that you don't lose a Tempo but
even so this end game is is one in every
table base cuz after you take here I
just play Rook B5 and agreed bye-bye I'm
just going to any checks you do I get
behind I start pushing slowly slowly but
surely your king is way out this is over
this is over unbelievable what was she
thinking with this move after all that
defense we're we're back here after all
that defense to play the move Rook to
H2 I guess she just suspected of what
she thought was that she could just play
like this and it wouldn't be a problem
but now she's just lost it's just a rook
and pawn Now Incredible what turns and
this game actually this game is
different in two ways because gorty was
just winning before she was way ahead
then she blew it Alyssa came back and
now we're getting the result That was
supposed to be the result of course
that's not going to be any consolation
of all at all for for Alyssa given you
had said earlier Jen you know she
deserves to get a draw here given how
how collapsed against Arena Crush
another end game collapse clearly we
find a weakness in her game in those end
games study the end game kids now are we
gonna have one expected result in this
game I mean Arena Crush Zony has team
headed for a draw for quite a while but
both players with a just about a minute
on the clock right now and so you we
still have to keep our eye on this game
because you never
know yeah not this I wouldn't anything
in this tournament even you never know I
do know something crazy probably will
happen I mean what you're saying is it
will be a draw well well you're saying
it's hilarious I mean this has been a
dead dead dead dead dead draw for the
better part of three
hours because of what we've been seeing
in uh the competition uh and the
horrendous techniques of the players on
both sides of uh The Bays upstairs um I
have to agree I mean until this game has
been me too okay this one will be draw
this one you can't mess up draw now okay
well that's a relief I mean okay but
they're going to play it
out nobody wants to be the one you
that's okay nobody want playing to naked
Kings is okay I mean you you go F6 I'll
go King B5 it might be hard to get to
naked oh yeah probably you get to naked
kins pretty easily yeah well no I mean
I'm just saying that uh on the on white
side of the table she'll go F5 black
will willingly sacrifices her Bishop for
this pawn and then yeah what's funny
about this position is they both know
it's more than dead Dron well now she
decides to bring her King back you
trying to win the pawn oh no she off
with the draw all right about time
amazing fight though from these ladies
you got to be impressed uh that they
decided to play so long so long well the
rest day is tomorrow so so
what why not nobody wants to be the one
to offer the other one to draw there's
like there's some psychology at play
because they could be playing a playoff
in one week's time and nobody wants to
give up that edge and be like draw H I
always thought the protocol was for
white to make the draw offer and in fact
it was black who made the draw offer
with King C5 to D6 so in my generation
of players um in a dead drawn position
it was white who come on at that point
it's okay I think just because this has
gone on for so long yeah but I'm just
saying that white should have offered
the draw maybe the moment she traded
Rooks or something right right after
Rook B but no but Anna could have just
offered a draw after Rook B2 I feel like
the etiquette is a little um a little
bit like up in the air in this one just
because it's after Rook B2 Anna was the
one who forced the trade of us yeah no
I'm not saying about the position I I I
I'm I'm sorry I think you misunderstand
me I'm not talking about this specific
position I'm just saying that when
you're getting into a drawing game uh
but white who has the advantage at the
start is the one who makes the peace
treaty and could have a lot longer ago
in this game and you do wonder if there
was an arrest day tomorrow if maybe they
would have just uh decided hey it's
better for me to take a my energy for
the next tournament next game it's just
not as we know from seeing the Women's
Championship so far it's not just about
Irene and Anna that now um and we've got
an update on the boarding game
okay we're looking at this game and
we're we're checking that it is going to
be a win for black we're projecting she
did play G5 however a little bit of a
surprise she could have played the move
Rook to C5 right now but she has the
tempo still she's still winning
completely this rook and pawn is
completely winning even if the Rook is
on the E file it's winning so she can
actually let the King march two more
steps and then put the Rook on the E
file as long as her King is a little bit
more down the board she should be
winning this position with no problem
we've said said stuff like that before
it may not mean too much in this
championships but that is something to
do we see in the other game sainaa fer
has decided to just sacrifice her Rook
for this Pawn on F2 and now she should
be drawing she decided to just finish
the game uh she will be discusted with
herself for not winning this one that
was completely winning no question about
it but now this one is easily drawn
although AA will be looking at this
position and wondering after the move 86
which is on the board can I somehow get
my king over here and use the king and
Rook to pick off the H Pawn and win the
game easily turns out that it is just a
draw after Rook takes on the Square and
King G5 it just happens to be a draw but
yes boy she's uh really playing with
fire in this position because some of
these end games are losing too when she
must have calculated through to say this
is going to be a draw for her because
the kings are just not close enough uh
together for it to be a loss but crazy
chess in these end games and I'm sure
these ladies are going to go back to
their leev mof's rook and pawn manuals
to make sure they understand the
technique in rook and pawns supremely
important if you're going to win games
meantime Ray Robson of course has uh his
own issues with night and pawn endings
apparently so the end game counts we we
had said learn your end games cheat
learn your end Games first AA did play
the move Rook D5 cutting off her
opponent's king uh alysa's King from
getting over here in order to stop uh
the G pawn and that basically finishes
the game that's a winning move it's
going to be impossible now for
Alyssa uh Alisa to stop this pawn and
the escort of the king will mean that
white will be forced to give up a rook
and that's a very simple King and Rook
versus King ending which we all
learn so big beginner's class so big win
there for um a Gort
which he's wrapping up we've also got
some tweets as we get our next interview
set up um Eric Hansen has wrote in and
said that uh it's going to be fun to
watch Nakamura fight back to keep his
territory he has been at the helm of
American chess for a decade aranson of
course one of your co-hosts for today in
chess CH bra and Shout out we we miss
you I'm winning our bet Eric and winning
our bet and we also have a lot of
positive comments of course of Wesley's
uh Dazz win including one from our our
friend Howard ston um that uh let me
just pull it up something very flowery
so I can't really like paraphrase it you
know this dashing little game is played
by Mr so in such a vigorous and
accomplished
style so you can always count on Howard
to
to yeah flourish yeah we've got flish
we've got a fourth time US Women's
Champion Anna zatonski about today's
fight which didn't lead to any
GL yeah it wasn't dashing or flowery or
flourishing or vigorous or anything like
that it was just an oldfashioned battle
between two veterans who played each
other so many times before what were
your thoughts onor coming to the game uh
playing against a player who's really
your main rival in this
competition um I don't know like I
wanted to equalize and maybe fight for
for a win and I I think I had a good
position right later and I I I could
give him more probably problems nothing
serious
but do you look at this result I mean it
was a draw for a long long time why
didn't you but I was slightly better so
even in the bishoping pawn ending or
yeah why not my my Pawn was on B4 and
your Pawn was on F3 I know it's a
draw I know I know it's a draw but I I I
need to try why not yeah looking for
just any little Edge in the situation
yes did you did you feel the need to win
today given the circumstance ances in
the
tournament I try my best yeah of course
I I try to win and uh that's why uh uh I
was like keeping Rooks all the time I
could easily it's good be draw like 30
moves ago right yeah we know yes but I
tried to I tried hard and if she would
make some mistakes I would probably win
but she played she defended very well
position
so back to the question again did you
feel that let me ask it a different way
do you feel that a draw today is an
unsatisfying
result okay a little bit a little bit
unhappy but
uh it's it's not so
bad what are your thoughts about the
future of the tournament okay I will try
to win every single game so what what
else I should do well we expect that
fighting attitude from you all the time
yeah but you can see my every game uh my
shortest game I think was 58 moves
something like that right yeah you've
been keeping us busy for sure You'
keeping us working earning our dollars
I I I think like every almost every day
like I am asking for second score
score a tremendous Gladiator you are and
we appreciate your fighting Spirit here
at the championship thank you Anna
satony four-time Women's Champion always
fighting to The Bitter End thank you
Anna and uh for keeping us riveted in
our seats and I will try to win every
game I love that I love that answer I
like it better then I'll take it game by
game a little new and we got some poll
results um who do you think is going to
win the US Championship we asked this at
the beginning of the round so keep that
in mind when you check out these results
Fabiano Carolina the major leader in
this ball um I'm sure Wesley would have
gotten more results if we conducted it
after his sizzling Victory Nakamura fans
still a plenty and Ray Rob Wesley only
10 that was before his win though
because it was in the first like hour or
half hour of the show so I think if you
pull them now now it would probably be
like much
tighter meanwhile in the Women's
Championship um Irena crush the the
heavy leader here um and also some Naji
and some tatoo fans in fact for somebody
who keeps hashtagging us um talking
about how much he loves tat he calls her
the Blue Fairy I will tell you that the
in person you'll notice that it's a
little bit more purple than blue so
purple
fairy and speaking of purple we've got
Irina Crush she's with
Ashley yes the seven time Champion
ireena Crush after quite a bit of work
your opponent seemed to be testing you
today yeah I mean you know this line in
the opening I think it's should be a bit
better for white um I got a position I
was pretty happy with but just wasn't
sure how to make progress you know at
that point I wasn't sure what to do if
she would just be doing nothing you know
after she played I think a good move
King B8 you know uh with the idea of
Rook C8 protecting the C6 Pawn so that
every time I play B4 she takes and play
plays B5 if I may interrupt you just
briefly we saw there on the screen uh it
looked like a victory for ashria Ison as
Alyssa Melina who who you've had a
miraculous Escape against earlier has
now lost her second game in a row after
that but
continue yeah um so she made a good move
King BH he was actually quite low on
time but she found this idea to hold the
position um kind prophylaxis against my
idea of B4 and I wasn't sure how to
improve my position there so I tried to
not very fortunate maneuver Bishop uh E2
Knight D3 just you know trying to make
some moves um wasn't sure what to do and
then I actually allowed her to play C5 I
just missed that because I wasn't uh I
wasn't thinking black could do anything
in this position except just sit there
you know and it was sort of on me to
make progress which I was having trouble
doing and that move yeah I gave her a
slightly better position actually I had
to be kind of careful with this D4 move
and also take care um not to let her uh
her Bishop get too strong after run like
today you are no longer in first place
you you were tied for a moment but now
you're back again what are your thoughts
about your status in this tournament you
know I'm just focusing on my games um
there's so many rounds left to play and
um you know uh Nazi you know I'm playing
her in the last round with white so it's
good that um the people who are ahead of
you I mean you still have a chance to
play them directly you know to affect
your fate um so I feel fine um too bad I
couldn't do more with the white pieces
today but but that's the way it went uh
what are you going to do on your rest
day
rest good answer well we I will probably
take a walk in Forest Park um which I'm
probably not going to do today because
it's already quite late so Anna kept me
at the board for a while and uh that
that'll cut into my walk today um but I
do want to take a walk tomorrow if it's
a nice day it's such a beautiful Park
absolutely well enjoy thank you seven
time Champion aren Crush after a long
days
work back to you guys and we do have the
results wrapped up in the Women's
Championship now the game between Sabina
fer was a draw against AA asaran and we
also saw Alysa go down to AA gorti and
gorty now with two points so as we see
uh going into the rest day the Women's
Championship Naji pidi on top and TV
brahaman and Arena crha just behind her
very good and in the men's section
again it's the three-way tie at the top
between two very big favorites Fabiana
Wesley yes so in the uh in the overall
us CH Championship don't forget a woman
can um qualify for this tournament as
well um Grand Masters Wesley so and
Fabiano kanana sharing the lead with
four points each um Ray Robson um great
result but disappointed of course about
today's Miss with three and a half and
then um it's our defending Champion
Alexander ones and of course the a big
surprise Jeffrey Jeong all with three
points out of
five and we'll have the women's
standings after our interview um we have
Alysa melino in the studio she's with
Maurice
Ashley yes with Alyssa after a
disappointing loss to be sure Alyssa
this game was Topsy Turvy first you were
losing then it looked like you were
drawing then all of a sudden you were
losing again what were your emotions as
you were playing the
game well I thought I had um
compensation when when she gave up the
pawn and I had an opportunity to force a
Perpetual after Queen C4 Rook D4 Queen
C8 I could have went back and forth but
I tried to push really hard for a win I
thought I had a break and know sometimes
when you when you push too hard this is
what happens so I I fought back as hard
as I could after
that uh the the game you had you know
sometimes people tell a story about a
tournament and the game you had against
Arena it's it's something you want to
shake off do you feel like it's still
affecting you even now two rounds
later um it may be in the back of my
mind because you know I pushed too hard
this game and so maybe you know I felt
like I really needed to win and get back
into it when if the position calls for a
draw then that's what that's what I
should play so luckily tomorrow is the
rest day I can shake it off I can come
back recharge and start the tournament a
new we heard a young Agata say that she
had six hours of homework last night and
and more homework to do tomorrow what
will you be doing on the rest
day well not six hours of homework thank
goodness yeah done with Law School uh
fortunately my firm is um being very
hands off while I'm here so I don't have
to do too much work for them yeah but
tomorrow we'll just be about you know
getting into the proper psychology for
for the coming tournament just
relaxing um yeah just looking at you
know what I can improve on and keep
moving forward good advice well we hope
you do that well tomorrow and I'll see
you in two days thanks guys thank
you what a day what of a day Thrills and
Spills some great chess great defensive
chess great attacking chess and some
horrific Technique we are seeing it all
we get a whole smorgas Board of
different things going on in our games
speaking of smorgas boards we do have
the popup chess demo tomorrow and that's
going to be a smus m of different chess
variants including blindfold and Blitz
and bullet and your favorite yaser Bug
House yes and I'm pretty sure EET is
going to be involved in the bullet
competition a gorti getting set up for
her interview right now and here she is
she's got two points now out of five so
tough start but is starting to show her
medal she's with
Maurice well the 13-year-old like she
took gorty after a victory how does it
feel to win your first game at the US
Championship oh this is your second win
excuse me how how does it feel to get
your second win of the US Championship
uh it feels good I guess but I don't
know I thought I messed up the ending
some a little bit cuz I let the king go
to B1 I don't think I need I needed to
allow that yeah she got she had a drawn
position at that point actually oh uh
yeah I I'm not sure after Rook A7 was I
don't think she should have taken on
E6 I'm not really sure cuz after Rook A7
if it still draw yeah as long as she
keeps her Rook on the G file and don't
let your king cross over she still had
really good chances to dra yeah maybe
but then uh after I got the G it was I
think oh yeah at that point you were
definitely
winning uh yeah so I'm not really sure
what I should have done instead I I mean
I think instead of going check with my
work I should just play like King B3 and
then allowed the king to go to B1 I
realized that that the King after going
to B1 could be a draw so it's kind of
upset but then r s was like okay maybe I
can try cuz she was getting low in time
so I thought maybe she can U make make a
blender in time trouble or something so
which she did yeah that's why I was
trying to like not make um like slow
moves there at the end so I can like I
would have time to think myself so and
it worked out there worked out great for
you in fact uh in the end two wins
feeling like you're in the championship
yeah and if I have to play better next
round uh absolutely great result you got
a rest day tomorrow M what's your plan
for the rest day um not really sure I
think there's some at 6:00 there's some
to go to the Hall of Fame 6:30 at the
hall of fame but before then what do you
plan to do I know one one Agata told us
that she's doing six hours of homework
and and lots of stuff for school do you
have to worry about school right now I
no I'm not wearing at school but
probably prepare for my game the next
day you're not going to have a fro or
some yogurt some or have yeah maybe yeah
well have a little fun we hope you have
a good time congratulations on you win
today thank you the wins keep coming for
the youngsters another win uh for a
13-year-old in the championship they are
definitely definitely tough Jennifer
it's been a wonderful broadcast as usual
I enjoyed the day uh very much but it's
been a long day I'm looking forward to
the free day what are you going to do on
your free day um let's see I've got a
pack today we've got this uh this event
that I'm hosting at the World Chess Hall
of Fame so I'll be doing that and then
that's your focus working out you know
working out yeah I got to n how much do
you bench
press am I supposed to answer that yes
I'll give you an over
under uh 30 PBS oh come on that's not
even
fair
what oh I'm offended now Mar is with
a 30 lbs that's terrible yes I'm sure
asria could easily bench press 30
lb how much do you bench press do you
know no no she doesn't I didn't suspect
you did just yet well today you looked
busted yeah how did you come back in
this game um I thought I was lost
somehow but then I was like okay I'll
try to draw this and not like survive
longer and then the end game kind of
arose and I wasn't entire I thought she
was still probably winning but then she
I think she misplayed it with King H3
exactly King H3 and I wasn't sure if I
was better at some point or could have
pushed for the win but I think the end
was the draw wow that's an amazing
result for you were you when you're
suffering like that I mean it's hours of
suffering it's not like it's Blitz and
it's two minute chest you know it's over
in 10 minutes what are you thinking when
you're sitting there are you are you
thinking buckle down and fight or are
you just depressed and thinking about
the next game um I'm thinking about like
fighting and like making it harder for
her to win that's the right attitude
what are you going to do on the rest day
um I'm not sure yet but I think there's
an event in the world chest Hall of Fame
tomorrow you guys don't think about the
next day at all right you just one game
at a time but that's at 6:30 you got an
entire day to relax what what do you
plan to do with the entire rest of the
day I'm not sure yet you going to do
homework yeah I haven't started any
yet it's amazing to being in the
championship and having to do work for
school that must be strange yeah well
congratulations on your result today and
get a good rest in thanks guys thank
you let's take a look at the standings
in the Women's Championship as we go
into the rest B we've got Naji pidi um
clear first running start if you will
from the cardio Queen um T vaman and
Irena Crush just have a point behind um
Anna ditoni huge fighter wants to win
every game she's got three points I
really loved her attitude today she
seemed like in the in the beginning of
the tournament she was a little bit less
excited but right there you saw di who
is a champion and ready to uh be back
and back with Force I was better my Pawn
was one square further up the board than
the other Pawn got to love it and let's
take another look at the overall
Championship Standings um Wes liso and
Fabiano caramon tied for first Ray
Robson really should be there as well
but still hey he's still having a good
tournament and the rest day will be well
timed for him to kind of get over it and
we've got some final thoughts from mauce
ass well every single round is crazy
here at the championship so we might
want to make this up but it's just the
truth ups and downs Thrills and Spills
mistakes blunders everywhere but also
some scintillating games we saw Fabiano
do one yesterday but it was Wesley Souls
turn today with a completely dominant
win in this picture behind me right now
tells the story of how wonderfully he
played but the story of the youngsters
still continues as they're fighting like
crazy Jeffrey Jang having not lost a
single game so far and taking down four
time five time Champion gakamsky that is
clearly a story of the first half of the
tournament but guys arrest date to come
you know I should be just putting my
foot up in Wasington basketball but I
got more work to do too so we will see
you guys later I'm having fun at this
tournament for sure that's right we'll
see you on Wednesday and if you are in
St Louis um head on down to the World
Chess Hall of Fame in 6:30 and watch
some uh some bullet in some Bug House
absolutely it's been a pleasure to be
with you for this first week and we'll
see you next week this is Jen jiadi
signing off for yaser Saran Maurice
Ashley here at the St Louis chess
club
[Music]